[Musique]
messieurs bonsoir bonsoir nous vous
recevons pour une chaîne internet qui
s'appelle Serview nous sommes en direct
est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter
succintement Charles gaveave Charles
gaveave ben j'ai 80 ans je suis fils
d'officier je suis rentré après des
études d'économie que j'avais fait un
peu par hasard à Toulouse dans la
finance aussi un peu par hasard j'ai
trouvé que c'était intéressant parce
qu'il se passait des tas de choses et
j'ai essayé de comprendre pourquoi le
marché monté ou baissé depuis
50 60 ans et j'y suis toujours ça n'a
pas donc je m'intéresse au marché à la à
la formation des prix à la création de
valeur à des choses qui me semblent
essentielles dans l'économie mais pas du
tout au PIB à la balance commerciale ou
au chômage ça je me contre F c'est
peut-être votre angle mort mais on en
reparlera pierre Larou Tourou bonsoir
pierre Larou Tourou ingénieur agronome
je suis engagé depuis très longtemps
dans la lutte contre la précarité contre
le chômage pour moi c'est un sujet très
important contre la pauvreté sur les
problèmes de mallogement de d'échec
Scola euh depuis plus de 10 ans
maintenant je travaille sur les
questions de climat avec le grand
climatologue jean-jousel et et depuis 5
ans je suis député européen et là je
suis tête de liste d'une liste qui
s'appelle changer l'Europe parce qu'on
pense qu'il est urgent urgentissime de
changer l'Europe et je dois dire que
j'ai hésité à accepter ce débat quand
vous l'avez proposé euh je suis un homme
vraiment ouvert à plein de débats mais
certaines de vos déclarations sur
Pinochet ou votre soutien à Zemour ou à
l'extrême droite j'ai beaucoup beaucoup
hésité pour moi les chambres à gaz ce
n'est pas un détail de l'histoire pour
moi c'est juste une horreur et donc vous
ayez
soutenu mais le fondateur du Front
national pardon le front pardon vous
avez aidé financièrement des gens
d'extrême droite voilà donc j'ai
beaucoup hésité mais je sais que c'estvw
vous aurz invité de toute façon et je me
dis au lieu de vous laisser la parole il
y a des foisù vous posez des bonnes
questions mais souvent vos réponses sont
totalement fausses ou alors bon donc
j'ai hésité mais je me dis que c'est
peut-être bien d'avoir un contradicteur
pour ne pas laisser croire que ce que
vous racontez toujours vrai mais euh
voilà en général je suis content de
venir ici mais là il y avait quand même
ce bémol on peut pas dire n'importe quoi
j'arrive du Parlement européen l'Europe
s'est construit parce qu'il y avait eu
30 millions de morts et on s'est dit
plus jamais ça et les ceux qui cherch
j'ai Bou émissaires ceux qui disent que
l'immigré l'arabe le juif et la cause de
nos problèmes ont amené à la barbarie
donc financer des gens d'extrême droite
c'est quand même quelque chose de très
grave à mes yeux mais maintenant je suis
ici et je pense qu'on va avoir un débat
utile donc on est content de vous avoir
reç de vous recevoir tous les deux pour
pouvoir échanger dans le calme Charles
vous voulez dire quelque chose ce que ce
qu'a dit Pierre euh si vous voulez le
libéral par définition si vous voulez
quand on lui propose un débat il
l'accepte il met pas de conditions il
porte pas de jugement sur les gens avec
qui va débattre qui se trompe et qui ont
amené la France dans le désastre
européen qu'on connaitt tous les jours
donc je jeessis simplement de dire c'est
que je connaissais pas monsieur la
roserou
euh voilà je le connaissais pas et donc
on m'a dit c'est un homme de gauche et
tout j'ai dis qu'est-ce que vous voulez
que ça me foute et donc je lui il a des
à prioris moraux dans la discussion moi
j'en ai aucun j'ai dis si cet homme a
quelque chose à dire qu'il le dise on
l'écoutera et on laissera les les
téléspectateurs décider qu'il y a raison
ou qui a tort mais ce que je voudrais
dire un peu ce qui a très étonnant dans
la situ dans la civilisation dans
laquelle on rentre c'est que aujourd'hui
des gens qui sont dans le métier de
réfléchir
paraît-il disent queil y a ce qui est
plus de réfléchir c'est plus de savoir
comment le monde fonctionne comment
l'améliorer mais c'est de porter un
jugement moral sur lui par exemple pour
la première fois de ma vie moi je suis
formation aristotélicienne l'économie
c'est une branche de la logique c'est
pas une branche des mathématiques ou de
l'astrologie c'est une branche de la
logique et donc aujourd'hui quand je dis
des faits comme par exemple que l'Europe
est en train de tuer la France qui est
un fait on me dit c'est un fait de c'est
un fait de droite c'est la première fois
dans ma vie qu'on me dit il y a des
faits de gauche et des fait de droite
c'està-dire qu'aujourd'hui on est passé
vous savez dans la vieille discussion
grecque vous avez le Logos le pathos et
l'thos c'estàd la logique l'éthique et
le sentiment aujourd'hui on me fait
couler toute la journée le sentiment
c'est horrible vous avez donné de
l'argent à zmour mais comment vous
pouvez faire une mon contre fou je fais
ce que je veux avec mon fric et
j'autorise personne je apporter un
jugement sur ce que je fais de mon fric
et s pas discuter avec moi qui viennent
pas mais ça m complètement égal on va
discuter parce que on sait faire des
commencer dès le départ par un truc qui
me dit vous êtes immoral parce que vous
avez de bonnes Mours c'est le niveau
zéro de la discussion bon les choses
sont dites merci on peut que progresser
du coup oui parce que vous partez très
bas gars les gars les gars les gar juste
pardon j'arrive du Parlement je pass
mant à parler avec tout le monde sauf
l'extrême droite je suis rapport pardon
sont des citoyens comme les autres alors
si si Front national arrive à 51% des h
qu'est-ce que vous faites excusez-moi
mais encore une fois un parti qui a été
créé par quelqu'un qui ricanait sur les
les chambres à gaz sur les les camp de
concentration pour moi il y a plein
d'options qui sont débattues je prétends
pas avoir la vérité révélée je passe mon
temps à dialoguer avec des gens
différents des gens de droite de gauche
des gens voilà voilà quand vous êtes au
Parlement européen vous êtes obligé on
m'a demandé d'être rapporteur général du
budget c'est moi qui a négocié les 160
milliards du budget de l'Europe je suis
très critique sur le fonctionnement de
l'Europe peut-être qu'on aura des points
de convergence je pense que l'Europe si
on demande de changer l'Europe c'est qu'
on est très critique mais voilà ça n'est
pas banal des gens qui ricanent ou
l'autre qui se moquait en demandant le
paysan qui s'est suicidé est-ce qu'il
s'est pissé dessus est-ce que sa corde
était française ben un paysan qui se
suicide ça n'est pas drôle voilà moi
j'ai fait la gros et je pense
régulièrement à cette femme qui s'est
suicidé dans sa salle de traite parce
que on avait mis en place une Europe qui
protégeit le revenu des paysans et les
gens de droite ont supprimé et
aujourd'hui il y a des pays su pas drô
pour mais ça bien tendu c'est pas drôle
mais vous rendez compte que depuis qu'on
a commencé cette conversation vous êtes
dans un Patos total pas Patos mais vous
êtes en train de pleurer sur les des
gens des sentiments
je mais les communistes ont fait 100
millions de morts et pourtant vous
discuter avec des communistes toute la
journée ils ont fait 100 million de
morts donc si vous voulez dire B je
parle pas avec Stine AEL vous parlez
avec St non pas du
tout demand comment vous avez a la
gauche disc avec des communistes
marchardien allez on va commencer
c'est pas je je vous demande de faire
non mais ne commençons pas sur le Patos
s'il vous plaît on commence pas sur le
Patos bon mais qu'il arrête ces espèces
de trucs d'appel à la bonté humaine ça
me fatigue donc je vous demande
d'échanger un
é ça été dit je compte vous faire la
première question est-ce que vous sentez
chacun un choc économique venir ù dans
le monde peut-être à gauche à droite en
Europe aux États-Unis en Asie quel est
votre des ches ben écoutez c'est tout
simple j'imagine que si vous parlez
d'che économique c'est vous parlez d'une
crise en
Chine chinois puisque j'ai passé un
certain nombre d'années à Hong Kong et
en Chine le
CLE crise et le cycle opportunité c'est
le même donc il est tout à fait évident
que l'Union soviétique a fini par
crever sous le poids des réglementations
et du fait que la philosophie était
fausse c'est-à-dire que toutes leur
logos était faux la
socialdémocratie va crever de la même
façon et nous allons avoir une chute qui
correspondra à celle de l'Union
soviétique et ça sera une opportunité
extraordinaire pour ceux qui aiment la
liberté et non pas les Petits Hommes
Gris c'est-à-dire que ça fait 50 ans
qu'on est gouverné par des Petits Hommes
Gris qui m'empêche de travailler qui
m'empêche de bouger qui m'empêche de
prendre des initiatives et je dis
simplement le la caractéristique de
l'humain c'est d'être libre et ces
gens-là ne pensent qu'à m'empêcher de
bouger et je dis simplement oui il va
avoir une crise et oui il vaut mieux la
fin dans l'horreur qu'une horreur sans
fin c'est un proverbe allemement qui
sont des spécialistes de la chose donc
je dis j'appelle cette crise de tous mes
vœux parce que ça sera la fin de la
dictature des crétins sur les gens
intelligents ce que disait stevski qui
était une phrase magnifique il
disait de façon tout à fait pressciante
il disait nous rentrons dans une période
où les gens intelligents devront se
taire de peur de fâcher les crétins nous
y sommes aujourd'hui les gens
intelligents doivent se taire parce que
les crrétins ne supportent pas dans leur
dans leur pauvre petit Patos que les
gens intelligent parle et ben j'en ai
marre je dis simplement foutez-moi la
paix avec vre Patos ça ne m'intéresse
pas ce que je veux c'est qu'une économie
où chaque homme soit libre et chaque
personne soit libre pas qu'elle soit
obéissante voilà
donc on va vers une crise et c'est une
bonne nouvelle est-ce que est-ce que
l'inertie de ce que vous ce que vous
percevez comme trop de contrôle trop de
de réglementation est-ce que cette
inertie ce choc qui arrive connaissez le
le le choc inertiel oui est-ce que ça va
pas être la dernière fois que le le chat
mort rebondit mais le chat
rebondit vous savez on vit dans un monde
qui se croit encore dominé par le monde
occidental si j'ai passé du temps en
Asie parce que je suis parti il y avait
un temps en Asie parce que je me disais
que tout allait se passer là-bas donc ça
m'intéressait de voir comment ça se
passait et maintenant il est tout à fait
évident que toute la croissance du monde
va se passer dans un endroit qui partira
à peu près de la Crimée qui descendra au
travers de la Turquie qui passera
ensuite en Syrie puis en Irak l'Iran
au-dessus puis vous toucherz
le Pakistan vous arriverez en Inde et ça
va être le boom de l'océan Indien comme
le monde n'a jamais connu de Boom
c'està-dire qu'il va y avoir un boom
dans l'Anci indien inimaginable un boom
de migration un boom un boom de
croissance un boom de croissance parce
que simplement ils sont en train de
développer leur système économique de
façon géniale ils sont ils sont en train
d'arriver à un système concurrentiel ils
sont en train deouvrir sur le monde et
c'est là où la moitié à peu près des
forces de travail qui existont dans 20
ans sont en train d'être formé
aujourd'hui parce que la démographie se
pète la gueule partout ailleurs partout
ailleurs sauf ses jeux donc le les 30
ans qui viennent appartiendront à l'Inde
et cette Inde qui est extraordinairement
créative on a réussi à se couper de tous
les liens avec
eux puisque ben si vous voulez par
exemple on a plus
d'énergie le lien normal c'était entre
l'Allemagne et la et la Russie de façon
à ce que d'un côté il y a les matières
premières de l'autre côté il a le
l'industrie de l'Europe et qui aurait pu
faire mais à partir du moment où on
coupe le lien entre l'énergie russe et
l'économie allemande comme l'économie ça
n'est que de l'énergie transformée si on
a plus d'énergie donc l'Europe est en
train de devenir un peu comme Venise
comm Amsterdam a commencé on va devenir
un un mouroir tranquille où des gens
viendront
visiter nos cathédrales et comme on
était grand en 1250 mais c'est fini
pierre est-ce qu' on va vers une crise
majeure la réponse est oui hélas oui et
moi je ne m'en réjouis pas du tout parce
que ça peut faire très très très mal je
me souviens c'est Ken rogof l'ancien
chef économiste du FMI qui y a quelques
années avait cette formule en disant les
systèmes tiennent souvent plus longtemps
qu'on le pense mais ils finissent par
s'effondrer beaucoup plus vite qu'on
l'imagine les systèmes tiennent plus
longtemps qu'on le pense mais quand ça
pète ça s'effondre plus vite qu'on
l'imagine il parlait du système
financier je vais l'expliquer parce
qu'on a rien réglé après la crise
finance la crise financière les lobby
ont tout tout bloqué mais là c'est c'est
vrai aussi pour notre système
alimentaire à cause de la crise
climatique de notre système démocratique
de notre système social donc oui je
crains qu' à force de mettre des rutines
à force d'accumuler les bêtises pour
être poli depuis 40 ans tout ça peut
très mal finir pourquoi je suis persuadé
qu'on va faire une nouvelle crise en
2005 j'étais un des rares qui avait
annoncé la première crise financière je
me souviens Dominique schrotkan se
foutait de ma gueule j'ai fait un
article dans le monde qui montrait
comment la dette aux États-Unis a
augmenté le taux d'épargne était négatif
et schroskan se foutis de ma gueule en
disant qu'il y avait aucun risque de
crise un are vocabulaire non plus tard
un an plus tard la crise seule pas m'a
éclaté cette coure je sais pas si on la
voit je l'ai fait pour venir vous voir
c'est juste les chiffres de la Réserve
fédérale aux États-Unis tous les 3 mois
il y a la dette totale la dette des
familles la dette des entreprises la
dette on voit que la dette vous voyez a
augmenté de façon considérable quand la
crise financière la première avait
éclaté il a en 2007 on était un peu plus
de 30000 milliards de dettes 30 bouger
je arrête de bouger je veux qu'
cameraman 3000 milliards et là on est à
plus de 75000 voilà l'an dernier la
dette totale aux États-Unis privée et
publique a augmenté de 13 % du PIB donc
le modèle des libéraux les États-Unis
c'est vrai qu'il y a une croissance très
forte il y a des choses très bien ils
ont une politique industrielle ce que
nous on n'est pas capable de faire en
Europe ils ont mis en place des des des
projets pour les infrastructures il y a
des choses très bien mais quand il y a
besoin de 13 % de dett pour avoir une
croissance à 2 % c'est un peu comme si
votre voiture avait besoin de 3 l
d'huile tous les 200 m elle tourne
encore mais s'il faut mettre autant
d'huile c'est que ça peut péter
n'importe quand donc ça c'est la dette
aux États-Unis jamais roulé avec une
Honda en rodage bon et l'autre et
l'autre l'autre moteur de l'économie
mondiale c'est la la Chine voilà où
c'est encore pire la dette totale
explose sans compter le shadow banking
les crédits qu'on met pas dans les
livres à la Une du Figaro il y a 3 ans
il y avait un village chinois sofre un
immeuble plus grand que la tour effffel
c'est la plus grosse bulle immobilière
qu'on a jamais vu la Chine vous avez
aimé la crise des subpre vous avez aimé
la bulle en Espagne la donc les deux
moteurs de l'économie mondiale peuvent
péter n'importe quand comme on ne sait
jamais à quel moment on sait jamais quel
est le grain de sable qui va faire
dérailler la machine oui et donc je en
2005 on ricané quon était quelques-uns a
annoncé la crise mais là c'est le FMI
qui est à la Une des échos qui dit on n
rien réglé depuis la crise première
crise financière et le FMI dit que la
prochaine crise peut être 10 fois plus
grave 10 la phrase qui était reprise
dans les échos c'est la prochaine crise
peut être 10 fois plus grave que la
première crise financière donc on avait
dit après la crise financière qu'on
allait faire la séparation des banques
pour casser la spéculation qu'on allait
réguler le secteur financier en fait on
a rien fait et ça peut péter n'importe
quand et je reviendrai après ça sur les
analyses c'est pas la crise de la social
démocratie quand Monsieur G explique on
va s'effondrer c'est le modèle libéral
au contraire la dette c'est intéressant
de voir comment la dette aux États-Unis
je pe je peux vous demander quelque
chosey pour détendre j'aimerais que vous
vous appeliez avec votre autorisation
par vos prénom oui Charles Charles
pierre pierre Charles est-ce que tu veux
rebondir là-dessus ben si tu veux c'est
un petit peu
le c'est une telle tarte à la crème ça
fait tellement longtemps que je
l'entends ça fait tellement que c'est
longtemps que ces gens ont tort que je
me dis toujours par où commencer pour
essayer de montrer qu'il se trompe
surtout et depuis toujours et donc je
voudrais je voudrais dire un truc tout
simple c'est
d'où d'abord comment tu te sens Charles
ça va je me sens très bien c'est
j'essaie de réfléchir si tu veux parce
que j'ai perdu
l'habitude de raisonner avec des gens
qui raisonnent comme on raisonnait en
1945 c'est juste regarder la réalité
Paron c'est juste les chiffres de la
Réserve fédérale sur la dette oui mais
si vous voulez si vous donnez des
chiffres de la Réserve fédérale sur la
dette il faut donner aussi les chiffres
de la France de la France et les
chiffres des donc on peut pas donner des
chiffres de façon sélective ça ve rien
dire pi pierre donc donc essayons donc
je vais essayer de résumer un petit peu
ce que je voudrais dire de façon à faire
comprendre où je veux venir je veux en
venir
bien je retourne un peu en arrière et je
dis simplement
ceci qu'est-ce que c'est qu'être libéral
êre libéral c'est laisser les gens
décider par eux-mêmes de ce qu'ils vont
faire de leur vie et comment ça se
traduit politiquement c'est apparu aux
alentours du 17e anglais avec un homme
qui s'appelait Lock qui était un grand
penseur et qui disait
simplement pour que chacun devienne
indépendant quel est l'ennemi naturel de
chaque être humain c'est son état
puisqu'il a le monopole de la violence
légitime il peut me mettre en prison il
peut me tuer et cetera donc toute la
pensée libérale à partir du 17e ça a été
de dire l'ennemi de chaque homme c'est
son état mais on a besoin d'un état donc
il faut le contraindre par la loi c'est
c'est l'idée numéro 1 c'est-à-dire il
faut que la loi soit votée par les
citoyens représentation il faut que le
budget soit voté par les citoyens il
faut que on un pouvoir d'appel contre
les citoyens et il faut que l'économie
soit laissée dans les mains des
particuliers et l'État doit s'occuper
des quatre fonctions raliiennes parce
qu'il peut pas y avoir de marché
là-dedans qui sont la justice la police
la
diplomatie
et et voilà et donc aujourd'hui vous
avez un monde où depuis à peu près 70
ans les pouvoirs de l' individ ne
cessent de baisser les pouvoirs des
États ne cessent de monter et on est en
train de rentrer dans une espèce de
dictature de la norme une
dictature absolument extraordinaire où
j'ai plus le droit de faire ce que je
veux je vous donne un exemple par
exemple dans la gestion de votre épargne
mettons vous dégageiez une épargne on va
vous forcer à investir selon des
critères qui seront ceux de du moment
allez que par exemple on réchauffe la pe
se faire en admettant qu' ou un effort
de guerre ou un effort de guerre
n'importe quoi et donc aujourd'hui je
n'ai plus le droit d'investir mon effort
comme je le veux les fonds de pension
n'ont plus le droit donc l'épargne est
dirigée par les États pour des choses
qui favorisent les états alors
qu'autrefois l'épargne c'était le socle
de la déépendance de chaque individu
donc ce que j'essaie de dire c'est que N
nos libertés sont en train d'être bouffé
partout que je suis infiniment moins
libre que mon père infiniment moins
libre que mon grand-père et que mon
arrière
grand-père et le le libéralisme c'est
simplement dire aux gens laisser l'État
dans ce qu'il doit faire mais interdis
d'aller dans les endroits où il n'a rien
à faire et c'est ça qui très libéral et
aujourd'hui ce que j'essaie de dire aux
gens c'est vous ne pouvez plus bouger
sans demander la permission d'aller
faire pipi c'est extraordinaire ce qui
se passe dans le monde à quel point nous
sommes avons des réglementations
tatillones exemples bah je sais pas très
facilement par exemple si tu as un fond
de pension français tu peux pas tu es
obligé de mettre 50 % en épargne en
obligation de l'État français qui est en
état de quasi faillite et ben c'est un
scandale si tu pourquoi je vous vous
force acheter des obligations qui valent
rien donc je sais qu'elle ne valent rien
qu'est- quel est le droit de l'État de
me forcer déjà il prennent des impôts
mais quel est le droit droit de l'État
d'acheter ses saloperies donc ce que
j'essaie de dire c'est que la seule
chance qu'on ait c'est de retourner à
plus de liberté et pour ça il faut aller
vers la démocratie directe à la Suisse
que ce soit pas des Cornaux qui prennent
les décisions mais que ce soit les
Suisses qui décident de ce qu'ils
veulent ou ce qu'ils veulent pas les
Suisses ils votent surtout j'ai pas
besoin d'un corps politique qui trahit
aujourd'hui si vous voulez les
socialistes ils arrivent au pouvoir P
ils me nationalisent tout ils foutent
l'économie Fran en l'air puis ensuite
les autres après il libéralisent tout
ils refoutent l'économie en l'air mais
foutez la paix aux gens laissez les gens
s'occuper de la police de l'armée de la
magistrature dans l'état et foutter la
paix aux gens S et de la santé et la la
santé elle peut tout à fait d'organ par
des des associations privé je veux dire
il y a des tas de pays où la sécurité
sociale existe pas où tu t'assures et ça
te coûte beaucoup moins cher et ça à
tout le monde beaucoup moins cher donc
il y a des gens tu as déjà été dans un
hôpital aux États-Unis ou en Angleterre
en Angleterre j'ai vécu 25 ans alors
merci bien je connais tu jamais malade
si si j' j'ai étis malade ça m'est
arrivé j'ai même été profondément malade
làdessus sur la
santé va pas commencer à parler de la
santé parce c'est stop stop St alors je
vous demande je vouser je demand une
chose c'est tu demandes à ton voisin
s'il a terminé et je demande à Charles
de faireose terminé donc je vais essayer
de résumer tranquillement ce que
j'essaie de dire ce qui est tout à fait
étonnant c'est que le but d'un homme
c'est d'être
libre libre de faire ce qu'il veut dans
le cadre de la loi
et c'est pas d'être un esclave à qui on
impose des choses qu'il a pas envie de
faire et par exemple aujourd'hui en
France
ben je crois qu'il doit y avoir à peu
près 60 % de mes consommations qui sont
dirigé par l'État je pay une sécurité
sociale je pourrais en avoir une
indépendante qui pour qui pourrait me
coûter moins cher et si il faut aider à
la à la solidarité nationale à ce
momentl on paye des impôts qui vend à la
sécurité sociale donc si vous voulez il
y a toute une série de choses qui se
passe dans le monde aujourd'hui qui nous
amène à devenir des espèces de sujets de
gens qui savent tout et qui s'occupent
de nous c'est la fin on n plus dans un
régime démocratique on est dans un
régime de
clientèle et c'est très
curieux parce que les gens le sentent
très bien et ils sont malheureux on
n'est pas heureux si on n'est pas libre
est-ce que tu peux donner la parole à
ton voisin c'est fait pierre alors juste
sur la question de la santé quand même
pardon comme avant de savoir si je
j'accepis ce débat j'ai regardé votre
dernierre sview vous avez déjà parlé de
la question j'ai regardé aujourd'hui les
chiffres de CDE le coût de la santé
rapporté par par pour chaque personne
aux États-Unis est de 12000 un peu plus
de 12500 dollars par année 12500 chez
nous en France c'est exactement la
moitié donc nous dire que notre système
coûte trop cher en france on est à 6600
6600 aux États-Unis sont à 125 j'ai pas
dit qu'il coûtait trop cher ah bah si si
pardant vous l'avez dit par contre
l'Espérance Dee et l'espérance de vie
par contre est beaucoup plus courte aux
États-Unis ils mettent globalement
globalement deux fois plus cher mais il
y a des millions d'Américains malgré les
progrès d'Obama qui n'yont pas accès
mais et l'espérance de vie chez nous en
moyenne est à 82 ans aux États-Unis
seulement à 76 ans parce que leur
système ok c'est pas par des cotisations
la plupart des gens doivent mettre leur
argent privé la moitié plus de la moitié
de la dépense de santé c'est à titre
perso si tu as pas d'argent tu peux pas
le mettre et les autres dépensent encore
plus mais donc en tout cas le système
globalement le système de santé
américain coûte deux fois plus cher
l'espérance de vie est 6 ans plus courte
et le nombre de lit par habitant il y a
deux fois plus de lit d'hôpitaux par
habitant en France qu'aux États-Unis
voilà et je remarque il y avait un
libéral très connu a 20 ans sur France
Inter Jean-Marc Sylvestre les plus
anciens s'en souviennent qui a passé sa
vie à critiquer les cotisations sociales
les coation il est survivant mais il
n'est plus sur France Inter terme il y a
une époqueù il était très connu et en
2003 il a fait un texte assez émouvant
pour dire ces cotisations sociales m'ont
sauvé la vie voilà il dit j'ai eu un
petit problème je suis à l'hôpital
petite douleur à l'épaule finalement il
faut faire une opération du cœur à cœur
ouvert il dit j'ai eu les meilleurs
infirmiersr infirmières les meilleurs
médecins les meilleurs antibiotiques les
meilleurs les examens on n pas compté et
en France qu'on soit SDF ou on soit
journaliste connu ou Tartempion vous
avez droit aux meilleurs antibiotiques
au meilleurs mais il dit au total ça
coûte 250000 je fin par pas si vrai que
ça dis pas y a sans doute des progrs à
faire et h là avec toutes les réformes
de la santé je sais pas comment le
système tient encore je dis pas que tout
est parfait on est en train de [__] en
l'IR notre système de santé on va on a
pas le temps mais juste Jean dire que tu
finis tu auras toujours le temps de
finir ICICI Jean-Marc Sylvestre qui
avait passé son temps pendant 20 ans à
critiquer les cotisations les
cotisations écrit ces cotisations
sociales m'ont sauvé la vie le coût
total c'est de mon de mon passage à
l'hôpital c'est 250000 € aux États-Unis
j'aurais dû vendre ma maison voilà donc
le modèle américain je je reprendre tu
connais pas sa maison je je pas sa
maison alors quand monsieur quand
Charles GAB nous explique que c'est à
cause des socio-démocrates que y a que
il y a cette cette dette voilà j'ai fait
je pensais bien que vous arrivz avec cet
argument donc j'ai apporté un deuxième
graphique c'est aussi la dette aux
États-Unis rapporté au PIB il est encore
plus clair on voit que tant qu'on tenait
bon sur les idées de Roosevelt sur le
besoin de justice sociale non pas un
système soviétique Roosevelt disait il
faut garder la capacité d'initiative du
capitalisme mais avec des règles
sociales des règles sur le temps de
travail sur le salaire minimum pendant
30 ans il y a eu aucune crise financière
aucune crise financière il n'y avait pas
besoin de dette ni privée ni publque
quelle année ça commence à par ça
commence à 1952 voilà OK et puis après
c'est à partir de l'arrivée de Ronald
Rean les libéraux vos amis vos demidieux
Rean qu'on commence à avoir besoin de
toujours je dis pas je dis pas que les
communistes étaient de vos amis don non
mais pardon vous avez expliqué que le
libéralisme pardon vous avez expliqué
qu'on était plus libre pardon vous avez
je vous ai laissé parler ce qui est
normal on a le temps ici c'est un
plaisir mais vous avez expliqué en gros
que c'était la faillite de la
social-démocratie et que le libéralisme
était la solution ou alors je n'ai rien
compris à ce que libér de mais pardon
c'est juste que on peut la situation est
pardon le chômage il y a 15000 personnes
qui meurent chaque année du chômage en
France vous avez dit dans votre
présentation que ça ne vous intéressez
pas je respecte votre liberté si vous
l'avez dit on pourra le regarder vous
l'avez dit justement et moi j'ai au
contraire rag dis que c'était un de mes
sujets de préoccupation et de combat
mais je respecte votre liberté on est je
suis aussi de clonage humain et
simplement le le ces questions donc pour
on voit que c'est très clair sur cette
courve tant qu'on tenait bon sur des
règles sociales il y avait la capacité
d'initiative du capitalisme il y avait
une économie bien florissante mais il y
avait pas besoin de dettes pourer le
système et c'est à partir de la r la
date là c'est 1980 1980 et là
l'inflation était à 20 % aux États-Unis
par la det totale non non mais moi je
vous parle de l'inflation les prix les
TR pr ha de 20 % parce que vous montrez
la dette vous montrez vous montrez pas
le faitentre
là je dis je dis simplement que
l'inflation était à 2 % et là elle était
à 20 ok mais les revenus depuis pardon
l'inflation au États-Unis était plus
faible qu'en Europe ils ont quand même
augmenté la dette de 13 % du PIB pardon
comme c'est le calcul ratio dett total
sur PIB l'inflation n'est pas en jeu
donc pourquoi est-ceil y a besoin de
toujours plus de dettes depuis que les
libéraux justement sont arrivé qu'est-ce
qui a changé radicalement entre l'époque
où on respectait les règles sociales et
ben c'est justement que le travail ne
paye plus j'étais l'autre jour avec les
agriculteurs qui sont venus
en ben si ça permet de ça j'aurais pu
amener les miens t téléphone hein tu as
ton téléphone non non mais je v pas
mettre sur mon tphone mais ça je peux
répondre à ces questions sans avoir s
problème compris quand les agriculteurs
en colère sont arrivés le jour moi j'ai
fait la gros ça m'intéresse depuis très
longtemps et je leur ai dit qu'ils
avaient raison d'être en colère cette
courbe ça la courbe en rouge c'est ce
que paye monsieur et madame tout le
monde quand achè des produits agricoles
la courbe en bleu c'est ce qui va au
revenu des paysans pierre je te coupe
une seconde pierre est commun du fait de
venir avec ses sources parce que
j'embête tout le monde ici avec ses
sources person aura pu amener les mienes
mais ça c'est pas la questionsends char
il y a deux personnes qui viennent ici
comme ça
c'est député de la Somme qui s'appelle
François Ruffin et Pierre larouto laisse
terminer pierre je te donne la parole
suite après ok TR bien de l je déteste
le mensonge donc je donne toujours mes
sources donc c'est juste pour montrer
que ce que j'ai dit aux agriculteurs
c'est que pendant très longtemps
l'Europe a protégé le revenu des paysans
il y avait quasiment aucune différence
entre l'évolution de ce que paye
Monsieur Madame monde et l'évolution du
agriculteur et puis ce sont c'est la
révolution libérale Margaret Thatcher
Ronald Regan qui disent qu'on va laisser
libre oh là là on va laisser libre les
gens vont être libres et quelle est la
liberté quand il y a 3000 agriculteurs
qui essaient de vendre à un seul
industriel l'industriel leur dit si tu
me vends pas tu vas te voir ailleurs tu
ton lait tu le fous dans le dans le dans
le torrent et donc la liberté que vous
proposez elle fait qu'en fait les prix
donnés aux agriculteurs s'effondrent et
que les grands les fabricants
d'industrie s'en mettent pain les poches
et les agriculteurs ça permis de mettre
le zoom sur cette question mais ça n'est
pas une exception don graphique à
Charles non mais moi j'aurais pu amener
les mien c'est dommage on avait le droit
si tu veuxais pas je pensais qu'on
allait parler pas qu'on allait monter
des trucs qui étai parce que pour
expliquer les bienfaits du libéralisme
j'aimerais avoir une coupe qui montre
les bienfait du libéralisme une le
revenu disponible par habitants dans le
monde qui ont choisi les pays libéraux
plutôt que les pays socialistes alors je
on va y revenir si vous voulez simple je
montraer comment pourquoi il y a besoin
de pourquoi notre système peut
s'effondrer c'est parce qu'on a oublié
la dignité humaine et la valeur du
travail j'ai montré avec l'exemple des
agriculteurs pendant très longtemps on a
protégé le reven agriculteurs et puis la
révolution libérale on le fout en l'air
et ça c'est pour l'ensemble des salariés
monsieur et madame tout le monde dans
les 15 pays les plus riches de la
planète l'Allemagne la France le Japon
et la courbe en rouge c'est pour les 15
pays les plus riches de la planète ceux
qui allaient au salairire salaire et
cotisation de CQ pour les retraites pour
la maladie c'était 67 % du PIB il y a 30
ans 67 % du PIB et puis on a supprimé
des règles avant il y avait des règles
qui fait qu'il y avait des conventions
collectives Roosevelt avait dit il faut
des règles pour que le salaire progresse
comme la productivité les libéraux ont
expliqué tout ça c'est de la connerie on
va négocier librement son salaire et
c'est quoi la liberté quand il y a 3
millions de chômeurs la plupart des
salariés la négociation c'est si tu es
pas content tu peux aller voir ailleurs
donc globalement et je finis dans non
c'est quand même important d'essayer de
comprendre c'est donc globalement c'est
un calcul qu'on a fait avec Michel
Rocard qui n'est pas un grand gauchiste
pour l'ensemble des pays occidentaux ce
qui va au au salaire et au quotisationc
à 67 % on est tombé c'est une baisse
considérable c'est 57 % et donc la
croissance aurait dû s'effondrer quand
il y a monsieur et madame tout le monde
qui a de moins en moins d'argent et donc
on pousse les gens à s'endetter en
disant tu as pas eu d'augmentation tu as
pas eu d'augmentation mais on va te
prêter tu vas quand même pouvoir acheter
une voiture ce qu'on donne pas par le
salaire on le donne par la dette privée
et c'est des sommes colossales qui sont
partis au B c'est quoi les source de la
source du dernier graphique Eurostat
pardon là
c'est c'est l'OCDE OCDE pour les 15 pays
les plus riches et celle et celle
d'avant OCDE aussi pardon ça c'est juste
on a simplifié là on a Monte la
diversité il y a h pays la courbe en
rouge et la moyenne vient des 15 pays
les plus riches de l'OCDE voilà et donc
ce sont des sommes donc premier point il
faut pousser les gens à s'endetter parce
que sinon la consommation devrait
s'effondré donc on va dire tu as pas
d'augmentation mais je vais te prêter de
l'argent pour acheter un appartement et
puis ce sont des sommes colossales qui
sont partis vers les marchés financiers
donc monsieur peut-être vous êtes très
doué pour faire encore plus de bénéfices
que la moyenne mais effectivement
Charles oui j'ai pas forcément envie de
de voilà mais donc oui donc ce sont des
somme colossal qui aurait dû aller au
salariés à monsieur madame tout le monde
au cais de CQ pour financer les
retraites et l'hôpital et qui sont par
les marchés financiers donc les marchés
financiers se goinfent et il y en a qui
il y en a qui se gaffent pendant qu'il y
en a qui souffrent est-ce que tu peux
donner la parole à ton voisin qui
s'appelle Charles je lui donne Charles
gaz à vous écoutez euh moi je vais vous
raconter une histoire qui est beaucoup
plus simple c'est que finalement vous
venez de me tenir un très très très joli
discours où
le comment dire le la répartition a été
parfaitement injuste depuis des siècles
et que on pie les pauvres gens mais je
veux pas parler de ça parce que c'est
pas des sujets intéressants mais ce qui
est très étonnant c'est pas non parce
que c'est faux c'est c'est ce qui est
très étonnant si vous voulez c'est que
par exemple quand vous réfléchissez à ce
que vous dites vous prenez un pays comme
la France et vous vous rendez compte
qu'il y a une espèce d'injustice qui
s'est passé en France depuis très
longtemps vous avez un secteur privé qui
est soumis à toutes les tempêtes et un
secteur public qui est archi protégé et
ce secteur public archi protégé c'est
lui qui fait la pluie le ban puisqueen
France si j'ose dire ceux qui sont élus
représentent le secteur public et pas
tellement le secteur privé donc ce que
j'essaie de dire si vous voulez c'est
que si vous laissez les marchés libres
les gens trouvent leur équilibre non
mais dans quel pays magique ça il a pas
fini de parler dans sais pas vous avez
des pays vous avez beaucoup de pays qui
sont des pays libres et où je prends un
exemple qui est assez simple si vous
voulez vous
regardez quelque chose comme
la répartition du capital la répartition
du revenu entre le capital capital et le
travail et bien dans un pays
comme la France ça fait à peu près 60
ans
que dérive constante qui va de la
rentabilité du capital vers la
rentabilité du travail pardon mais c'est
tout à fait exact mais on peut pas dire
ça s tu laisses terminer il te rend la
parole et ensuite tu re je dis
simplement c'est que la part travail n'a
cessé d'augmenter et ce qui est très
étonnant c'est que du coup les
entreprises françaises ferment et vont
se mettre à l'étranger où ça marche
mieux parce qu'elles sont elles ont pas
les mêmes contraintes
donc je suis un petit peu embêé parce
que la réalité c'est que le poids de
quand vous avez une relation absolument
parfaite dans tous les pays que j'ai
suivi partout entre quand le poids de
l'état de l'économie augmente le chômage
augmente puisque vous avait de plus en
plus du capital disponible qui est fait
par l'État et qui est fait de façon non
concurrentielle donc vous voyez ça dans
chaque pays du monde et donc en France
on est maintenant je crois sans doute un
des plus haut jamais historiques du
poids de l'État dans l'économie on doit
être aux alentours de 60 % du PIB on a
des déficits budgétaires qui sont tout à
fait
considérables nos systèmes éducatifs et
de santé sont en train de partir à volau
et la concurrence n'est plus ce qu'elle
été et nos écoles ne sont plus ce
qu'elles étai donc vous êtes en train de
me montrer des graphiques j'aurais pu
vous amener le mieux je savais pas qu'on
avait le droit c'est bien dommage mais
ce que je veux dire c'est
que vous avez une réalité qui est toute
simple c'est que si vous voulez laisser
les gens libres en général ça marche si
vous les laissez pas libre ça marche pas
et aujourd'hui quand je regarde l'Europe
d'aujourd'hui vous pouvez pas vous
empêcher de penser que le poids de
l'État est absolument inimaginable que
nous perdons des positions
internationales dans tous les domaines
que plus rien n'est inventé en Europe
qui a été quand même la mire de toutes
les inventions c'est le continent toutes
les inventions sont passées au moin
jourdhui elles se passe ailleurs et
l'Europe est en train de devenir petit à
petit un petit peu comme Venise l'été
quand on a découvert les États-Unis et
que c'est Amsterdam qui est passé devant
quoi donc je suis un petit peu surpris
des discours que vous tenez parce que
c'est des c'est des discours si vous
voulez qui sont parfaitement étatistes
et qui montrent que l'État dans le fond
fait son boulot moi j'ai pas
l'impression que l'État fasse son boulot
j'ai pas l'impression que l'argent qu'on
dépense soit bien dépensé
j'ai pas l'impression
que les gens soient particulièrement
heureux en France et donc je me dis
simplement bah écoutez je suis un petit
peu embarrassé pardon je suis pas là il
y a pas de pardon il te rend la parole
et ensuite tu r voilà donc ce que
j'essaie de dire c'est ce que je veux
c'est que les gens ne soient pas
simplement prospères ce qui serait déjà
pas mal mais qu'il soient libre libre
libre d'agir comme ils le veulent libre
de créer libre de se casser la gueule
libre d'être reçu libre de ne pas être
reçu libre d'être entendu toute ma vie
ça a été la recherche de la liberté j'ai
pas besoin qu'on me donne des conseils
sur la façon d'être libre Charles est-ce
que tu peux rendre la parole à Pierre
c'est fait merci tout le monde est
d'accord pour dire qu'il faut la plus
grande liberté possible je person envie
de le goulag c'est juste que l'autre
fois dans quand vous êtes venu ici dans
ce studio vous avez expliqué que
l'Allemagne tout va bien quand vous vous
dit vous vous AZ dit il y a peut-être 3
% des Allemands qui ont des problèmes
pant je me suis coltiné vos 3 heures
j'ai préparé et c'est juste incroyable
en 2023 2024 expliquer encore que tout
va bien en Allemagne ça n'est pas 3 %
des gens qui ont un problème la réforme
de il y a aujourd'hui j'ai vérifié avant
de venir ce matin il y a 6 millions de
gens en Allemagne qui ont des boulots à
10h par semaine à 538 € par mois 538
voilà il c'est pas une anecdote il y en
a 6 millions et quelle est la liberté
d'un homme ou d'une femme qui vit avec
530 € par mois vous êtes venu avec votre
fille on a pris un café là pendant un
quart d'heure est-ce que si votre fille
était avec vivait avec 530 € par mois
vous Dirie elle est libre c'est super ce
modèle ma fille est une des 6 millions
qui vit avec 530
€ab pas raison d'amener ça
sur qu' faut pas fa pardon c'est trop
facile de dire tout va bien en
allemag vousz dit 3% des gens qui av un
problème en
allem pour char valable pour Pierre
j'aimerais qu'il ait de la vous
expliquer
as Redu la parole non pas encore donc je
voudrais juste pardon moi le problème du
chômage il y a 15000 personnes qui
meurent chaque année en France à cause
des conséquences du chômage l'incerme
dit qu'on enlève tous les autres
facteurs de risque les maladies et en
tant que tel le chômage fait 15000 morts
la première cause d'échec scolaire dans
notre pays on peut avoir des discussions
sur la façon dont l'école apprend à lire
et à écrire mais la première cause échec
scolaire c'est le chômage ou la
situation de grande précarité de par
question donc je j'ai une question moi
quand Charles dit notre système de soin
se vutre nos un unité vôre notre état
notre état devient de plus en plus lourd
que j'entends des économistes dire il
faut dégraisser le mamouth mais par pas
sens peut avir non mais justement je
viens de dire par aux États-Unis le coût
de la santé est deux fois plus important
simplement il est financé
essentiellement par le secteur privé
donc quand on dit que l'État est trop
important il y a des moments où c'est
pénible pour être poli quand il y a trop
de page de réglementation je suis
d'accord avec les agriculteurs quand
leur demande de remplir 50 papiers et
que on leurand même pas un revenu
correct il y a des moments où la
suradministration qu'elle soit
européenne ou française est trop pénible
alors que on pourra avoir des règles
simples pendant 31 ans l'Europe a
protégé le revenu des paysans ce qu'on
avait appelé les côas laitiers c'était
des règles très simples en disant chaque
année on voit le volume de lait de
fromage don on a besoin on évite la
surproduction il y a un prix qui était
correct c'était une régulation mais très
simple et le but d'un paysan n'est pas
d'avoir des subventions c'est de vivre
de son travail et pendant 31 ans c'est
mon copain Michel Rocard qui l'avait
fait mis en place pendant 31 ans les
l'Europe a protégé le revenu des paysans
sans avoir besoin de contrôle tatillon
et sans avoir besoin de subvention et
puis c'est des gens de droite qui l'ont
supprimé c'est Jean-Pierre affarin c'est
Bruno Le Maire il y a des différences
entre l'Europe de gauche et l'Europe de
droite et maintenant l'Europe est plus
tatillonne il y a plus de contrôle les
paysans en on marre on leur fait des
contrôles par satellite pour voir s'ils
ont bien planté ça un mec qui n'a jamais
foutu les pieds dans une parcelle va va
les contrôler et en même temps on n'est
pas capable de contrôler de d'assurer le
revenus donc il y a des fois où on peut
critiquer la suradministration et on
aujourd'hui si notre système de santé
souffre c'est par manque de moyens c'est
parce qu'on a voulu faire des économies
qui a une population qui vieillit qui a
une population qui qui va de plus en
plus souvent d'urgence on est tous très
contents d'avoir quand on a un problème
d'aller voir un oftalmo et on s'est pas
donné les moyens d'avoir les moyens
financiers autour donc et dans le
problèm de d'éducation on se donne pas
les moyens effectivement de donner à
l'éducation tous les moyens on se donne
pas les moyens de s'attaquer aux racines
du problème moi j'ai fait du col portage
de livre je trouve que dans notre pays
on fait tout pour le développement
physique des enfants il y a les
échographies il y a le fluor il y a les
vaccins et pour le développement
intellectuel et affectif on laisse les
familles chacune dans son coin et donc
on ne fait rien pour lutter contre les
inégalités donc si vous voulez on
prépare ces 3 heures sur les les
questions d'éducation au sens global le
rôle des familles de la société de de la
Nation pour éduquer mais en tout cas la
critique de l'État globalement et donc
je je finis en expliquant que
aujourd'hui dans tous nos pays a cette
concurrence salariale et deuxième raison
pour lesquelle il faut toujours plus de
dett c'est la concurrence fiscale quand
j'étais petit et c'est encore plus vrai
pour vous l'impôt sur les bénéfices
éétait à 50 %. quand il y avait des
bénéfices donc je viens de montrer qu'il
y a jamais eu autant de bénéfices
puisqu'on écrase la masse salariale dans
tous nos pays on écrase la masse
salariale donc ce qui va au bénéfice est
de plus en plus important et en plus on
a fait baisser l'impôt sur les bénéfices
je répète quand j'étais petit l'impôt
sur les bénéfices était à 50 % on
trouvait normal quand il y a des
bénéfice on donne la moitié aux
actionnaires qui ont pris des risques et
la moitié pour l'éducation pour la santé
pour pour la recherche et voyez le
dumping c'est la courbe d'Eurostat c'est
mis en scène par KMG donc pas des
gauchistes on est tombé à 19 %. le taux
moyen d'impôt sur les bénéfices est
tombé à 19 % en Europe alors qu'aux
États-Unis de Roosevelt à Trump il était
jamais tombé en dessous de 38 %. donc ce
dumping c'est qu considérable les
bénéfices explosent et jamais on a taxé
aussi peu les bénéfices alors qu'on a
donc dernier point officiellement ce
dumping c'est pour la croissance et pour
l'investissement voilà la croissance en
France depuis 50 ans est-ce que ça
marche voilà la croissance en Allemagne
depuis 50 ans est-ce que ce dumping
salarial et fiscal ça marche la réponse
est non l'Allemagne est en récession il
y a 3 semaines le ministre de l'Économie
a dit la situation est catastrophique
parce que quand vous avez 6 millions de
petits boulots 6 millions de gens qui
vivent avec 530 € c'est humainement
catastrophique et économie omiquement
ils peuvent pas s'acheter une Mercedes
ok ils sont pas au chômage ok mais leur
liberté est très faible et quand il y a
6 million d'Allemands sans compter les
retraités 20 % des retraités enessous ch
de pauvreté donc cette concurrence cette
la pression à la baisse de la masse
salariale et la pression à la baisse sur
la fiscalité nous amène à une
catastrophe économique et c'est pour ça
qu'il faut toujours plus de det parle à
Charles je relaisse la parole à Charles
gaveav bien la seule chose qui augmente
c'est le nombre de milliardaires pardon
il y a quand même une efficacité ce
dumping fiscal et ce dumping salarial à
quand même vous avez des clients sans
doute qui profit de cette concurrence
fiscale pierre tu peux redonner la je
laisse la parole à Charles g voilà bon
ben écoutez je sais pas tropù commencer
parce que j'ai eu un j'ai un très bel
exposé de la façon dont les s'appuyer
sur l'état c'est régler les problèmes
des économies donc ça c'est déjà une
nouvelle intéressante mais je voudrais
j'ai un petit peu de mal parce que
j'essaie de
réfléchir je me dis à la limite notre
pays va mal
aujourd'hui
est le poids de l'État dans
l'économie c'est
combien je dis il y a des
choses comment vous mesurez comment je
sais pas secteur non concurrentiel allez
là où il y a pas de concurrencere plus
de 50 % si
vous on est à 50 ou 60 % doê encore une
fois quand on investit dans la santé si
demain vous tombez malade vous serez
très content je suis sûr vous serez très
je ne souhaite pas que vous soyez malade
mais je suis sûr que si vous avez un
problème vous serez très content d'être
pris en charge par les meilleurs
hôpitaux est-ce que est-ce que Charles
t'a donné la parole oui mais cette
critique de l'État elle est elle est on
peut être un peu plus subtile dans
l'analse plus subti dans l'analyse mais
je suis content de voir que vous me
trouvez pas subtile j'ai dis que vous
pouvez être plus subtile je suis
persuadé que vous pouvez l'être je peux
l'être sans trop difficulté mais ce que
je veux dire c'est une chose toute
simple si vous voulez c'est que la
réalité c'est que la création de
richesse est un acte individuel et cet
acte
individuel dépend de liberté politique
que chaque individu a de prendre des
risques en fonction de ce qu'il pense et
dès le moment où on vous prend par
exemple 50 ou 60 ou 70 % de ce que vous
gagnez en prenant des risques vous n'en
prenez plus donc ce que j'essaie de dire
c'est qu'en eff en effet une société qui
est mais est-ce qu'on est vraiment non
mais est-ce qu'on est vraiment en train
de tuer les milliardaires et de les
assassiner sous sous les taxesant il est
gauchiste non mais pardon mais nous
faire
gauchiste est-ce que c'est vraiment
est-ce qu'on est vraiment dans on
surtaxe les milliardaires pardon on on
vit pas dans le même monde mais vous
avez quelque chose contre les
milardaires AZ quel évidence vous avez
un problème je suis milliardaire allez
ok qu'est-ce que ça peut vous [__] que
je sois milardaire pas vous soz
milliardaire ça des millions de gens qui
n pas quoi
vire c'est dans votre pensé limité dans
votre pensé limité vous pensez que
quelqu'un qui a gagné de l'argent c'est
qu'il l'a pris à quelqu'un d'autre c'est
d'une crétinerie totale j'ai jamais
entendu j'ai jamais entendu quelque
chose dei chouette celui qui crée de de
la richesse il rend les gens riches
autour de lui ok mais il y a 30 ans il y
avait un partage beaucoup plus équitable
de la richesse parce qu'il y a des
salariés aussi on s'en fout' s' fout pas
c'est ce que
vous ce qui compte c'est la création de
richesse c'est pas le partage de la
richesse comment elle est partagéci
est-ce que des salariés parce que la
richesse c'est pas que le patron il y a
des salariés qui se réveillent le matin
pour aller au boulot et Rich pi pire pi
pierre merci je savais pas question te
poser est-ce que tu connais le vieil
adage qui dit dans toute grande fortune
il y a du sang de pauvre non c'est
complètement con c'est baljac qui a dit
dans toute grande fortune à l'origine il
y a un grand crime et c'est pas vrai du
tout c'est complètement idiot dans la
fortune de je sais pas Bill Gates il y a
pas de grand il a pas de grand crime à
ma connaissance peut-être fait j'en sais
rien tu sais comment il a construit sa
boîte Bill Gates bah il a construit sa
boîte avec trois ou quatre copains dans
un coin en Californie puis ça a plutôt
bien marché quoi il a pas fractionné sa
boîte en plein de petits trucs pour
éviter de payer de l'impôt à GAE c'est
ça c'est c'est tiens je te signale que
l'une des grandes décisions de la Cour
suprême des États-Unis c'est de dire que
le devoir le devoir de chaque citoyen
c'est de payer le moinsimp possible
également légalement je parle pas de fr
fiscale mais légalement le devoir de
chaque citoyen parce que l'argent que tu
as gagné il est à toi tu en donn une
partie à la communauté mais il faut pas
que la communauté commence à te voler
qu'est-ce que tu penses de la politique
extérieure américaine
Charles de qui des États-Unis en ce
moment que ce soit sur les C ou 10
dernières
administrations bah attends tu peux pas
dire que la politique américaine qui
avait sous bouche c'était la même que
celle qui fils le fils euh c'est pas la
c'est j' avais une grosse différence
avec celle par exemple de d'Obama
d'Obama il y avait une grosse différence
avec celui qui a attaqué le plus de
grand nombre de pays c'est quand même
Obama je crois c'est si mes souvs sont
exacts donc l'idée qu'un homme de gauche
n'attaque pas les autres c'est assez
curieux donc non mais ce que j'essaie de
dire c'est ce qu'il y a d'essentiel pour
qu'une société fonctionne il faut
revenir aux racines il faut que la
création de richesse soit facile
c'est-à-dire que c'est encré dans
quelque chose comme le droit de
propriété on n'a pas le droit de voler
le travail de quelqu'un d'autre donc il
faut que la création de richesse soit
facile il faut qu'elle soit facilement
transmissible il faut qu'elle soit
protégé par les lois et toutes ces
chosesl c'est des choses que dans le
fond nous n'avons plus en Europe est-ce
que je peux te couper Charles bien sûr
moi je suis tout à fait détendu la
concentration de patrimoine la
concentration de richesse quand tu n'as
pas la chance de naître dans avec une
cuillère en
argent à ton époque on pouvait
entreprendre être partir de rien aux
États-Unis et j'ai beaucoup d'entrepris
oui et Moné j'avais créé une société de
gestion où je gérais qu 10 milliards de
dollars à l'époque quand tu quand quand
tu vois à l'heure actuelle quand tu veux
entreprendre en France quel crti tu
pourrais formuler sur l'état et sur
l'entrepreneur l'état si tu pour que il
y a quelque chose que j'aime bien aux
États-Unis où j'ai vécu où j'ai étudié
et cetera ça aux États-Unis oùx
ÉtatsUnis j'étais dans l'État de New
York j'étais dans université dans les ou
New York Mme non non c'était New York
c'était du côté de Buffalo par là-bas
dans l' cétait University of New York et
ce que j'aime bien làdedans c'est l'idée
que si tu prends un risque que tu perds
sur ton risque c'est c'est déductible de
les impôts je trouve ça au poil parce
que comme ça ça fait partager la prise
de risque par l'ensemble de la
population par contre si tu gagne à ce
momentlà tu payes des impôts ça paraît
tout à fait normal et donc pour moi la
le le risque c'est littéralement je suis
j'ai toujours été intéressé par un
économiste qui s'appelle chum Petter
c'est-à-dire l'histoire de la création
destructrice c'est-à-dire de temps en
temps il y a un gars qui arrive et qui
par un éclair de génie crée quelque
chose qui n'existait pas avant et
détruit des tas de choses qui exister et
le la marque de toutes les sociétés
conservatrices c'est d'essayer
d'empêcher l'invention d'essayer
d'empêcher ce gars de sortir qui va
changer le monde le vrai révolutionnaire
de l'histoire c'est pas Lénine c'est pas
Staline c'est le gars qui a trouvé
quelque chose c'est Edison si tu veux
lui c'est un vrai ou le gars qui a
trouvé la machine à vapeur ça c'est des
vrais révolutionnaires ça change tout tu
connais la la la légende de l'invention
du
téléphone par belle ouais tu sais
pourquoi il a créé le téléphone sans
doute parce qu'il voulait parler à sa
femme à midi j'en sait rien parce que sa
femme était malade voilà donc il voulait
lui parler donc il voulait lui parler
c'est exactement ça donc si vous voulez
il y a il y a dans cet aspect
extraordinaire de la liberté il y a
l'aspect création
et je vois aujourd'hui que je quand je
suis en France par exemple j'ai
travaillé aux États-Unis je travaill en
France j'ai créé une boîte je géré des
milliards de dollars enfin j'ai fait des
tas de trucs dans ma vie et c'était très
intéressant parce
que si jeose dire quand je vivais en
Angleterre et que j'ais cet argent tout
ce qui n'était
pas interdit formellement par le droit
était permis quand j'ai revenu en France
après quelques années tout ce qui
n'était pas forement autorisé par l'État
était était était interdit en France
donc dans un cas la liberté était
définie comme tout ce qui n'est pas
interdit est libre dans l'autre tout ce
qui n'est pas autorisé est interdit et
donc la France est une est une est un
pays qui est naturellement
contre la liberté ai que que ça paraisse
alors que le monde saon c'est très
facilement laisser les gens aller au
maximum de leur capacités au point
d'ailleurs que si se casse la gueule
c'est pas trop grave char j'aimerais que
tu donnes la parole à Pierre bien sûr
non mais je je vais conclure simplement
en disant pour moi le la seule chose qui
compte c'est le fait que dans une
société le maximum de gens doivent être
libres libre de faire comme ils veulent
libre de choisir comme ils veulent et
que le rôle de l'État n'est pas de les
diriger
ni de les favoriser ni de les pousser
dans un sens ou un autre laisser les
gens et favoriser la possibilité de
choix des gens c'est ça qui m'intéresse
dans la vie c'est tout tu donnes la
parole à Pierre fait al peut-être un
point de convergence une fois toutes les
heures le fait qu'aux États-Unis on peut
effectivement prendre plus de risques et
que si on se plante c'est pas très grave
et qu'on peut recommencer voilà donc il
y a quand même un côté positif après ça
faut arrêter de croire que l'Europe on
est que des gros bets l'hydrogène vert
c'est chez nous qu'on dépose le plus de
brevets c'est quand même l'Europe qui
pardon après ça les États-Unis mett des
énormes primes justement ils
subventionnent pour attirer tout chez
eux c'est vraiment pas le libéralisme
Joe Biden a mis 369 milliards
l'inversion de rédu acte mais c'est chez
nous qu'on a je rappelle aussi que c'est
chez nous qu'on a inventé Internet et
les écrans tactiles c'est parce qu'on
avait mis des milliards pour chercher le
bon de X l'Europe s'est dit ça vaut le
coup de mettre de l'argent dans la
recherche fondamentale et c'est des
hommes et des femmes d'abord des
Européens puis avaient coopéré avec le
reste du monde mais c'est en Europe
parce qu'on cherchait le boson de X
parce qu'on a on avait besoin d'échanger
beaucoup d'information on a inventé
internet on a inventé les écr en tactile
et après ça les Américains ont été
capables de développer l'aspect
industriel et aujourd'hui sur les
énergies du futur c'est chez nous parce
qu'on a quand même malgré tout des
chercheurs et des chercheuses qui ont un
cerveau qui marche très bien qu'on
dépose le plus de brevets mais les
Américains c'est là pas du libéralisme
mettent des énormes subventions si vous
fait si vous allez aux États-Unis pour
faire l'hydrogène il vous donne des
subventions qui divisent par 4atre le
coût de production donc après ça sur la
liberté j'ai déjà dit que quelle est la
liberté d'un homme ou d'une femme qui
vit avec le RSA en France quelle est la
est en Allemagne parmi les 6 millions
c'est pas anecdotique de de gens qui
sont à 10h un petit boulot à 10h par
semaine 530 € je me souiens dans mes
cours de philosophie un certain laacord
d'ire je crois que c'est en 1835 ça n
rajunit pas mais la cord disait entre le
riche et le pauvre entre le faible et le
fort c'est la liberté qui opprime et
c'est la loi qui libère c'est la loi qui
libère il y a besoin de règle du jeu si
on avait pas fait une loi pour interdire
le travail des enfants les enfants
travailleraient et ne pourrai pas aller
à l'école si on n pas met une loi pour
un salaire minimum il y aurait une une
concurrence permanente donc il faut il
faut trouver le bon équilibre entre la
capacité d'innovation j'ai l'impression
j'ai l'impression d'être à la messe le
dimanche je suis je suis ému je suis
bouleversé de règles sociales j'ai rien
contre les règles sociales mais je tu
n'as rien contre la messe j'ai rien
contre la messe j'ai rien contre les
règles sociales j'ai rien contre la mais
je crois en plus que la Corda était
dominicain j'en suis pas mais donc en
tout cas il expliquit que la liberté
quand il y a des inégalités de naissance
quand il y en a qui ont beaucoup
beaucoup d'argent au début et qui
peuvent choisir il y a 10 personnes qui
veulent un job mais il y a un seul job
et bien il y a besoin de régulation
sinon faut c'est pour ça qu'il faut un
système libre o vous avez 10 Jobs qui se
crée à la place d'un qui va office
minist non je crois pas et je finirai
tout à l'URS j'ai montré la courbe sur
la dette aux États-Unis qui montre qu' a
vraiment une grande différence avant et
après l'arrivée des libéraux tant qu'on
tient bon sur des règles de justice
sociale il y a la capacité d'initiative
Roosevelt était pas un communiste il y a
la capacité d'initiative mais il y a des
règles sur le salaire minimum sur le
temps de travail sur comment on finance
la retraite des vieux la première chose
que fait Roosevelt avant de lancer
breton Woods c'est la déclaration de
Philadelphie il n'y aura pas de P pays
durable sans justice sociale le travail
n'est pas une marchandise qu'on peut
brader c'est pas quand des millions de
chômeurs qu'on va baisser les salaires
donc ceux qui avaient connu la crise de
29 pensent qu'il faut garder la capacité
d'innovation du capitalisme mais qu'il
faut des règles sociales ça marche
jusqu'à l'arrivée des libéraux et on
voit que le besoin de dette il arrive
avec les libéraux parce que on comprime
les salaires et on pousse les gens à
s'endetter et une autre courbe que j'ai
trouvé aujourd'hui c'est intéressant
c'est le nombre de gens qui sont en
prison aux États-Unis il y en a toujours
eu mais il y a vraiment une augmentation
donc le libéralisme n'est vraiment pas
un humanisme le libéralisme fut en l' la
planète j'espère qu'on va en parler tout
à l'heure vous avez dit en supposant
qu'il y a un réchauffement donc le
libéralisme dérégulé le capitalisme
dérégulé fut en l'air la planète fut en
l' la cohésion social même du point de
vue bêtement économique il ne tient plus
il peut s'effondrer n'importe quand et
du point de vue humain l'évolution du
nombre de prisonniers aux États-Unis la
courbe est parallèle ça pas les
inégalités sociales provoquent de plus
en plus de violence même si c'est pas la
seule cause est-ce que Pierre tu me
donnes la parole allez-y chers collègue
merci bien Charles j'aimerais que tu
fasses quelque chose et ensuite je
voudrais que Pierre fasse la même chose
je voudrais que tu verbalises les
angoisses de pierre et je voudrais
ensuite que Pierre verbalise les
angoisses de Charles moi j'ai pas
d'angoisse non je te demande de verb
mais je lui laisse je laisse j'ai aucune
angoisse la seule chose qui m'intéresse
dans la vie c'est comment rendre chaque
citoyen le plus libre possible quelle
était ma question c'était quelles sont
mes angoisses non de verbaliser
verbis tu penses qu'il a peur de quoi et
ensuite toi tu penses qu'il a pe de
quoi moi j'ai déjà a du mal à savoir ce
que je pense alors savoir ce que pense
un autre j'ai aucune idée parce que
c'est c'est de la présomption l'empathie
c'est non c'est pas de l'empathie c'est
de la présomption parce queon ne peut
pas connaître la complexité de l'esprit
d'un autre j'ai déjà du mal à me à me à
me patouiller avec mes propres idées mes
propres préférences mon instinct c'est
chaque fois qu'il y a un choix entre
être libre et être contraint je choisis
la liberté toujours parce que c'est ma
nature mais je comprends très bien qu'il
y des gens qui qui préfère être animal
domestique qu'animal sauvage ça ça me
gêne pas une seconde donc mais je le
comprends très bien j'en ai dans ma
famille tout le monde on a sa famille et
cetera je pense c'est petit je pense que
l'homme est fait pour être pour être
libre il est il est fait pour être mais
personne ne dit que l'homme est fait
pour être avec des fers et des des des
liens oui mais attends pierre s'il te
plaît h donc je dis
simplement la seule société qui est
permis aux gens d'être libre de façon
générale ça a été nos démocratie qui
s'appuyit tous sur la concurrence sur la
méritocratie sur l'éducation et sur des
choses comme ça et donc je me dis bon
ben ces sociétés là m'intéressent plus
que les autres mais il faut pas croire
qu'elles vont trouver la solution pe
faire est-ce qu'on peut faire cette
expérience de pensée que tu te mettes à
la à la place de pierre et que tu
essayes d'imaginer ses angoisses par
rapport à ton point de vue quelles sont
ces angoisses par rapport à ton point de
vue mon angoisse c'est toujours celle
que non non l'angoisse qu' qu'il doit
avoir comme beaucoup de gens c'est c'est
de penser qu'automatiquement le genre de
société à
laquelle j'aspire pas vraiment mais
enfin qui ne me gêne pas c'est une
société où les gens sont compétitifs se
BAGAR c'est une société assez sportive
en quelque sorte j'ai toujours été un
grand sportif dans ma jeunesse et je me
suis fait battre par des gens qui
étaient meilleurs que moi j'ai battu des
gens qui étaient moins bons que moi il
m'est arrivé de me faire battre par des
gens qui étaient moins bons que moi
aussi donc j'ai une espèce de de
d'amitié pour tout ce qui est vous savez
ce qu' fait de le coup dans les Vissers
de rugby on se met des grandes claques
pendant le terrain sur le terrain puis
ensuite on va voir une VI ensemble donc
le simple fait de se donner des claques
je trouve sur le terrain de rugby ou un
match de tennis et déjà un Act ok
n'importe quoi et déjà un acte d'amitié
virile si je dire je trouve ça au poil
qu'on puisse se mettre les claqu et
ensuite aller prendre une Dr donc je ne
crains pas la compétition je la les fa
de tes petits collègues dans les douche
avec la serviette ou non le petit col
avec la douche dans la serviette ça
m'est arrivé quand la première fois que
je suis arrivé à New York j'avais été
dans une je devais avoir 25 ans j'ai été
dans une auberge de jeunesse là où il y
avait des gars qui étaient dans la
douche qui mesuraiit de M 10 de haut et
je me disais je suis pas sûr d'être
content dans la douche avec euxy ce que
je veux dire s'il y avait moment où on
se dit je suis pas certain d'être dans
la dans le bon endroit au bon moment qui
mais mais sinon non ça m'a jamais gêné
d'être de savoir que euh et je ne me
suis jamais senti obligé de
protéger les gens qui voulaient pas se
battre autant j'essayais toute ma vie de
protéger des gens qui acceptai de se
battre autant s'il voulait se retirer et
dire je juge mais je ne joue pas si vous
voulez juger jouez si vous voulez ne pas
juger à ce moment-là foutez-moi la paix
ne m'expliquez pas ce qu'il faut faire
est-ce que tu peux donner la parole à
Pierre moi c'est fait moi j'ai dis ce
que j'ai dit moi j' j'aime mettre des
claques aux autres et ce qu' m'en
mettent aussi d'ailleurs pierre je
voudrais que tu verbalises ou tu tu tu
fasses ce don de d'empathie
sur les angoisses de Charles par rapport
à ton point de vue et je voudrais
qu'ensuite que Charles je voudrais
d'abord dire à analyse à Charles tout à
l'heure que quand je lui parler de sa
fille en disant si c'était votre fille
qui vivait avec 530 € vous l'avez pris
comme un piège c'est pas ça moi souvent
Paron souvent quand je fais des des
conférences j'explique pourquoi on peut
aller vers une crise terrible j'explique
les solutions et j'explique
fondamentalement qu'on a droit au
bonheur ce qui me guide et je mets la
photo d'un de mes fiston on est dans les
Pyrénées il joue au foot avec les
cousins la vie est belle et donc ce qui
me guide c'est que j'ai envie que mes
enfants mais aussi votre fille et les
gens qui euh qui travaillent qui vont
travailler jusqu'à minuit ce soir et les
gens qui je trouve qu'on est on pourrait
vivre dans un pays de cocagne on n'a
jamais été aussi riche globalement il y
a des trucs à améliorer il y a mais ce
qui me fout en r c'est de voir des gens
qui tombent dans la rue des enfants dont
on n' pas allumé l'intelligence des
hôpitaux qui s'effondrent alors qu'on
aurait les moyens de les payer mais donc
et après ça je crois que si on continue
les politiques qu'on a mis en place
depuis 40 ans on va vers une catastrophe
économique ce système ne tient que pas
sil faut toujours plus c'est une fuite
en avant toujours plus de dettes et
qu'on va faire une crise climatique vous
avez je je pense que on n pas d'accord
làdessus vous avez dit tout à l'heure en
supposant qu' un réchement
climatique aujourd'hui il fait 50 degr à
Bangkok pendant qu'on parle ici il fait
50 dire en supposant qu'il a un
réchauffement on n pas sur la même plan
commence pas à prendre le contrôle de
l'interview je prends auun contrôle mais
on pas la même vision du monde d'accord
mais on va avoir le temps d'évoquer les
choses on n pas sur un plateau télé on a
le
temps je t'ai posé une question quelle
était ma question je pense que éta ma
question
les angoisses de Monsieur gave merci
vas-y et donc je sais pas trop s'il a eu
il a lu des bouquins sur l'épisode
soviétique qui pensent que dès qu'il y a
une règle elle est contraignante et moi
je trouve que le sujet c'est de trouver
le bon équilibre s'il y a trop de règles
c'est insupportable s'il y a trop
d'impôt ça fout tout en l'air mais quand
il y a plus assez de règles et que c'est
la loi de la jungle et bien il y a une
précarité catastrophique qui amène à des
catastrophes sociales je suis désolé
mais des je vous ai montré le nombre de
prisonniers aux États-Unis je vous ai
dit il y a 15000 morts en France chaque
année à cause du chômage et donc je
pense qu'il faut trouver le bon
équilibre et que on avait un équilibre
c'est sans l'idéaliser mais ceux qui
avaient connu la crise de 29 et la
barbarie on dit il faut garder je répète
Roosevelt et d'autres on dit il faut
garder la capacité d'initiative du
capitalisme mais avec des règles voilà
et ça a marché pendant 35 ans 40 ans et
puis des libéraux onliqu on va [__] en
l'air toutes ces règles et on s'enfonce
dans la crise et donc voilà moi
j'aimerais qu'on remette en place des
règles pas des systèmes et quand vous
parlez de liberté je j'ai fait l' grro
et je m'intéresse aux questions
agricooles depuis très longtemps et je
vous dis j'étais un copain de Michel
Rocard qui a mis en place les côtes
laitiers ben les côes allitiers pendant
31 ans ça protégeit le revenu des
paysans sans subvention ils avaient un
prix correct et bien c'est le secteur où
il y avait le plus de jeunes qui
s'installaient parce qu'il savait qu'il
fallait se réveiller le matin et que le
soir il y a des fois où on fait le
village jusqu'à 2h du matin parce qu'il
faut finir le village mais donc je vous
dis pas que c'était youlaabom mais il
savait que avec ce système de protection
du c'était un système très facile il y
avait très peu de contrôle mais il y
avait un prix correct pour le lait il
n'avait pas Besin de subvention et
pendant 31 ans c'est le secteur où il y
avait le plus de jeunes d'agriculteurs
qui s'installaient il y avait quasiment
aucun suicide ça fonctionne et puis
c'est des imbéciles libéraux JRE police
Bruno le ma c'est euh rafarin qui
suppriment les côas laitiers on leur dit
mais monsieur le ministre il va y avoir
une crise les prix vont s'effondrer et
Bruno Leem dit c'est pas très grave on
exportera plus vers la Chine et
aujourd'hui toutes les semaines il y a
des suicide de paysan donc la liberté je
suis désolé mais pour un secteur que je
connais quand il y avait des règles qui
permettaient d'avoir un prix correct
pour le lait la liberté des agriculteurs
était bien plus forte que aujourd'hui où
c'est la concurrence permanence tu dois
bosser 80 he tu es surendetté et il
parlent tous franchement je suis allé
passer des heures et il parlent tous de
l'oncle qui s'est suicidé du fait que
lundi on a enterré un copain voilà c'est
pas un problème théorique c'est pas du
paatos c'est pas du Patos on a tout pour
être heureux on a jamais été aussi riche
il un système où des millions de gens
ont le moral à zéro et où des milliers
de gens ont une vie de Moise et bien
c'est pas du Patos il faut changer ce
système ça je suis bien d'accord avec
vous pierre est-ce que tu donnes la
parole à Charles je donne la parole à
Charles GAV je suis bien d'accord avec
vous pour expliquer que les
interventions ça marche moyen c'est pas
à moi qu'il faut le dire pardon vous
n'avez pas mis pardon je veux pas
désagrave je viens de vous dire au
contraire que les interventions ça
dépend c'est quoi les interventions je
viens de vous expliquer que pendant 31
ans l'Europe a protégé le RES
agriculteurs les quotas laitiers les
quotas céréaliers sans quasiment aucune
subvention sauf dans les zones
compliquées comme les zones de montagne
il y avait juste on mettait en place des
outils de régulation il y a besoin de
régulation tu voilà moi je me souviens
dans mes cours de catéchisme déjà il y a
3000 ans en Égypte Joseph devient le
conseiller de Pharaon parce qu'il
interprète l'histoire des vaches grasses
et des vaches maigres tout le monde le
sait le pharaon est très troublé il a
fait rve bizarre il y avait des vaches
très très bien nourres qui sortaient
d'un le et après ça des vaches toutes
maigr ches en train de crever et il
savait pas ce que ça voulait dire et
Joseph lui explique que quand il y a des
très très bonnes récoltes les années de
vaches grasses le prix du sorgot le prix
du des céréales va s'effondrer et les
paysans n'arriveront pas à vivre et donc
le rôle de l'État c'est de stocker pour
que le prix ne s'effondre pas et que les
paysans vivent correctement et après ça
il y aura des années de vache maigre
s'il y a des sécheresses la récolte va
diminuer et le rôle de l'État ce sera de
utiliser les stocks qu'il a fait 3 ans
avant pour que le peuple puisse ne pas
mourir de et avoir des céréales à un bon
prix donc déjà il y a 3000 ans dans la
Bible il y a des trucs qui sont
philosophiques il y a des trucs qui sont
pipos mais ça c'est une histoire vraie
déjà il y a 3000 ans en Égypte on a
compris qu'il fallait réguler les
marchés et que la main invisible elle ne
fonctionne pas elle ne fonctionne jamais
elle est vraiment invisible sauf pour
les plus riches qui s'en fout plein des
poches il y a besoin de régulation mais
je on me demande de vous donner la
parole je suis tout à fait content de
l'apprendre si j'ai jamais dit qu'il y
en avait pas besoin de régulation vous
passez vot temp dire qu'il
faut j'ai pas dit qu'il fallait pas de
régulation je dis simplement qu'il faut
simple il faut simplement laisser les
gens libres et aujourd'hui vous pouvez
raconter tout ce que vous voulez mais
les paysans français euh ils sont ils
vont d'abord ils vont pas bien il
voudrait répondre à l'histoire de la
vache maigre et de la vache grasse qui
sont dans la Bible et qui est un vieux
truc c'est tout à fait exact Joseph VO
la les vaches sortir grass et sortir
maigre et en effet il fait des il fait
des provisions ça c'est le rôle de
l'État donc le rôle de l'État qu'est-ce
que c'est c'est dans une société vous
avez des activités qui sont fragiles et
des activités qui sont mettons
antifragiles pour parler comme Nass
Taleb et donc le but de l'État c'est de
faire accroître
l'antifragilité de la société dans son
ensemble et donc s'il faut des
régulations moi j'ai jamais été contre
les régulations je pense pas que les
régulations soit une bonne chose mais si
vous régulez jusqu'à la plus jusqu'à
plus soif à ce moment-là ça marche c'est
là la question de l'équilibre je ne
c'est là c'est là où la toute la
question de l'équilibre est là et donc
pourevenir à votre question bien sûr la
paysannerie française ne va pas bien
mais si vous réfléchissez un petit peu
vous regardez ce qui se passe en France
aujourd'hui vous connaissez un peu la
paysannerie française qui est mon cas et
bien dans le temps ils vivaient durement
la terre était dure mais ils vendaient
leur terre à un prix qui était très
élevé et donc ce qui leur assurait une
retraite confortable après une vie qui
était très dure chacun en conviendra
aujourd'hui la T terre est capturée par
les organismes publics qui s'appellent
la safè et donc ils ont plus ils peuvent
plus vendre leur terre elle est capturée
par des elle est distribuée aux amis de
la safè aux enfants des gens qui
travaillent dans la safèas des sources
de ça ça se passe ça se passe c'est
connu comm c'est connu comme le LAN pas
du tout l'État l'état n est pour rien
l'état non c'est c'est la FNSEA c'est la
FNSEA des gros industriels quiette
source ça n' aucun rapport avec l'état
ça rien à voir avec l'État mais
simplement le
valeur des terres en France n'a rien à
voir avec la valeur des terres dans tous
les autres pays d'Europe ça c'est facile
à voir c'està-dire qu'aujourd'hui on se
retrouve avec une valeur des terres qui
est à peu près le 5e de ce qu'elle est
en Pol par exemple mais d'où est-ce que
tu sors le fait que il s'échange
les parle
par Ch du tout en France elles sont pas
chers du tout les terres es son elles
sont beaucoup moins cher comm Espagne
incroyable je teose la question le le
fait qu'il séchange les terres tout ça
tu sors ça d'où bah c'est dans le le
truc de la Saffire c'est connu comme
tout j'ai pas beso d'AV S par qui c'est
publ c'est regarde simplement tu prends
n'importe quel tu regardes sur Google le
prix des terres en Europe le prix des
terres en Europe aujourd'hui le prix des
terre en Europe je crois que ça c'est un
bruit de couloir c'est non c'est tu
prends le prix des TER en Europe tu fais
Google prix des terr en Europe ça doit
être 5000 € par hectare en France et ça
doit être 20000 en Belgique de l'autre
côté de la frontière parce qu'il y a pas
ce système de préemption par une caste
qui la caste des gens qui dirige la
Saffire et qui contrôle les terres en
France interprétation bah j'en sais rien
moi tout ce que je sais c'est pourquoi
les terres sont au tiers du prix en
France de ce qu'elles sont en Belgique
de l'autre côté de la frontière ou en
Allemagne de l'autre côté de la
frontière ou même en Espagne ou même en
Pologne la France est le pays qui les
terres les moins cheres c'est donc on a
plus le paysan n'a plus la propriété de
sa terre s'il avait la propriété de sa
terre il avait la vraie propriété il la
vendrait au même prix que ça se vend
partout ailleurs en Europe alors les
terres les moins cher en Europe c'est en
France c'est pas en Ukraine l'Ukraine
n'est pas en Europe oui puis l'Ukraine
c'est un autre une autre histoire parce
que là aussi c'est toutes les terres
l'Ukraine appartienent aujourd'hui à
Black Rock donc on pour en parler aussi
tu veux mais ça c'est autre chose donc
ce que j'aioi la source de ça le Black
Rock en Raine B c'est je crois la moitié
des terres en Ukraine sont détu par des
grands groupes financiers américains bah
ça il se'est fait taper sur Google
d'accord il se fait taper sur Google
c'est Google il y a des il y a des
blagues qui circulent il y a des blagues
qui circulent mais en général il vous
donne la liste donc revenons un petit
peu à cette question de la liberté parce
qu'elle est absolument la communauté de
fa ça elle est oui bien sûr vous pouvez
aller vérifier le prix des terres en
France c'est le prix des terr en France
par rapport à tous les autres pays
d'Europe c'est vite vu aussi de fa che
aussi l'Ukraine l'Ukraine ou oui c'est
mais je crois
que je je je cite de mémoire mais je
crois que 30 ou 40 % des terre en
Ukraine ont été achetés par des groupes
américains donc c'estt peut-être
d'excellentes raisons de continuer cette
guerre en Ukraine j'en sais rien on
parler plus tard continue sur R ce j'ess
de dire c'est que il y a cette chose
très étonnante qui est la liberté le
paysan c'est un peu le premier des
entrepreneurs
et quand je parle à mes paysans dans le
Gers en Gascogne ou à côté de chez moi
en
Avignon ce qui est très étonnant qu'il
me dit c'est qu'il passe la moitié de
leur temps les de TI de le temps à
remplir des papiers pour avoir des
subventions et ça m'étonne parce que les
paysans que je connaissais dans ma
jeunesse qu'on décrivait dans mes livres
d'histoire c'était des gars qui
faisaient desjà cris quand les emmerd
trop qui allit brancher les paysans qui
allit brancher leur
seigneurs qui était
plutôt difficile à vivre c'était et je
donc ce que j'essaie de dire c'est que
on a transformé nos paysans en en clair
qui remplissent des papiers à peu près
la moitié du temps et en obliger l'autre
moitié du temps c'est-à-dire que ce qui
faisait la force de la France c'était
cette indomtable paysannerie française
qui éta à l'origine de toutes nos
victoires militaires et on en a fait des
types malheureux et quivivent de
subvention c'est-à-dire ils sont
peut-être ils sont
peut-être prospères pour ce que j'en
sais j'en sais rien ça dépend lesquel ça
dépend desquel mais en tout cas dansgers
il sont pas trop prospèr ni dans la
région d'abignon non mais il y a un
énorme problème de revenu pour beaucoup
d'agriculteurs
oui et alors mais pardon là on est
d'accord je l'ai dit tout à l'heure ils
en ont marre de la technocratie qu'on on
est il y a mais attendez vous venez
deexpliquer il y a 5 minutes que la
technocratie vous du très bon boulot
puisqu'on était on avait pas besoin on
avait on était pas en train de discuter
de revenu je vous explique qu'il y a des
il y a eu des époques et c'est pas une
discussion de trois copains qui prennent
un café ou un vert de vin rouge que
pendant 31 ans l'Europe avait un système
qui était très simple il y avait
quasiment aucun contrôle il n'y avait
pas besoin de subvention on se mettait
d'accord sur le volume voilà et c'est
depuis que au contraire on a foutu en
l'air ces outils de régulation donc
c'est la double peine ou la triple peine
pour les paysans je vous dis on était
que deux aller les rencontrer l'autre
jour il y avait Marion maréchal Le Pen
qui était venu faire du marketing et moi
on était que deux élus à passer 3 heures
avec les agriculteurs en col où ça je
suis député européen il agricul sont
venus et les vrais agriculteurs ceux qui
avaient vraiment un problème de revenu
la blague qu'on entendait c'est il y a
personne de la FNSA ils sont tous en
train de faire du ski à Courchevel le
point de départ de la colère c'était des
vrais agriculteurs qui ont qui
travaillent 80 he par semaine et qui
n'arrivent pas à vivre de leur travail
parce qu'on a foutu en l'air les outils
de régulation qui existai avant et donc
ils ont en même temps des revenus qui
s'effondrent parce qu'on a déconné on a
foutu en l'air les outils qui
fonctionnaient avant et c'est pas on
c'est des gens comme Bruno LEM c'est des
gens comme pianpierre afarin c'est des
gens de droite qui ont détruit des
outils qui avaient existé pendant 30 ans
et en même temps on a mis en place des
outils de contrôle ils ont en marqueon
les Fass cagé comme on dit à Toulouse en
disant qu'il y a un gars qui n'a jamais
foutu les pieds dans une parcelle qui
n'y connaît rien mais qui vérifie qu'il
vont aller la planter de luuséan entre
deux récoltes et mais si la parcelle est
inondée ou si au contraire la passerelle
est tellement victime de sécheresse que
ça sert à rien mais on va les leur
casser les pieds en disant vous auriez
dû faire vos semis là donc en même temps
on ne protège pas le revenus on leur
casse les pieds avec des des contrôles
et en même temps on ne fait rien contre
le dérèglement climatique et ils
souffrre de plus en plus dérèglement
climatique donc je comprend qu' son non
non parce que c'est c'est pas pardon il
y a besoin de il dit ce que j'ai dit non
je vois pas en quoi on peut critiqu la
technocratie il est en train il est en
train de dire que la technocratie ça
marche pas ce que disis d'cord dire je
suis d'accord régulation chose si vous
êtes d'accord avec moi
pass laiss faire vous dites que le
laisser faire moi je pense deux choses
différentes avir des règles du jeu avoir
des règles du jeu qui peuvent être très
simples et la technocratie aujourd'hui
on n pas de règles du jeu donc les PR
s'effondre et on a le pire le pire des
situations on n' pas les règles simples
qui protègent les revenus et par contre
on leur casse les pieds avec plein de
contrôle et tendis que pendant 30 ans
c'est pas une utopie le on a fait le
contraire on protégeit leur revenus sans
subvention parce qu'on respectait leur
dignité on respectait leur travail
l'Europe protéger le revenu et il y
avait très très très peu de contrôle
voilà et donc c'est il faudrait mieux
effectivement changer l'Europe c'est le
titre de notre liste pour les
européennes changer l'Europe et on va
faire tout avec les copains d'alons
enfants avec les copains de nouvell
donne pour remettre en place des
politiques qui protègent le revenu des
paysans et qui leur permettre de
protéger la
planète ça me paraît bien ce programme
ah ben ça je pensais pas avoir un vote
de plus en venant ce soir non non mais
j'ai pas dit que c'était mais j'ai
jamais j'ai jamais rencontré un
programme que je n'aimais pas c'était en
général dans l'application du programme
que les problèmes venaient et donc chat
che PT a dit la même chose exactement ça
si vous voulez on a je savais pas que
vous étiez en campagne tout s'explique
parce que je me dis on dirait un homme
en campagne et puis maintenant je vois
en effet que vous êtes en campagne donc
je compr propose que des choses qui
marchent déjà là c'est pas
March mais si me laiss parler je serai
content parce que ce que je voulais dire
à notre ami ici présent si vous AZ dû me
prévenir que j'avais quelqu'un en face
de moi qui faisait campagne parce que
c'est tout à fait moi je fa campagne
rien du tout je explique ce que je pense
lui il cherche à faire ce qui nécessaire
pour être
élu on est pas sur un pied d'égalité
laissez-le laissez le Contin il faire
campagne mais invitez-moi avec quelqu'un
qui parle
raisonnablement do le Do chose de très
intéressant c'est-à-dire que les
politiques en campagne te font les yeux
doux avec des ils sont toujours toutes
les solutions Charles
je je me
fcher je suis confus j'aurais pas dû at
TER non
j'accepte mais il met le doigt sur
quelque chose de très intéressant
c'est-à-dire que pendant les campagnes
les politiques nous promettent nous
émerveilles et après en terme
opérationnel ça spignole un peu quand
même pardon d'abord pardon commence pas
tes phrases par pardon ça fait 25 fois
que je te le dis député seulement depuis
5 ans députés européens c'est la
première fois et même quand vous
m'invitez avant j'avais déjà les mêmes
combats je ne pensais pas être députés
européen et pour savoir est-ce qu'on se
bat est-ce qu'on se bat ou pas en même
temps j'ai essayé de faire le job le
Parlement m'a demandé d'être rapporteur
général du budget donc c'est quand même
moi qui a négocié ma question est-ce
qu'on se est-ce que c'est juste du pipo
pendant les 3 mois avant l'élection ou
est-ce qu'on se bat pour ça et bien je
suis désolé mais je l'idée comment
trouver de l'argent pour la santé pour
les pour les l'emploi pour le climat
j'ai fait voter trois rapports par le
Parlement qui tout le monde a voté sur
l'extrême droite qui dit comment on peut
trouver de l'argent avec unee petite
taxe sur la spéculation on a entendu les
gilets jaunes spéculation la taxe sur
les marchés financiers la taxe sur
transaction financière on a entendu les
gilets jaunes c'est pas ceux qui gagnent
1000 ou 1500 par mois qui doivent être
taxés et après ça j'ai fait une grve de
la fin pendant 18 jours donc ça veut
dire quand même que et je me suis fait
engueuler il y en a qui m'ont demandé
quand est-ce que je démissionnis c'était
la première fois qu'enit quoi moi au
contraire vous vous m'avez donné la
parole mais c'est la première fois qu'on
voyit un député et le rapporteur général
du budget qui fait une grve de la fin
pendant 18 jours parce que pour moi
c'est pas de la rigolade
enfant de 5s un enfant de 5 ans fait la
différence ber laisse-moi terminer
Bernis ils ont du caractère donc pardon
moi j'étais licencié de ma boîte j'étais
consultant en stratégie j'étais le mec
le mieux noté d'Europe et j'étais
licencié à cause de mes idées en matière
sociale et on m'a dit si tu renonces à
parler de tes questions social tu peux
être un des patrons au niveau du au
niveau mondial et je me suis dit mon but
dans la vie n'est pas d'être non c'est
pour dire que T c'est trop facile de
dire que tous les politiques sont là
pour être en campagne voilà j'ai j'étais
licencié de ma boîte quand je me je me
battais pour la semaine de 4 jours par
je suis convaincu que la semaine de 4
jours nous permet de vivre mieux et de
créer des emplois donc moi mon but n'est
pas de faire carrière si je suis plus
député dans 3 mois je m'en fous il y a
une vie en dehors du Parlement européen
mais par contre je trouve très
dramatique qu'on ne parle pas des
solutions pour changer l'Europe il y a
c'est on va vers un effondrement c'était
votre première question oui on va vers
un effondrement si on continue avec des
règles du jeu qu'on a qui qu'on a mis en
place depuis les libéraux depuis depuis
40 ans donc c'est pour ça que je me bat
si je suis en campagne avec les les gens
de changer l'Europe c'est pour ça pierre
tu peux donner la la Charles à vous très
bien si vous voulez moi euh
qu' a vous savez un libéral qu'est-ce
que c'est la définition d'un libéral
c'est simplement un
homme qui respecte la
loi c'est la loi rien que la loi mais
rien en dehors de la loi donc on se
retrouve dans un monde moi pour moi si
les gens votent quelque chose avec
lequel je ne suis pas d'accord par
exemple comme les Français quand ils
aent décidé de voter mitteran et de
mettre des communistes au pouvoir ce que
j'ai trouvé du point de vue humain
absolument insoutenable 81 j'étais à
Londres parce que je ne voulais pas
vivre dans un pays où il y avait des
ministres communistes et communistes
étent responsable de 100 millions de
morts qui me semblait quand même tout à
fait excessif donc je je respecte la loi
et à partir du moment et un libéral par
définition c'est celui qui respecte la
loi plus que n'importe quoi d'autre et
s'il est pas d'accord il s'en va donc
c'est un truc très très simple donc je
vous verai jamais un libéral convaincu
frauder la loi bien maintenant la loi
comme l'avais dit fort traitreusement
cet animal de mteran la force injuste de
la loi c'était une trahison vis-à-vis de
ses fonctions puisque c'était un c'est
dire que la loi peut-être injuste il
faut pas savoir si la loi est injuste
parce que vous mettez face à face deux
notions qui sont antinomiques et la loi
et la morale la loi et la loi point
barre et la morale est personnelle et ne
peut être que personnelle donc si vous
dites la force injuste de la loi vous
êtes comment elle s'appelait celle vous
savez dans la tragédie grecque là qui
veut enterrer son oncle et l'oncle et
l'oncle veut pas qu'elle soit enterrée
c'est l'autre oncle veut pas qu'elle
soit intéresser euh la tragédie de si
vous la connaissez toute la tragédie
grecque vous savez où j'ai un trou de
mémoire faudra que je demande à ta fille
il faudra qu'on demande à ma fille oui
Antigone Antigone merci ma fille
heureusement que tu es là Antigone ben
voilà donc si vous voulez il y a à tout
moment dans n'importe quel humain la
tension entre la loi et la morale
individuelle et bien le libéral à ce
moment-là quand il a une tension entre
la loi et la morale individuelle si la
loi la loi qui est promulguer par
exemple qu'on doit tu on peut tuer les
Juifs les enfants ou j'en sais rien et
là ce qu'il pense il s'en va il ne
désobéit pas à la loi la seule façon
c'est à ce moment de quitter son pays
pour ne plus être soumis à cette loi
mais si vous restez dans le pays vous
restez soumis à la loi on peut se battre
on peut se battre pour changer des lois
si elles sont ind comment tu fais pour
résister bah si tu fais la politique de
la chaise vide bah si tu simplement tu
t'en vas simplement parce que quand tu
es tu t'en vas ok mais moi je si tu peux
pas rester dans un pays si tu ne peux
pas rester dans un pays sans
automatiquement
sacrifier terminer dans un ou simplement
si tu veux si tu peux pas dépendre une
position qui est considérée comme
illégale et que toi tu considères comme
morale Antigone elle meurt ou elle s'en
va c'est-à-dire que entre la morale et
la loi n'importe quel individu
conséquent choisira sa morale
personnelle
individuelle et et pour ne pas briser la
loi qui est un autre point essentiel il
s'en ira du pays non c'est une vision
quand même très très datée hein la
République socialece que Charles t'a
donné la parole non mais je la prends
volontier un partageur non non non mais
ce que je veux dire c'est que vous dites
c'est une vision datée mais c'est une
vision qui date des débuts du
christianisme c'est-à-dire vous avez
toujours à choisir entre la morale et la
loi la morale ça nê une affaire
qu'individuelle personne n'a m le droit
de dire qu'elle est ma morale
personnelle et la la loi je j' obéis si
je suis dans le pays j''yobéis et si
j'accepte pas cette loi je m'en vais et
donc vous pouvez pas dire que c'est une
avveille parce que vous êtes en train de
dire que tous les gens qui ont eu que de
Gaulle qui n'a pas respecté la loi
française et qui a respecté sa morale
individuelle de résister et ben il avait
eu raison de Go a mis en place le
Conseil National de la Résistance
l'autre fois vous avez ricané sur le
Conseil National de la Résistance pardon
avec parole tu donnes la parole à Pierre
s'il te plaît non monie pris est-ce que
tu peux lui donner la parole attends je
voudrais terminer pour dire simplement
toute la tension de la civilisation
chrétienne qui est essentielle c'est
cette tension entre la morale
individuelle et la loi qui est
collective c'est-à-dire que tu ne peux
pas bâtir une société qui est honorable
qui dit viable sur le long terme si tu
forces une des deux parties à l'emporter
sur l'autre donc que je essayer
simplement de dire aux gens c'est j'ai
le droit d'avoir ma morale individuelle
vous vous avez le droit de m'imposer des
choses par la loi si vous êtes une
majorité mais à ce moment-là j'ai le
droit de m'en aller et c'est ce que j'ai
fait en 81 et c'est tout et je m'en
vente pas j'ai dit j'étaé vivre à
Londres où on pouvait je pouvais vire
selon mes convictions donc encore une
fois toute la vie d'un homme c'est ce ce
cette tension qu'il y a entre la loi et
la morale où est-ce que tu mets la
patrie là-dedans ben pour moi si tu veux
la la la patrie la patrie c'est vraiment
ma morale à moi c'est-à-dire que c'est
ce qui est au-dessus de tout pour moi la
patrie c'est vraiment une notion
essentielle et la patrie c'est l'endroit
où ton père est enterré he c'est ça
l'étymologie numopatrie donc tu vas sur
sa tombe et donc pour moi la patrie
c'est une notion extraordinairement
forte et la loi j'ai le droit et même
j'ai le devoir de la refuser en tout cas
d'après l'Église catholique si elle me
si elle me force à faire des choses que
je refuse qui ne sont pas acceptables tu
connais la théorie des baayonnettes
intelligentes tu sais moi je sa connu
une théorie des bonnettes intelligentes
sur lesquelles tu peux t'asseoir hein
c'est je veux pas te faire de pine mais
à mon avis ça existe pas ch j'aimerais
que tu donnes la parole à Pierre c'est
fait moi j'ai dit simplement la loi et
la morale c'est tout le débat de la
civilisation mais justement quand j'ai
dit que c'était daté c'est que que on
parle de Goul ou la République là on est
dans une république sociale il y a le
droit au chacun a le droit et le devoir
de travailler il y a le droit au
logement de Gaul il se bat il se bat
contre les nazi il se bat dans la
Résistance avec un courage incroyable et
en même temps il prépare un texte
magnifique les jours heureux le
programme du Conseil national le
résistance qui dit on va mettre en place
la sécurité sociale c'est quand même
génial dans un pays où ils ont tous
perdu ils savent qu'ils risquent leur
vie quand ils vont se battre contre les
nazis mais en même temps ils
réfléchissent on va mettre en place la
sécurité sociale on va s'arranger pour
que les médias soient libre par rapport
au grands capitalises pour que les
médias connait une presse libre on va
donner le droit de vote aux femmes donc
et aux yeux de de Gaul une République
c'est pas il y a une dimension sociale
je suis désolé c'est pas tout à l'heure
vous rigolier en parlant du Patos quand
je parlais des problèmes de chômeurs et
de précaire mais en concret le quand je
reviens par je fais les courses pour la
famille l'autre jour deux deux
rencontres qui me qui me frappent la
caissière du supermarché au pied de mon
immeuble qui m'explique il y a toujours
autant de gens qui quand ils arrivent à
la caisse ils laissent des produits
parce qu'ils se rendent compte qu'il
leur manque 3 € 4 € et voilà et donc la
flambée des prix c'est et puis l'autre
jour l'autre caissière la plus jeune
j'ai compris qu'elle avit fait une
tentative de suicide elle a eu 15 jours
d'arrêt elle était complètement blanche
complètement livide elle est crevée elle
me raconte que son médecin voudrait
qu'elle s'arrête encore mais son patron
lui a dit que non que son patron
aimerait qu'elle trava Traille et elle
dit que de toute façon même quand elle
est en arrêt maladi avec 60 elle a
seulement 70 % de son salaire et qu'elle
s'en sort pas donc il y a des gens qui
sont englués vous et moi on a un job
intéressant vous il y a des gens qui
vous reconnaissent dans la rue moi il y
en a qui me remercient pour mon action
mais il y a des gens des millions de
gens aujourd'hui qui sont englués qui
ont une vie très très compliqué les
salaires n'augmentent pas les loyers oui
les on s'engueule à chaque fois que les
enfants veulent faire voilà donc c'est
pas du paatos je suis désolé et la
République est sociale quand je dis que
c'est daté on considère depuis des
dizaines d'années en France et dans
d'autres pays Angela Merkel c'est parler
de l'économie sociale de marché en 2007
Angela Merkel voulait compléter les
traités européens avec un protocole
social Merkel c'est pas une gauchiste
marxiste et c'est Sarkozi qui a hélas
empêcher qu'on ait un protocole social
européen donc pour moi la dignité c'est
pas juste un problème d'éthique
personnel se mettre mettre en place une
société où chacun peut vivre librement
et après ça je profiterai de ma liberté
je vous laisserai libre mais tant qu'il
y a des millions de gens qui qui
galèrent au quotidien qui n'ont pas qui
n'ont pas accès à l'éducation vraiment
qui n'ont pas accès à la santé qui on
qui ont une heure de transport tous les
jours parce que les loyers sont trop
chers en centrreeville et que donc et le
matin le ROR ne marche pas donc c'est on
s'engueule parce qu'il y a voilà et bien
non je ne peux pas être libre moi dans
un monde où il y a autant de de précaire
et c'est je ne suis pas le seul à le
penser puisqu'on l' mis dans la
Constitution en particulier parce que de
Goul et ceux qui avaient connu la
barbarie se sont dit que si les nazis
sont arrivé au pouvoir c'est qu'il y
avait une crise sociale c'est qu'il y
avait une humiliation euh cyil nique
explique comment tout le monde est
d'accord pour dire que l'humiliation du
traité de Versailles le peuple allemand
été humilié mais aussi un système
économique qui fait des humiliations au
quotidien pour les millions de gens qui
ont une vie de de mï et qui voit qu'il y
en a qui se goinfre au sommet et bien
cette humiliation elle peut permettre
aussi c'est ça qui pousse les gens à
chercher des bouques émissaires et à
voter pour l'extrême droite donc ce
n'est pas un Patos de s'intéresser à la
justice sociale mais la seule se
justi la seule justice sociale qui qui
est jamais fonctionné dans l'histoire
c'est le plein emploi hein c'est-à-dire
à partir du moment où vous avez un plein
emploi parce que vous laissez les gens
libres de leur décision vous mettez pas
des bêtises euh des règlements à la noix
ou ceci cela dès le moment où il y a le
plein emploi le type qui est pas content
parce que son patron l'embête il donne
sa démission il va dans le dans le bour
d'à côté je vous assure que moi j'ai
vécu à Hong Kong pendant 10 ans et en
Hong Kong il y a un plein emploi pas
possible parce que ben justement les
gens sont libres d'aller devenir et
aussi que ça paraisse le Hong Kong est
le pays avec Singapour qui ont eu la
haussee du niveau de vie la plus
phénoménale depuis 50 ans et ces pays il
n'y a aucun
droit il y a pas de droit du travail et
le niveau de vie est monté comme une
fusée et donc vous retrouvez toujours la
même chose c'est-à-dire que la liberté
comme le disait ce bon Milton Friedman
amène toujours à plus de prospérité en
général et
parfois un peu plus d'égalité alors que
la recherche de l'égalité forçonnée
amène toujours à un appauvrissement
général et à moins de liberté pour tout
le monde donc ce que je veux dire c'est
que de la liberté n'est l'égalité et de
l'égalité n'est la misère et considérer
queégalité n'est la misère de la
recherche la recherche de l'égalité
n'est la misère on l'a vu dans toutes
les explications par exemple les
communistes fallait tous égau et ils ont
tous terminé au goulag pardon quand
Angela Merkel propose un protocole
sociale pour lutter contre la
précarité tu as donné la parole à dire
que la recherche de l'égal est-ce que
Pierre tu as reçu la parole non je dis
simplement vous avez l'égalité j'ai lu
un ma merveilleux livre il y a quelques
années qui avait été écrit je crois par
un anglais dans les années 45 50 qui
était assez marrant vous savez vous avez
des gens comme vous qui voulent que tout
le monde soit pareil j'ai jamais dit ça
mais si vous l'avez dit enfin vous
m'arrêtez vous arrêtez vivre dignement
j'ai pas dit qu'il soit pareil et j'ai
dit que chacun pourra utiliser sa
liberté comme il voudra si chacun dig
prend la parole c'est de ta fout
char alors béton vous avez des gens qui
veulent que tout le monde soit pareil
donc monsieur ne fait pas partie j'en
suis très satisfait s'appelle Pierre
pierre pardon j'avais oublié son nom
donc pierre n'en fait pas partie j'en
suis content pour lui parce que et donc
ces gens qui cherchent l'égalité il se
rend compte qu'il y en a qui réussissent
mieux que d'autres et en c'est en
particulier parce que ils sont plus
beaux c'est un bouquin en Angleterre qui
est sorti qui m'avait fait rigoler mais
il a 50 ans c'est bun 60 ans 70 ans et
donc il dis c'est insupportable cette
égalité il y en a qui soit beau et il y
en a qui sont Vilin et donc ce qu'on va
faire c'est qu'on va faire subir des ép
l'expérience de chirurgie esthétique
pour que tout le monde soit pareil et
donc ça tous les Anglais passent ils ont
tous la même tête et ça marche pas du
tout ça marche pas du tout parce que il
y en a qui ont du charme et d'autres qui
ont pas de
charme et donc si vous voulez ça marche
pas du tout et quand quand on est
sapioexuel on fait comment ah ben je
sais pas tu tu choisis comme tu veux tu
peux déguiser en femme si tu veux si
mais mais il faut que tu ressembles aux
autres femmes il faut que tu ressembles
aux autres femmes les hommes doent
ressembler sais que ça veut dire
sapiosexuel non ça veut dire quoi tu es
attiré par l'intelligence
euh c'est c'est c'est souvent le cas des
femmes c'est asszusant ce que tu dises
parce que c'est souvent le cas des
femmes les femmes sont très souvent
attirées par les et d'ailleurs il y
avait une pièce de Gir SAÉ c'est ce qui
é oui il compris votre modestie
d'ailleurs c'est ça qui non
mais av il y avait une pièce de girudou
beaucoup d'humour il y avait une pièce
de girudou que doré qui s'appelait
l'apolon bac alors si vous je sais pas
si vous l'avez vu c'était très mignon
l'Appolon Bellac c'était une jeune femme
qui est tirer le diable par la
queue à partir d'un certain moment elle
s'est dit pourquoi le diable enfin bref
elle a elle a elle a commencé à faire
des à approcher les hommes elle leur
disait pas qu'ils étaient intelligents
parce qu'ils le savaient tu vois tous
les hommes sa qu'ils sont savent qu'ils
sont intelligents elle leur disait
qu'ils étaient beau
en général le type qui était crochu
bancal et tout il il était très
satisfait de voir qu'une femme lui
disait qu'il était beau
donc dans une société comme ça cette
femme qui savait parler aux hommes en
leur disant qu'ils étaient beaux parce
que les hommes personne leur dit qu'ils
sont beaux les femmes s'attendent à ce
qu'on s'attendent à ce qu'on dise
qu'elles sont belles mais les hommes on
leur dit jamais qu'ils sont beaux et
donc elle volit de succès en succès à
partir de ce moment-l vous pouvez le
dire c'est une fè de girodou la Polon
bac c'est à mourir de rire et donc ce
que font nos hommes politiques
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il vous disent je
suis don monsieur est un éminent
exemplaire s'appelle Pierre deè fois deè
fois pardon don pierre est un éminent
exemplaire ils disent je suis pas pour
l'égalité que tout le monde soit pareil
je veux que simplement chacun soit libre
mais les deux sont en inomique vous ne
pouvez pas être pareil vous pouvez pas
être libre si l'autre vous boutte toute
la
journéeenemi l'égalité et la liberté
c'estes deux notions qui sont
complètement antinomiques ça ne peut pas
survre ensemble vous pouvez avoir une r
problème il y a des écoles où il y a
marqué liberté égalité
fraternité mais non au contraire
justement c'est la tension qui est
intéressante justement tu vas recevoir
la parole mais jeis terminer avant d'en
finir jeis en terminer je dis simplement
si vous êtes libre c'est ce que disait
solitine qui a beaucoup souffert d'un
excès de liberté comme chacun
sait comme disait sol il disait si vous
êtes dans une société où les gens sont
libres ils ne peuvent pas tre égau dans
une société où les gens sont égaux ils
ne peuvent pas être libres donc arrêtez
de parler d'égalité c'est un mensonge
vous n'êtes
pas dans une soci dans une position
égale à celle des autres puisque vous
êtes député européen donc vous avez un
pouvoir sur nous qui est absolument
considérable et qu'est-ce qui vous donne
le droit d'exercer ce pouvoir sur moi
rien avant que tu donnes la parole à
Pierre je voudrais poser une question
Charles oui je vais me faire la voocab
c'est quand même étonnant tu par pardon
et tu montes pas ta voix sur moi parce
que sinon je vais monter tu veux que je
monteç je suis remis à est-ce que tu
veux que je monte je me suis remis à la
muscu peu d'au oui on va t'emmener ça
tout de suite s'il te
plaît Charles je vais me faire l'avocat
du diable est-ce que pour toi l'égalité
c'est un ivellement vers le par le bas
l'égalité c'est la tentation du diable
chacun d'entre nous est libre dans
chacun d'entre nous on a la capacité à
être on a un projet pour chacun entre
nous chacun d'entre nous doit travailler
toute sa vie à savoir quel est ce projet
et l'égalité c'est un désir de te
ramener dans quelque chose qui n'est pas
ton projet ce que tout le monde fait
donc pour moi la base de la de la
chrétienté la base du christianisme
c'est cet appel est perdu soyez libre
pour savoir quel est le projet que Dieu
a pour vous qu'est-ce que tu penses de
la nuit du 4
août bah la nuit du 4 août c'était un
des moments où l'aristocratie française
a n'a pas compris que la bourgeoisie
était l'ennemi en fait le grand problème
de la Révolution française c'est que ça
s'est passé on aurait dû avoir
logiquement une alliance entre les les
bon les pays les les les aristocrates et
le peuple contre la bourgeoisie ça
aurait été la chose normale et en fait
avec l'histoire du on a eu la
bourgeoisie qui a pris le pouvoir sur
les deux et ça depuis la France a plus
été ce qu'elle était quoi c'était le
peuple a été mis en esclavage je par la
bourgeoisie Charles par que n'aurait
jamais fait la noblesse Charles tu peux
donner la parole à Pierre s'il te plaît
c'est fa en le
regardant je peux pas regarder les gens
boire en même temps hein ah bah bon
c'est pas vrai si je peux lui faire un
toast
pierre liberté égalité fraternité c'est
cé intéressant ce que tu soulevais mais
oui dire que l'égalité ça force ça mène
au déclin ça mène le nivellement non on
est aussi de clonage mais qu'on soit
qu'on part du principe que tout homme
toute femme a une dignité est capable de
participer à la vie de la soci
peut participer au débat public voilà je
suis député pendant 5 ans parce qu'on
m'a confié une responsabilité je le vois
comme un service et on verra si je fais
5 ans de plus ou pas mais je me vois
comme quelqu'un qui est au service de de
la communauté et et et vous pourrezêtre
députter un jour et vous pourrez
députter vous pourrez être un député
voilà si vous voilà mais donc je trouve
assez choquant de de renoncer au
principe je renonce oui ça c'est ça je
peux témoigner mais oui mais si on
laisse la politique aux gens les plus
corrompu et les plus cyniqu ça va pas
s'améliorer oui oui on se prend des
coups oui quelqu'un m' expliquer encore
l'Our un journaliste que sur d cétait
beaucoup trop honnête pour faire de la
politique oui mais mais on va pas laiss
vanité il t'a pas donné la
parole pas don la
Paro je c'est je suis très heureux je
trouve que c'est très très beau ce
triptique liberté égalité fraternité et
qu' a une tension et le mot clé
peut-être c'est la fraternité c'est pour
ça je dis et si c'était ton frère qui
avait un petit boulot merdique à 500 €
et si c'était ton frère qui n'ait pas de
logement correct et du coup c'est pas un
problème théorique si on va se donner
les moyens mon frère je passe pas mon
temps à être collé avec lui on a on peut
être mais si mon frère est dans la rue
je me dis pas oh c'est dommage les
statistiques sont pas bonnes si c'est
mon frère ou ma sœur qui est dans la
mouise je vais me dire voilà si c'est
mon fils qui a un boulot merdique si
c'est pendant 3 mois c'est pas très
compliqué c'est pas très grave mais si
c'est pendant 15 ans que les gens
survivent ou sousvivent avec des boulots
à 500 € si c'était mon frère ou votre
frère ou votre fille vous diriez non
c'est pas possible voilà et quand c'est
donc c'est pour ça et c'est au nom de la
liberté justement parce que chacun on a
qu'une vie quoi et c'est parce que pour
on peut pas vivre librement si on passe
son temps à se demander je voyais
l'autre jour une amie qui qui va être
sur notre liste qui est au RSA et qui
Isabelle morer qui vit à mulouse et qui
se qui en même temps a de tempsend des
petits boulots pour améliorer le RSA et
qui a une fois m'avait dit qu'à chaque
fois qu'il y avait quelqu'un qui sonnait
elle avait peur que ce soit Luissier qui
vienne pour la [__] dehors et ben on
n'est pas libre il y a une fois Julie
dit est-ce qu'Isabelle est-ce que tu
veux qu' prenne un petit café ensemble
et elle était contente qu'on prenne elle
me dit mais en gros la question c'est
qui va payer est-ce que c'est toi ou
est-ce que c'est moi voilà et je pense
que pour nous tous ici on s'en fout un
café à 1,50 € on s'en fout pas non mais
1,50 € mais par contre il y a des
millions de gens pour qu' la moindre
dépense 1,50 € voilà donc je ne sais pas
comment on peut être libre quand à
chaque fois qu'il y a quelqu'un qui
sonne on a la troule que ce soit l'
Luissier est g mais non c'est juste
mais juste alors non mais vraiment j'ai
l'impression d'entendre du Z là
faites-moi pitié un peu pant il y a
5600000 inscrits à Paul emploi le
journal Les Échos c'est pas un journal
de gauchiste disait le chômage remonte
depuis quelques mois et il y a toujours
on n'est jamais passé enessous la barre
des 3 millions de gens qui font Z0 heur
par semaine et au total il y a 5600000
hommes et femmes qui sont inscrits à pa
emploi donc ça veut dire qu'ils n'ont
pas un revenu correct ils n'ont pas un
boulot correct et donc vous vous vous en
foutez c'est du Patos non mais il a dit
dès le début dans sa le chômage ne
l'intéresse pas il a dit dès le début on
va pas remonter il a dit dans sa
présentation l' ch chage j'en a Ren à
fout c'est le j'ai cré des emplois toute
ma vie vous en AZ CR combien vous cré
combien j'étais patron j'étais salarié
chômeur patron de PME j'ai fait un peu
tout dans ma vie voilà euh désolé donc
vous êtes un homme admirable mais je ne
suis pas la pas un homme
admirable je je pense que beaucoup de
gens ne se rendent pas compte pourquoi
il y a besoin de réguler le marché du
travail on vit une métamorphose
considérable ça c'est une courbe qui
vient de du de l'ancien ministre de Bill
Clinton Robert Reich qui dit que aux
États-Unis le volume de production a
augmenté de 80 %. le volume de
production industrielle il dit
évidemment ça aurait été mieux si la
Chine avait respecté des règles sociales
ce serait mieux si l'OMC non mais il dit
environnemental et environnemental mais
il dit on peut pas faire comme si toute
l'industrie s'était effondrée le volume
de production sur le territoire
américain a presque doublé mais avec les
robots avec les ordinateurs avec
l'intelligence qu'on a mis dans la tête
des gens on a besoin de 30 % de travail
en moins elle est où larition ça n
pardon j'y viens ce n'est pas la fin du
travail ce n'est pas la fin du travail
dans tous les secteurs là il y a deux
deux caméraman qui voilà il y a besoin
partout d'avoir des gens il faut des
agriculteurs le les carottes poussent
pas tout seul il faut des gens qui se
lèvent dans tous les métiers on a
toujours besoin de travail mais il y a
besoin globalement de 30 % de travail en
moins et donc ou bien on laisse 30 % de
gens dans la mouise au chômage ils sont
à 0 he par semaine ou des petits boulots
ou bien on relance la négociation sur le
temps de travail et Robert Reich
l'ancien ministre de Clinton dit il faut
réduire le temps de travail et
aujourd'hui dans toute l'Europe dans
toute l'Europe le débat revient sur la
semaine de 4 jours aujourd'hui dans tous
les pays on a un partage du travail qui
est binaire soit vous êtes à 0 he par
semaine soit vous travaillez beaucoup
trop et donc petite pub j'ai 0 centime
de droit d'auteur je publie un petit
livre qui explique comment 500
entreprises sont déjà passées à 4 jours
32h sans baisse de salaire et sans
augmenter les coûts de production si
vous mangez un yaourt maminova tous les
salariés de maminova si vous mangez un
yaourt de cette entreprise je ne suis
pas actionnaire c'est c'est juste pour
dire que c'est possible dans les
entreprises concurrentielles 500
entreprises du secteur privé c'est pas
l'état 500 entreprises du secteur privé
ici il y a 800 salariés il y en a
seulement trois là c'est du fromage et
des yaourt là c'est des chararpantes
métalliques là c'est des logiciels là
c'est une entreprise de pub ils sont
tous passer à 4 jours 32h et si
l'entreprise crée des emplois elle
arrête de payer les cotisations chômage
c'est comme ça que c'est possible sans
baisser les salaires et sans augmenter
les clients n'ont pas vu la différence
le prix du yaourt n'a pas augmenté et
c'est un meilleur partage du travail ça
permet d'avoir accès à la formation ça
permet de faciliter les recrutements ça
permet un nouvel équilibre de vie et je
préfère un partage du travail où tous
hommes et femmes on est à 4 jours ou
tous jeunes et vieux on est à 4 jours
plutôt qu'un partage du travail qui est
binaire où il y a des millions de
chômeurs qui font zé he par semaine et
d'autres qui travaillent trop Charles je
voudrais que tu poses deux questions à
Pierre et ensuite pierre je voudrais que
tu poses deux questions à Charles et
après j'aimerais qu'on passe à mes
questions Charles
vas-y alors la la question essentielle
c'est pour moi dans la question la
question que je vais poser mais je vais
poser de façon ça que nécessite un tout
petit peu
d'enveloppage c'est de dire dans le fond
le grand mystère c'est la création de
valeur pourquoi quelque chose quelquun
cré-t-il simplement une comme ça à
partir de rien il y avait quelque chose
qui existe alors qu'avant ça existe pas
donc cette création de valeur c'est un
peu comme un artiste si tu veux donc qui
d'un seul coup créer un truc qui
n'existe pas donc la création de valeur
c'est ce qu'il a de plus de mystérieux
dans l'économie et la réalité c'est
quand tu regardes les études d'un homme
qui s'appelait Pareto qui était un
italien français qui a enseigné en
France aussi la fin du 19e au début du
20e ce qu' disait c'est que 80 % de la
valeur été créé par 20 % des gens et que
la quasi totalité des phénomènes sociaux
cétait débrouillé selon la loi de par
c'est que 80 % des accidents de la route
sont fait par 20 % des conducteurs 80 %
dealcool en France est bu par 20 % des
ivroges et donc 80 % de valeur est créé
par 20 % des gens c'est quoi ta source
de ça c'est la la distribu de lo par ça
existe dans tous les phénomènes sociaux
tu le trouves dans tous les bouquins
c'est ça n'a jamais été prouvé mais le
chiffre sonne bien
Pareto av fait l'étude sur les grandes
fortunes italiennes et il avait
découvert que 80 % des fortunes étaient
détenu par 20 % des gens donc ah mais ça
qui que les capitaliste accumulle la
richesse oui pas dire ex vous prenez
vous y con non mais vous prenez moi
arrivé publier deux ou trois livres que
j'ai publié que j'ai écrit pendant mes
vacances sur les Platan et parce que ça
m'amuser et ce qu' avait d'intéressant
si vous voulez c'est que mon éditeur me
disait que 80 % de ces tirages se
faisait avec 20 % des
auteurs c'est toujours pareil toutes les
lois toutes les lois sociologiques sont
distribué 80 % des
types 20% des types couchent avec 80 %
des femmes c'est pareil paril
c'estàdire je veux la courbez vous avez
qu' aller dans l'université quand vous
êtes à l'université il y a 20 % des
types qui ont un succès fou auprès des
filles et puis il y en A0 80 % qui tient
la langue pose ta question à Pierre s'il
te plaît donc ma question c'est toute
simple c'est une société égalité
ce qu'elle fait c'est qu'elle détruit
comme on l'a fait avec beaucoup
d'intérêt et beaucoup de compétences par
exemple les régimes stalinien ou des
choses comme ça vous détruisez les
créateurs de richesse vous détruisez les
artistes qui pensent pas comme tout le
monde à force de chercher l'égalité
c'està-dire que les sociétés qui comme
but l'égalité termine toujours dans un
compamp de concentration les comités les
les les sociétés qui ch pas je connais
pas d'exemple opposés c'est toujours le
camp de concentration et les sociétés
qui vont vers la liberté
mine toujours avec des artistes et et
des PAL les farnaises et des choses qui
marchent donc est la question la
question c'est il faut faire monsieur a
beau faire des des bruits
d' à qui on donne une carotte mais le
plus simple c'est quand même un ça fait
pas ce bruit là tu as entendu un quand
tu lui don une carotte qu'il VI faire un
cheval oui un cheval oui pareil quel est
ta question auprès de ma question c'est
pour que le monde change il faut que
vous laissiez les libre les gens
compétent elle est où il est où le point
d'interrogation ben donc sa question
c'est son histoire d'égalité ça se
termine en général avec des camps de
concentration mais quelle était la
question mais la question c'est la
recherche de l'égalité dans la société
ne marche jamais voilà quelle est la
question merci beaucoup c'est super
c'est voilà c'est vite vu pour moi on ne
peut pas être cette banalisation des
camps de concentration devient vraiment
gênant pant je suis désolé on peut pas
dire que le camp de concentration c'est
quand même un truc un peu monstrueux qui
a vraiment existé il y a eu des dizaines
de millions de mors après ça parler des
conséquences runion soviétique je suis
confus ok pardon c'était pas cé aut les
autres les autres ils étaient tous
différta horrible pardon non non vous
avez touours TR troué que les camp de
concentration soviétique c'était mieux
quand même ah vous en êtes sûr vous avez
des preuves écrites que je soutiens
Staline vous m'avez vu petit avec St
j'ai pas d vous vous avez vous avez des
gens qui ont gouverné avec le par vous
AZ gouverné ave
Michel je suis un ami de Staline et j'ai
moimême tu des gens qui n'étaient pas
stadinien voilà vous vous m'avez mis à
nu euh après ça l'idé que 20 % des gens
font 80 % des richesses mais c'est quoi
ce Pipo excusez-moi mais quelqu'un un
infirmier une infirmière qui s'occupe
d'un malade crée de la richesse un
médecin quelqu'un qui se lève le matin
et qui va s'occuper du RER pour que même
s'il est pas bien il a pas dormi mais il
va quand même s'occuper pour que le RER
fonctionne il crée de la richesse un
professeur ma femme est professeur quand
elle transmet une langue à des à des
élèves et qu'elle essaie de les éduquer
à la liberté à la réflexion personnelle
elle crée de la richesse je suis désolé
et en même temps il y a des gens qui
inventent un truc qui est vraiment
nouveau effectivement y compris des
chercheurs quand ils ont inventé les
écrans tactiles internet ce sont des
chercheurs et des chercheuses payés avec
nos finances publiques européennes et
aujourd'hui l'Europe n'est pas le le la
catastrophe dont vous parlez on est y
compris avec votre critère on est ceux
qui dépose le plus de brevet de brevets
sur les nouvelles énergies donc après ça
expliquez que la recherche de l'égalité
ça amène au cun de concentration c'est
juste une honte j'ai retrouvé non pardon
je frais quand même Roosevelt est-ce que
rosevelt est un stinien on a le temps tu
es pas sur un plateau télé d'accord il
commence pas tes phrases par pardon tout
le temps char j'aimerais que tuarrêtes
tes blagues avec ou tes parallèles avec
les comp de concentration oui c'est pas
une blague c'est pas pas une blague mais
la loi de Pareto c'est la loi qui est le
plus connu dans le système aujourd'hui
par exemple 80 % des impôts en
france% ça me met profondément mal à
l'aise oui vas-y ok pierre je veux que
tu poses une question à
Charles quand tous ceux qui avaient
connu la crise de 29 disent qu'il faut
des règles sociales avant de convoquer
pon je finis jeou non j'ai pas le
contraire avant de prendre un mois à
Breton Woods là on VO Roosevelt et les
autres il y a qu'une femme mais elle a
eu un rôle crucial cétait la min du
travail de rooswelt voilà il signe avant
de prendre un mois à Breton Woods un
mois pas 3 heur entre deux avions pour
reconstruire le système financier et
monétaire voilà mais la première chose
que fait Roosevelt c'est signé la
déclaration de Philadelphie il n'y aura
pas de paix durable sans justice sociale
la pauvreté ou qu'elle existe et est un
anger pour la prospérité de tous le
travail n'est pas une marchandise même
si a des millions chômeurs on peut pas
baisser les salaires comme quand vous
allez au marché TR livres de de poireau
allez on brade à la fin et bien non ceux
qui avaient connu la crise de 29 pensent
qu'il y a une dignité que au nom de la
dignité humaine et parce que le salaire
ça compte dans l'économie il faut des
règles sociales donc ces gens-là sont
tous des sal celuilà c'est qui je sais
pas c'est un des membres de l'équipe de
Roosevelt pardon je les connais pas tous
mais est-ce que ces gens-l sont tous des
salignens parce que lui avit le
principal le principal conseiller de
roosev le New Deal de rosevel ça tenu 30
ans sans avoir sans aucune crise
financière c'était tous et le leur
recherche c'était la dignité leur au sol
c'était la dignitéégalité pas la fe cont
ton micro s'il te plaît pardon tuas pas
la feuille contre n touche pas ok donc
voilà est-ce que ces gens étaient des
staliniens dangereux ou est-ce qu'ils
ont juste donné sauver la démocratie
sauver la cohaison sociale
accessoirement aider l'Europe à se
sauver des nazis mais qu'ils ont permis
de mettre en place un système qui a été
équilibré pendant 35 ans sans avoir sans
aucune crise financière et sans avoir
besoin de dette juste parce qu'on
respectait la dignité de tout le monde
et qu'on disait il faut des règles la
déclaration de Philadelphie il faut des
règles sur le temps de travail sur le
salaire minimum et sur comment on
finance la retraite des vieux la
question est-ce que est-ce queation
politique monsieur est en campagne
est-ce que mettre en place des campagne
veut me convaincre est-ce que mettre en
place des outils de régulation c'est pas
300 pages de formulaire mais est-ce que
mettre en place des régulations pour
respecter la dignité de tout le monde et
qu'il a un salaire correct à côté du
travail et que y compris quand il y a
besoin de moins de travail parce qu'on a
fait des gains de productivité on peut
baisser le temps de travail après tout
il y a un siècle tout le monde travaille
3 jours trois fois plus il y a aucun
doute que depuis un siècle nos arrière-
grandsparents travaillaient 7 jours sur
7 de 12h par jour jour les enfants
allaient à l'usine voilà et on a eu donc
il y a aucun doute que on a divisé par
TR le temps de travail est-ce que la
prochaine étape ce n'est pas encore de
baisser le temps de travail aller vers
la semaine de 4 jours pour que tout le
monde puisse vivre mieux et qu'on crée
des emplois et qu'on a accès à la
formation tout au long de la vie réponse
alors vous avez deux définitions du
travail il y en a une qui vient du latin
instrument de
torture c'est la la Bor c'est celui sur
lequel on mettait les esclaves qui
voulaient pas travailler et l'autre qui
a déf mission chrétienne du travail
c'est un
accomplissement et donc moi si monsieur
a une envie de travailler comme me
disent les dames
anglaises que j'ai bien connu parce que
j'ai vécu 10 20 en
Angleterre avoir un mari à la maison
c'est avoir plus de mari et moins
d'argent ce qui est pas une combinaison
gagnante
donc moi mon ambition dans la vie c'est
pas que les gens arrêtent de travailler
ce qui me paraît complètement crétin si
je peux me permettre c'est autre chose
c'est que tout le monde a un travail
qu'il adore et fasse 7 jours sur 7 ce
qu'il aime donc ce que j'aimerais c'est
qu'on foute bien la paix aux gens et
qu'on les laisse décider de combien ils
veulent travailler s'ils adorent leur
boulot et ben qu'il le fassent 7 jours
sur 7 si c'est ça qui leur plaît j'ai
pas quand vous je je vivais en Chine à
Hong Kong quand je parlais des 35 heur
aux ouvriers chinois ils étaient morts
de rire moi il y a rien qui me plaît
plus que de travailler j'adore mon
boulot je le fais depuis 50 ans par
passion j'ai pas besoin de travailler
pour gagner de l'argent ça laissé du
temps pour éduquer tes enfants bah
faudra leur demander à eux mais les
quatre se débrouillent plutôt bien et on
je passaer du temps avec eux à déjeuner
et cetera oui oui je crois que je les ai
plutôt bien éduqué par exemple j'ai
toujours refusé de rentrer après 6h du
soir parce que je voulais pas rester au
bureau il me faisait brire je je voulais
rester avec mes enfants et être avec eux
donc oui je les ai bien élevés je crois
que je les ai bien élevés mais ce que je
veux dire c'est que arrêtez de nous
emmerder avec le travail le travail ce
n'est pas une malédiction si vous êtes
dans un travail qui est une malédiction
comme Monsieur semble avoir fait toute
sa vie et je le plains beaucoup comme
Pierre pardon est-ce que j'ai pas dit
que c'était une malédiction et vous a
vou les empêcher de le faire imaginez
pardon excusez-moi les empêcher il y a
une enquête qui vient de sortir qui dit
que 77 % des Français veulent un nouvel
équilibre ils veulent en même temps un
vrai travail ça n'est pas une
malédiction et la plupart des gens
veulent en même temps un vrai boulot je
peux faire finir une phras non vous
m'avez interrompu j'ai pas fini allez-y
vous faut pas interrompre les gens et
ensuite vous vous plainre d'être
interrompu allez-y mais to il faut pas
lui lancer des pics parce que euh il va
finir par répondre il aura bien raison
d'ailleurs donc c'est donc ce que
j'essaie de dire c'est tout simple c'est
que grâce à un certain nombre
d'inventions qui ont été les faites du
capitalisme et de personne d'autre tout
le monde aujourd'hui a accès à la
connaissance vous pouvez aller sur le
net et trouver les meilleur professeur
du monde vous formez vous avez pas
besoin de toutes ces crânes Deuf dans
les universités qui vous apprennent que
des bêtises vous pouvez faire une vous
pouvez c'est ce qu'on voit en Inde où
les enfants apprennent par eux-mêmes sur
le net ce qui est une révolution
inimaginable donc vous êtes plus obligé
de faire des travails idiots et tout ce
que je demande c'est foutez la paix aux
gens j'ai pas besoin qu'un politique qui
cherche à se faire élire viennent me
dire combien d'heures je dois travailler
je suis libre de travailler autant que
je veux j'ai pas besoin de vous et et si
les autres veulent pas travailler ils
travailleront pas et ça c'est vraiment
pardon c'est juste est- que Charles tu
donnes la parole ce que je dis c'est le
travail comme avait dit moi je vais le
dire mais je vais laisser la parole
après j'ai été chez ma fr fromageèire il
y a quelques semaines je lui dit vous
travaillez beaucoup ma pauvre dame elle
m'a dit mais monsieur y a-t-il autre
chose que le travail dans la vie il y
avait mais je me suis marré parce que sa
vie c'était ses fromages et si on le
fait travaer tout le monde n'a pas la
même volonté ce le faites pas travailler
mais forcez pas ceux qui ont envie de
travailler depu depuis quand on je
propose de forcer quoi que ce soit je la
semaine à 4 jours je red que T
parenthèse si vous m'autorisez Charles
tu t'es planté sur les terres
ukrainiennes vendu à Montsanto cargil
dont et euh il y avait aussi BL BL bla
d'ord AFP fact check c'est faux bien que
le marché foncier s'ouvre
progressivement la loi sur les ventes de
terres agricoles en vigueur en Ukraine
n'autorise pas de telles transactions
avec des acteurs étrangers on explique
plusieurs ont expliqué plusieurs
spécialistes de politique agricole à la
FP je suis surpris parce que moi j'avais
lu le contraire mais est-ce que tu as
une autre question pour Pierre tu as lu
le contraire où sur non j'avais lu le
contraire un peu partout si tu veux par
exemple Black Rock Black Rock tu des des
terrain des terrains
immenses au bu de filtre non non non
mais Black Rock ENF j'ai rien contre
Black Rock c'est un M principx une autre
question pour Pierre ben la question
c'est pourquoi vous voulez toujours
organiser la vie des gens pourquoi vous
les laissez pas libre de faire ce qu'ils
veulent s'ils veulent travailler toute
la journée qui travaill toute la journée
qu'est-ce qui vous donne le droit de
dire vous allez travailler que 4 jours
c'est juste c'est juste que je me rends
compte qu'il y a une énorme aspiration
la languette qui dit que 77 % des gens
veulent en même temps un vrai boulot ils
veulent un vrai boulot intéressant où on
travaille avec d'autres on a un revenu
correct on peut progresser et en même
temps du temps pour vivre voilà et et
tant mieux si on si c'est possible et je
vois bien que le débat r dans T les P
question été posé mais est-ce que vous
voulez passer à 4 jours 32h même à Davos
pour vous dire comment les esprits
évoluent je pense que le covid-19
peut-être que vous vous avez un boulot
passionnant peut-être que vous êtes
complètement li tout seul oui mais très
bien mais voilà mais il y a aussi des
gens qui qui veulent parce que ils sont
c'est pas eux qui décident de tout ils
ont un patron ils ont des collègues en
même temps il ce travail les intéresse
je répète ça n'est pas la fin du travail
ni dénigrer la valeur travail je n'ai
jamais dit que c'éit une malédiction je
votre trouve votre argument pas très
honnête je n'ai jamais dit que c'est une
malédiction par contre c'est une
malédiction d'avoir 5 millions de chaôur
et de précaire il y a des gens qui se
flinguent toutes les semaines parce
qu'ils sont au chômage dans la précarité
et donc la semaine de 4 jours permet en
même temps pour ceux et celles qui
avaient déjà un boulot d'avoir un nouvel
équilibre y compris d'avoir accès à la
formation je me souiens un salarié d'une
PME qui disait on en a parlé avec ma
femme on a envie de passer à 4 jours
pour pouvoir se former il dit ça fait 20
ans que j'ai pas mis le nez dans un
livre à chaque fois je dis à mon patron
je voudrais me former il me dit c'est
une bonne idée mais pas maintenant et
monsieur disait le soir je suis crevé le
weekend il y a les enfants je peux
jamais me former et il dit si on passe à
4 jours on aura du temps pour se former
donc il y a il y a des gens qui veulent
passer à 4 jour pour avoir du temps pour
être cool pour aller à la piscine pour
voir un copain une copine il y en a
c'est pour se former il y en a c'est
pour s'engager dans la vie associative
chacun est libre en tout cas je vois que
dans tous les pays d'Europe le débat
revient et juste je demande pas qu'on
passe tous à 4 jours 32h je dis juste
qu'il faudrait qu'il y ait des aides
pour que les entreprises puissent passer
à 32h sans baisse de salaire en disant
qu'elle prit moins de cotisation
aujourd'hui on paye des cotisations
pour les conséquences pour per les
conséquences du chômage notre idée avec
la le changer l'Europe c'est qu'on peut
ACC aider les entreprises il y a aucune
obligation mais aider les entreprises à
passer à 32 heur sans baisse de salaire
en disant si vous créez des emplois si
vous créez 10 % d'emplois en CDI vous
arrêtez de payer les coations en chômage
juste 2 minutes sur la question du temps
de travail parce qu'on entend beaucoup
de blagues vous auriez je voudrais vous
interrompre une seconde parce que
j'aurais aimé être prévenu que j'allais
avoir à faire quelqu'un qui était en
campagne électorale moi je pensais que
j'allais avoir affaire à quelqu'un avec
qui on allait discuter il a été invité à
av été invité à titre de je disais la
même chose mais ça me fait un peu de
peine parce que moi je m'étais pas
préparé je pensais avoir une discussion
intéressante avec quelqu'un dans j'ai
des j'ai des arguments il me sort des
documents il me sort des graphiques tout
mais pardon il y a 30 ans que je sors
les mêmes graphiques parce que et ça ne
fait que ça gravit voilà mais moi moi
j'ai fait plein de graphiqu moim-même
mais je pensais qu'on allait discuter
entre gens intelligents et non pas avoir
une discussion de comptoir sur la façon
dont il faut créer des emplois et rendre
les gens
heureux c'est pas mais c'est pas
vraiment le sujet de la tion le sujet de
réation tel que je l'avais compris
c'était comment pouvons-nous nous sortir
en Europe compte tenu des contraintes
qui existent sur nous et comment on va
réussir à sortir du merdier dans lequel
on est sans un appauvrissement
généralisé lutter contre le chômage fait
partie de sortir du merdier je suis j'ai
bien compris que c'est pas votre pas le
temps de travail que vous allez créer du
que vous allez créer des LO quel est la
durée du travail au Pays-Bas just
Charles je celui quie quelle est la
durée moyenne du travail au pour
répondre à des questions je suis pas je
suis pas votre étudiant par semain 29h
c'est les chiresat 29h ben oui moins de
chôage en Europe c'est en Suisse où il
travaille 42 simplement au Pays-Bas
c'est la ministre du Travail qui d à
Davos la arrêtez de me casser les pieds
avec des statistiques et des chiffres on
parle parle de principe on parle de
principe restons dans le flou restons
dans le flou je reste pas dans le flou
soyons pour le soyons pour la liberté
soyons pour la liberté de ceux qui ont
500 € par mois qui sont englués depuis
20 ans dans les petit boulot est-ce que
tu comprends son point de vue c'estàd
que mais non il refuse de voir la
réalité pardon il vit d' un monde de
rêver ou la liberté RG problè j'ai créé
des dizaines et dizaines d'emplois vous
en avez jamais créé mais si pant je vous
dis j'ai créé uneure vous avez été nommé
moi je est-ce que tu comprends son point
de vue moi je veux être libre c'est
pasile mais le gars qui dit je veux être
libre je vauxis être libre pardon et que
les autres soient libres estce ben voilà
je veux faire des citoyens je veux pas
faire des su est-ce qu'on se rend compte
de la mutation du travail pendant qu'il
fait qu'on a on produit deux fois je
vais pasortir aujourd'hui c'est pas
d'êre de droite ou de gauche libérale ou
pas libérale c'est aujourd'hui avec les
robot avec les ordinateurs avec
l'intelligence on a multiplié par 8 le
nombre d'étudiants et d'étudiantes en
France qui font une études après le bac
donc cette double
révolution divisé par nombre d'étud on a
multipié par 8 cette double révolution F
des études de sociologieachement pardon
mais merci pour les sociologues surtout
ne jamais réfléchir vous avez raison
donc cette double révolution cette
double révolution technologique et
intellectuel fait que on produit
beaucoup plus avec 30% de [__] en moin
voilà donc ça c'est vous pouvez pas le
contester donc ou bien quand il y a 30%
de travaill en moins on produit des
biens ça s'appelle la productivité c'est
ça qui permet Nive de vie voilà du coup
pardon non mais est-ce que du coup
est-ce qu'on laisse 30 % de gens dans la
mouise qui font Z0 he par semaine ou qui
sont chur en Suisse excusez-moi mais je
connais bien l'Allemagne l'autre jour
vous avez cité l'exemple de l'Allemagne
la Suisse un peu un paradis fiscal qui
attire mais l'Allemagne l'Allemagne la
durée moyenne la su fiscale c'est encore
un gros mensonge de la gauche bien sûr
l'Allemagne la durée Mo moyen est à 34
he tellement il y a des petits boulots à
10h par semaine donc nous faire croire
que la France est le pays qui travaille
le moins et je finis sur les Pays-Bas
l'autre jour à Davos il y avait un débat
même à Davos la ministre du Travail
disait aujourd'hui au Pays-Bas la durée
moyenne est à 29h par semaine 29h mais
le problème c'est qu'il y a des
différence terrible entre les femmes
presque toutes les femmes sont à 3 jours
et presque tous les hommes sont à 5
jours et donc la ministre qui pourtant
une femme de droite disait est-ce que ce
serait pas mieux que hommes et femmes
soi à 4 jours que homme et femme un vrai
sal tout m la même taille ben voyez pas
comme couple on a une égalité le mot
vous fait vomir mais on a une
égalité les hommes et les femmes je peux
pas donner la vie à un enfant je suis
pas égal qu'est-ce que c'est soit donc
ça ça vous inquiète qu'on aille vers une
plus grande égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes au travail mais ça m'inquiète
pas du tout simplement je vois
aujourd'hui qu' la l l'égalité pas entre
les hommes et les femmes il aura plus
d'Européens dans dans 10 ans en tout cas
cette femme qui à l'alure fertilité
s'écroule il y aura plusfant justement
si on avait du temps pour vivre si on
avait du temps et moins de stress
peut-être qu'on aurait plus de temps
pour faire des bébés ou plus envie l'éco
anxiété plus la précaritém l'éco anxiété
vous encore un truc ah l'éco anxiété il
y a pas d'éco anxiété le tout moyen
d'imposition en Suisse c'est 40 % oui
parce qu'il y a plein de choses qui sont
payées oui je sais bien j'en ai mon beau
frère qui travaille en Suisse mais tu
dois payer avec ton argent pour la santé
encore une fois aux États-Unis il y a
moins de cotisation mais le coût de la
santé est deux fois plus important oui
mais on le paye pas par des cotisations
on le paye ceux qui peuvent avec leur
fortune personnelle et il y en a qui
crèvent parce qu'ils n'ont pas accès aux
meilleurs médecins mais ce n'est pas des
cotisations c'est voilà qu'on parle de
création de richesse oui voilà c'est la
seule chose qui soit intéressante dans
la bagarre donc comment tu fais Charles
pour créer de la richesse quand tu as
une énergie qui n'est plus bon
marché alors ça c'est d'abord la
première chose c'est que tu prends la
première chose la première réaction
c'est tu dis bon puisque l'énergie est
devenue cher je vais aller me coller
dans un endroit où elle est pas cher aux
États-Unis ça pe c'est ce qui est en
train c'est comme ça que les États-Unis
ont foutu en l'air l'Europe c'est
simplement en faisant monter le prix de
l'électricité pour toute l'industrie
chimique allemande qui a besoin de
beaucoup d'énergie malheureusement et
donc à ce moment-là et ben on a toute
l'industrie chimique allemande est en
train de partir en Allemagne parce
qu'ils ont de l'énergie pas cher là-bas
parti aux États-Unis ils sont partis ils
sont ils sont quitté l'Allemagne ils
sont tous en train de fermer en
Allemagne donc c'est la première des
choses donc la première des choses si tu
veux c'est comme l'économie qu'on le va
non ça n'est que de l'énergie
transformée est-ce que Pierre tu as
quelque chose à Red dire quand Charles
dit ça c'est rien d'autre he il y a rien
d'autre non je dis pas dans
C vous êtes fatiguant avecos vos images
mais pourquoi c'est juste la dans votre
sens pardon j' dans Mo je trouve où on a
un
déb où on a un débat intellectuel et où
on a un débat où on se de côtés d'une
table vous me donnez la parole 5 minutes
je montre mes petites images on vous
montre les petites images et on aura
tous les deux des montrés d'images mais
je savais pas que j'avais le droit
d'arriver avec des images je pensais que
j'allais parler avec quelqu'un qui
réfléchissait et qui pas qu' allait
monttrer des petites imag ça devient
légèrement gênant juste montrer
l'évolution de l'industrie aux
États-Unis les chiffres officiels
montrer comment en plus ça va dans votre
sens que toute l'industrie part aux
États-Unis c'est pas seulement le coû de
l'énergie c'est qu'ils ont mis des
subventions terribles ils on mis donc
voilà c'est pas des petites images je
suis désolé on entend n'importe vousouz
le dire on comprendra ce que vous venez
de dire là just c'est pas mon opinion
vous quand vous dites le prix des terres
en Ukraine finalement 2 minutes on voit
que c'est pas tout à fait vrai pas mon
opinion c'est juste montrer des chiffres
montrer que c'est pas mon opinion et ici
on a bien fa checker les choses et bien
oui ce sont les chiffres hélas l'Europe
a une vision ï de l'industrie on est de
Laer par notre industrie au ÉtatsUnis
c'est pas une version naïve c'est une
version où il y a pas de stratégie y a
personne à la tête de on est d'accord et
je me bats moi pour qu'il y a des moyens
pour l'industrie Charles dit que le sang
de l'économie je parle S c'est l'énergie
c'est l'énergie tu es d'accord ou tu es
pas ouiidment c'est très importantok
Charles continue il y a rien d'autre
continue Charles si le travail humain ça
compte aussi c'est de l'énergie pas
seulement l'intelligence créativité
c'est pas que l'énergie pardon non
pardon les questions d'éducation par
question c'est pas de la calorie
seulement non pas seulement du temps oui
c'est du temps mais c'est pas seulement
des calories on pas on va pas on va pas
vous avez une relation quasiment
parfaite entre le la consommation
d'énergie et le PIB sur le long terme
bon ça c'est à peu près dans tous les
pays ça se passe partout bon à partir du
moment où vous dites comme j'ai lu avec
stupéfaction l'Europe qui pour des
raisons de
politique écologique a décidé j'avais vu
les documents je cite de mémoire mais
c'était qu'en
1935 quelque chose comme ça il fallait
que notre consommation d'énergie est
baissée primaire et baissé de 20 à 25 %
compte tenu de la relation qui existe
entre les deux ça veut dire que le taux
de chômage va passer à 25 % qu'on va
avoir une dépression comme on en a
jamais eu donc il y a une espèce de
contradiction extraordinaire entre ces
gens qui me disent aujourd'hui j'ai reçu
un homme tout à fait éminent que j'aime
beaucoup qui est très gay qui s'appelle
monsieur Furfari Furfari c'est une des
éminences de la Commission européenne il
a passé sa vie dans les systèmes de
de la Commission européenne et il est
spécialiste de tous les problèmes
énergétiques il vient d'écrire un très
bon livre sur les les problèmes de
l'énergie en Europe et donc ce monsieur
Furfari était était très amusante parce
que il disait quand j'avais 25 ans donc
dans les années 80
j'imagine on il y avait une espèce
d'optimisme extraordinaire à l'intérieur
de la Commission européenne il fallait
prendre des risques il fallait inventer
des trucs il fallait faire des barrages
il fallait trouver de l'énergie le but
c'était d'avoir une énergie pas chère
bon marché abondante ce qui est comme ça
ce qui a toujours été la cause premier
ver de la prospérité tout le reste c'est
du baratin et puis est arrivé à quelque
chose dans à partir de la du milieu des
années 2000 à peu près 2000 2005 2010 là
et d'un seul coup on s'est mis à
considérer l'énergie comme quelque chose
qu'il fallait économiser et qu'il
fallait empêcher de créer et il dit
c'est une abomination parce que ça va
entraîner un approvvissement généralisé
de tout l'Europe mais ce qu'il y a de
plus étonnant c'est qu'il dit si vous
avez si moi je vis je connais bien
l'Inde un petit peu je connais la Chine
et cetera ils en ont rien àirer de nos
machins énergétiques
les tas pas la parole non d'abord c'est
pas faux c'est vrai et ensuite par
exemple il y a eu un un email qui est
sorti de Monsieur maudit qui est quand
même le Premier ministre indien qui est
en train de passer au travers d'un
système électoral dans lequel il se
félicitait bruillamment que la l'Inde
est brûlée un milliard de tonnes de
charbon dans les 12 mois précédents
c'était pour lui un immense succès donc
c'est pas faux c'est juste et donc ce
que j'essaie de dire c'est que ce que
nous prenne le but de tout bon
socialiste allez je vais être
parfaitement breê brutal là c'est pas
que les gens soient heureux c'est pas
que les gens soient prospères c'est que
ce soit lui qui distribue l'étiquet de
rationnement c'est celui qui distribue
le rationnement et le chef dans les
régimes socialistes qui amène toujours
au rationnement donc le but du
socialiste de base c'est le rationnement
et c'est le ticket de rationnement et
c'est lui qui qui décide et je trouve ça
abominable et il font toujours ça dans
l'intérêt de la planète et en attendant
nous on marche les pieds dans la neige
parce qu' eu ils vont en avion donc je
essayie de dire le socialisme c'est
c'est le désastre qui nous qui amène
l'Europe du succès où elle était à cette
espèce de long avais l'impression qu'on
est dans une période très très
socialiste madame vanayon est socialiste
65 % du PIB qui est fait par l'État
c'est c'est ma définition du socialisme
ma définition du socialisme est-ce que
tu donnes la parole à Pierre je donne la
parole à Pierre mais je veux dire ma
définition du socialisme c'est tout par
l'État tout pour l'État et
R animez des mariages ou des Barva parce
que vous avez vraiment un sens de la
blague donc vous trouvez que Madame
Valon est une femme socialiste monsur
Baroso monsieur monsieur Baroso qui été
qui est parti chez Goldman sax corrompu
aussi ah oui donc mais mais pas
socialiste un gars qui va chez Goldman
sax et qui de sa corruption
ven elle refuse de les donner mais c'est
tout simple on sait qu'elle est
corrompu mais je sais pas Baroso je sais
pas siil est corrompu mais c'est pas
vraiment des gens de
gauche il était un trotiste il était le
chef des trist au Portugal il avit 1 ans
non non mais il est passé de
gauche il a tout fait pour pas
sè fin on avait dit qu'on allait faire
la séparation dis je dis Baroso c'est
pas difficile parce que c'est lui en
effet il est parti
immédiatement de la Commission
européenne aux gens qu'il était censé
réglementer qui s'appelle Goldman sax ça
s'appelle de la corruption ça s'appelle
c'est vraiment scandale Kenedy qui a
fait qui a fait le chemin inverse il y a
un Kennedy qui a fait le chemin inverse
le jeune Kennedy il y a un Kennedy qui
est passé de qui est passé de la pardon
qui est passé trader ou gestion d'actif
à encadrement encadrement des marchés je
savais pas qui c'est suelui-à alors
c'est comment il s'appelit ah si si si
c'est le gars il a eu le P il a eu des
tas d'emmerdement il a été viréil a été
viré c'était en
cétait juste par était contre non c'est
beaucoup plus loin que ça ça doit être
en 4 mais Roosevelt avait pris un
banquier pour faire la séparation des
banques un banquier il y a des banquers
intellig av compris qu' fallit faire la
séparation des
Bergie je peux avoir 2 minutes la parole
pierre donc Charles t'a donné la parole
écoute j'aimerais bien avir un coup
d'eau donc pourquoi ce ce pessimismeî un
petit ver d'eau tu peux m' verau s'il te
plat pourquoi ce pessimisme dont vous
parlez c'est juste qu'il y a un tout
petit problème qui nous est tombé sur la
table sur la tête c'est le réchauffement
climatique je sais que vous vous pensez
que c'est de la blague donc je vais pas
vous éner mes graphiques mais le nombre
de catastrophes climatiques a triplé
depuis 30 ans ça ça vient de munique
réassurance des Suisses voilà munique
réassurance pardon pardon je peux bien
sû monie monsieur voilà quand il y a 2
millions d'Allemands qui ont les pieds
dans l'eau les sociétés d'assurance vont
faire faillite elles sont pas elles-mêm
réassurées et donc on a une une courpe
qui montre comment le nombre de
catastrophes climatiques a déjà triplé
depuis 30 ans quand je vais à Bruxelles
c'est très concret il y a eu 200 morts
il y a 2 ans dans les inondations le 13
juillet des gens comme vous et moi je
connais une haute fonctionnaire sa fille
part dans un C scout c'est l'été la vie
est belle on rigole tous les enfants
sont joyeux et puis il pleut il pleut il
pleut il pleut c'est l'horreur 200 morts
200 morts dans les inondations en
quelques heures en Allemagne et en
Belgique donc tout le monde le
réchoement climatique pratiquer le patas
vraiment avec beaucoup d'intérêt c'est
tata non J's bien mais le pat j'aimerais
bien qu'on sorte un pe je veux pas
donner son nom mais cette femme elle a
perdu sa fille elle va faire des
cauchemars toute sa vie si c'était votre
fille qui mourit dans une inondation non
vous en avez rien à [__] vous avez
rien à [__] V le truc du Patos qui me
dit que je je pense pas aux autres j'en
ai marre vous dites en supposant qu'
réchauement climatique je suis désolé
mais si vous êtes je pense que si vous
êtes riche si vous aidez des gens à
gérer leur fortune je suis sûr que dans
votre boulot vous êtes très précis vous
passez votre temps avec des chiffres
avec des logiciels pour calculer et par
contre dès qu'on parle des débats
globaux vous refusez de voir la réalité
donc le nombre de catastrophes
climatiques a triplé et donc c'est pour
ça qu'il faut arriver en même temps
avoir un modèle de prospérité avec moins
de CO2 et donc on moins de CO2 ça veut
pas dire forcément plus aucune énergie
ça veut être des énergies plus propres
qui ne font pas de CO2 et puis la
rénovation thermique les transports en
commun là pour le coup la Suisse que
vous citez la Suisse il y a plus aucun
camion sur les autoroutes ou quasiment
pas les camions sont on va pas dire
obligés sinon vous allez faire une
syncope mais les camions n'ont pas le
choix on les met sur un train les
camions ne peuvent pas traverser la
Suisse et polluer et faire du CO2 et des
des particules fines ils ont investi
massivement dans les transports en
commun suite d'ailleurs à des
référendums c'est le peuple c'est le
peuple Suiss je suis d'accord avec le
besoin de démocratie directe le peuple a
dit on va on veut protéger nos poumons
et on veut protéger la planète et donc
aujourd'hui en Suisse il y a des
transports en commun donc on consomme
moins d'énergie mais on vit bien la
rénovation thermique j'ai vu l'autre
jour un monsieur qui vit dans H&M ça y
est on a fait la rénovation thermique il
dit c'est beaucoup plus confortable j'ai
moins chaud l'été j'ai moins froid
l'hiver et je gagne 800 € chaque année
sur mes dépenses de chauffage je gagne
800 € et ben c'est pour ça que on se bat
au niveau européen pour la taxe sur la
spéculation pour aider de ch mais donc
on peut vivre bien avec moins d'énergie
on peut vivre bien en consommant moins
d'énergie grâce au transport en commun
grâce à la rénovation thermique et faire
des renouvbles personne personne n'a dit
cont si vous avez dit qu'on allait
provoquer une crise une récession vous
avez dit que vouloirs consommer moins
d'énergie pardon je vous écoute vous
avez dit que ce serait une catastrophe
économique si on voulait consommer moins
d'énergie non au contraire on peut créer
900000 emplois en France on met le PA la
ration TH et trans commun et une
transformation de l'agriculture que
beaucoup d'agriculteurs souhaitent on
peut créer 900000 is et faire baisser no
factures de
chauffage monsieur est en
campagne je m chose depuis 15 ans vous
êtes en campagne depuis 15 ans ça peut
pas dire que vous avez raison j'ai connu
vous savez j'avais des j'ai des enfants
et j'ai pas envie qu'il connaissent le
Cha climaatos revoilà un coup du
patossolument exraordinaire il peut rien
dire sans parler des pauvres enfants des
pves on pourrait parler des choses
intelligent qume
j'ai j'ai j'ai je vous demande de choses
à vous deux n venim pas la conversation
non mais je voudrais qu'on arrête de
parler de Patos moi je voudrais sur le
Logos et sur lesos le Patos ça me BR
c'est Mo qui parle oui pardon donc s'il
vous plaît arrête d'en venimer la
conversation un petit coup de petit pic
à gauche petit pic à droite petit c'est
c'est profondément pu bon alors je
voudrais parler un petit peu si je
parler je vais te poser une question
tout de suite ou je voudrais parler truc
est-ce que tu as vu au badh que l'école
l'école a été arrêtée parce qu'il fait
52 degr que le taux d'humidité est monté
au taquet donc ça devient invivable et
comme ils ont pas assez d'argent pour
pouvoir
climatiser ils peuvent plus il très
chaud aux Philippines aussi d'accord
donc est-ce que si tu as pu voir
l'autocensure d'un certain grand
organisme
censé analyser le climat sur
l'augmentation de la température et le
taux d'humidité et les conséquences que
ça peut créer est-ce que tu as entendu
par de ça bien sûr qu'est-ce que tu en
penses alors il y a plusieurs choses
qu'on peut dire alors le book le livre
le plus intéressant qui a peut-être été
publié sur le sujet c'était un livre de
qui s'appelait d'un gars qui s'appelait
CIN alors conis pas hein je ne le
connais pas et ben alors c'était le gars
qui était dans l'administration Obama
responsable de toute la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique le l'écologie
verte et cetera donc c'est un gars qui
est professeur M
et à
caltec et qui a créé à caltec donc qui
est quand même le grand machin
technologique de la côte ouest qui pas
rien aux États-Unis on connaî très bien
parce que on a un pote qui était
enseignant
là-bas c'est Lui qui a créé c'est Lui
qui a créé la chair qui fait les modèles
qui peuvent utiliser en économie et
cetera bon alors il s'appelle Kun il a
publié son livre et son livre c'est the
science is not settled c'est-à-dire que
la science n' n'a pas donné son avis sur
les phénomènes de climatologie la
science n'a pas donné son avis ça a été
un Best cellerire aux États-Unis et donc
vous pouvez donc ce qu' dit c'est que il
y a c'est que la biographie de Nabila
c'est un bellerire aussi hein qui ça la
biographie de nabadie des scienceces à
l'unanimité y compris Claude Allègre
l'unanimité l'ensemble de l'académie des
science après 6 mois de débat non mais
pardon on peut pas laisser dire
n'importe quoi la moi je vous
dis je vous dis ce que
dit je vous dis ce que dit Kunin Kunin
donc c'est le type c'est et il dit il
fait tout son livre que je l avec
beaucoup de soin il dit il est probable
que le il est presque certain que la
température monte quand même bon en
effet c'est pas la première fois dans
l'histoire je vous signale qu'il y avait
des vignes en Islande en 1250 donc dire
que c'est
dit est-ce que c'est de sources humaines
personne n'a pu le prouver de façon
scientifique on peut prouver de façon
scientifique que ça a monté mais
personne n'a prouvé la relation entre le
CO2 et là enfin moi je vous dis ce que
dis cet h moi je suis loin d'être un
spécialiste et il dit donc on a des il y
a personne qui peut bâtir un modèle du
climat qui fonctionne pour prévoir ce
qui se passera la semaine prochaine
peut-être mais pour pour expliquer les
variations personne ne peut expliquer le
climat en remontant 10 ans en arrière
moi j'ai fait des modèles toute ma vie
et je peux vous assurer que les modèle
que je faisais d'habitude je pouvais
expliquer ce qui s'était passé dans le
passé parce que sinon ça sert à rien de
les faire al il y a pas un de ces mod
modèle qui explique ce qui s'est passé
dans le passé donc il il ne
correspondent même pas en rétrofitant il
correspondent pas et donc il disait ça
correspond pas les modèles qu'on utilise
aujourd'hui dans le climat 17 hommes qui
est éminent encore une fois un homme de
gauche tout à fait comme il faut et donc
si il était il était tout à fait il
était dans l'administration Obama le
gars qui était chargé de ça donc on peut
pas être plus de gauche aux États-Unis
en tout cas et donc était un homme
honnête allez-y vous avez fini tous les
deux mais qu'est-ce que ça avoir ça
toujours été une crpule non mais il éta
socialiste pour commencer oh d'accord
donc si vous voulez il gagn de l'argent
avec vous écoutez pierre va te répondre
pierre va répondre non non mais
j'attends bien mais donc je termine
est-ce que le bouquin de ce conin qui a
été un best seller mondial dit
simplement donc on met des modèles des
modèles du
température on va faire des dépenses
absolument gigantesque pour empêcher je
ne sais quoi et on va brancher ces
modèles qui ne marchent pas dans des
modèles économiques qui marche encore
moins bien et parce que je ne connais
pas moi j'ai fait des modèles toute ma
vie je connais si le futur était
connaissable ça saurait le futur est
inconnaissable donc vous mettez deux
trucs qui marchent pas l'un dans l'autre
et vous arrivez un désastre et je
reviens à mon cher monsieur furfar qui
dit quelque chose qui m'a fait rigoler
c'est un scientifique alors docteur en
chimie en physique tout à fait
remarquable l'université de liè je CIS
je sais plus laquel ENF Ty très bien il
ressemble un peu à il ressemble un peu à
arculle poireau voyez il a des petites
moustaches comme ça il est il est tout à
fait sympathique et ce que disait le
monsieur ffari c'est disait l'Europe a
dépensé c'est son chiffre c'est pas le
mien 1000 milliards
d'euros dans toutes les énergies
alternatives là qu'on a créé un peu
partout et après 25 ans de
dépenses le vent et le
soleil correspondent à peu près à 3 % du
euh de la consommation énergétique qu'on
a fait on aurait mis 1000 milliards
d'euros dans ces centrales nucléaires on
aurait plus aucun problème de quelque
façon que ce soit donc il y a une espèce
d'effet monsieur ffari est à la
commission il je veux dire c'est un des
hommes les plus éminents qui soit sur ce
sujet et il a écrit un bouquin qui m'a
beaucoup touché il y a à peu près 10 ans
la première fois j'ai pris contact avec
lui d'ailleurs c'était comment on
pouvait pas être à la fois écologique et
chrétien c'est que l'écologie c'était
quelque chose qui était pessimiste qui
était triste qui était maltusien il y en
aura pas assez pour tout le monde et
c'était abominable il disait lui c'est
un juif qui est converti au
christianisme ça c'est rigolo et il dit
c'est tout à fait remarquable mais on
peut pas être chrétien écologiste et
j'ai trouvé ça tellement vrai Charles tu
peux donner la parole à Pierre s'il PL
c'est fait moi j'ai dit ce que j'avais à
dire c'est que le l'écologie c'est un
truc pessimiste maltusien que les
maltusien T pierre t'as écouté ou je de
temps en temps faisant des
bruitist pessimiste mon mdecin me dit
que j'ai une maladie je préfère qu'il me
soigne plutôt que dire YouUp laabou faut
pas être pessimiste c'est pas un cancer
je suis optimiste je prends des
vitamines et je je préfère qu' médecin
me disent tuas un cancer et on on passe
à la chimie la semaine prochaine voilà
donc s'il y a un problème autant le
regarder en face sur est-ce qu'il y a
est-ce que le est-ce qu' a un
réchauffement estce qu' des activités
humaines pardon vous êtes sans doute un
très grand expert mais on a l'Académie
des Sciences après le livre de Claude
Allègre Claude Allègre a fait un bouquin
pour dire peut-être que oui peut-être
que non toutes les courbes étaient à
main levé contrairement à des des idiots
comme moi qui arrivent avec des courbes
d'Eurostat non mais Claude allgre a fait
tous ces et donc l'ensemble de
l'académie des sciences a dit on peut
pas laisser dire n'importe quoi un
ancien ministre de la Recherche et donc
l' après 6 mois de travail Valérie maçon
delmot et plein d'autres femmes et
hommes se sont battus et y compris
Claude Allègre a dû avaler son chapeau
dans le journal Le Monde du 28 octobre
2010 l'Académie des Sciences à
l'unanimité l'Académie des Sciences à
l'unanimité y compris Claude Allègre qui
a eu la honte de sa vie devant ses
collègues dit qu'il n'y a plus aucun
doute sur la réalité du réchauffement
matique et qu'à plus de 95 % il vient du
CO2 humain ça c'était il y a 14 ans et
maintenant c'est à 100 % qu' vient du
CO2 humain sur le fait on aura eu la
totale honnêtement je suis content de
vous avoir rencontré parce que vous en
ratez aucune est-ce que il y a toujours
eu des fluctuations oui il y a toujours
eu des fluctuations mais celle qu'on vit
depuis un siècle est complètement
différente ça c'est le CO2 depuis 800000
ans il se trouve qu'il y a des gens qui
bossent qui en restent pas peut-être que
oui peut-être que non il y a des gens
qui on péril de leur vie il y a des
glaciologues qui meurent vont faire des
carottes de glace au pôle Sud encore un
peu de Patos non tr mais je pense à ce
pauvre glaciologue qui est mort pour
dire qu'il y en a qui bossse il y en a
qui bossent voilà il y en a qui passe
des heures à vérifier des chiffres il
Meur pas mais il Meur pas c'est juste
bien payé allons allons oui Mo moins que
vous sans doute moins que vous pardon je
connais jeis pas pay je vaisux rir je
peux revenir arr Patos ça coupera
Charles pierre est-ce qu'il est possible
d'échanger sans s'en sans dout mes
arguments le gênent pour qu'il s'énerve
c'est sans doute que ces arguments le G
mais ça le gène sansout écoute-moi tu
fais des bruits avec ta bouche donc ce
qu' disent ça gne aussi est-ce que vous
pouvez pas s'il vous plaît échanger en
s'écoutant Charles je l'écoute je répond
à ces question non tu parles sur ma voix
là donc Charles tu écoutes pierre
regarde ce qui te montre Pierre essaie
de montrer sans envoyer des vannes c'est
ce que tu as dans les mains c'est
important c'est le résultat de travail
voilà c'est le résultat de de centaines
et de centaines de glaciologues qui sont
allés faire des carottes de glace voilà
et qui regard ça c'est du gaz qui est là
depuis 50000 ans on analyse son CO2 là
c'est du gaz qui est là depuis 100000
ans donc on voit qu'il y a toujours eu
des fluctuations c'est vrai parce que
notre Terre ne tourne pas de façon
parfaite autour du soleil donc il y a
des grands cycles mais jamais jamais
depuis 800000 ans le CO2 dans
l'atmosphère n'avait dépassé les 280
unités on appelle ça des ppm c'est un
peu comme des hormones on sit même les
hormones thyroïdiennne même si des
petites quantités mais on sait que ça a
une influence considérable donc jamais
depuis 800000 ans on avait dépassé les
24 80 unités de de CO2 dans l'atmosphère
et là vous voyez depuis un siècle quand
vous êtes né Charles je me suis
renseigné on était à 310 unités de CO2
310 1492 non il y a voilà et et le mois
dernier on était à je je je et là ça
n'est pas totalement hilarant le mois
dernier on était à 425 ppm 425 donc ça
veut dire que en un siècle il y avait un
système qui oscilait très très lentement
depuis 800000 ans avec effectivement des
moments un peu plus chaudes des moments
un peu plus froids ça allait très très
très très lentement et c'était un
équilibre et notre modèle industriel et
notre consommation d'énergie fait qu'on
a foutu en l'air ce système ce ce
document ce graphique n'est contesté par
aucun scientifique et le problème c'est
qu' c'est en train de s'aggraver je suis
allé hier sur le site de monaloa donc
c'est un observatoire mis en place par
les scientifiques américains et l'armée
américaine en 1958 donc déjà en 1958 ils
ont mis à 3000 m d'altitude pour être
loin de toutes les industries de toutes
les autoroutes et donc il y a des
scientifi qui se relayent à bonaloa et
tous les jours toutes les semaines il
mesurent le CO2 donc dans dans les
années 60 et 70 le CO2 augmenté sur un
rythme de + 0,8 unités chaque année
Plus+ 0,8 là depuis 5 ans ça va trois
fois plus vite même quand l'économie est
à l'arrêt avec le covid et on dit au
moins il y a une bonne chose avec le
covid le CO2 qui vient des camions
diminués mais les méga feux de forêt
vous allez dire que je fais du Patos 410
morts dans les feux de forêts en
Australie 410 personnes qui sont mortes
soit en une minute soit au bout de 15
jours de souffrance donc des c'est le
réchauffement climatique fait qu'il y a
de plus en plus de feux de forêt et les
feux de forêt font qu'il y a de plus en
plus de CO2 donc même quand l'économie
ralentit à cause du covid ou l'an
dernier il y a une flambée du prix du
pétrole du prix de l'énergie donc la
France fait un peu moins de CO2 mais les
méga les feux le CO2 qui vient des feux
de forêt fait plus que compensé donc oui
il y a une urgence et donc la bonne
nouvelle c'est que ça ne veut pas dire
vivre vivre moins bien on peut faire de
la rénovation thermique je le dis et
consommer beaucoup moins d'énergie et
sortir de notre dépendance au gaz qu'on
importe on peut mettre en place des
transports en commun efficace la Suisse
l'a fait quand le quand le patron de la
SNCF demande d'avoir 100 milliards pour
les transports en commun moi dans mon
coin Pyréné les gens seraient très
contents s'il y avait des transports en
commun les gilets jeunes je les
comprends si on dit que la seule
solution c'est d'augmenter le prix
deessence alors qu'il y a pas de
transport en commun je comprends que les
gens gueulent donc moi mon but je me
suis battu pour qu'il ait de l'argent
pour les transports en commun et après
ça on pourra dire aux gens tu tu n'as
pas besoin de ta voiture et ce serait
moins cher pour toi et plus confortable
de prendre des transports en commun mais
donc vouloir consommer moins d'énergie
ça veut pas dire vivre misérablement on
peut vivre heureux en consommant moins
d'énergie et des énergies non carbonées
alors j'ai j'ai je voudrais rebondir ce
que tu sur ce que tu dis le gaz il vient
o en ce moment là il vient des
États-Unis essentiellement GL je pense
que il y en a encore je suis pas un
spécialiste je mon joker mais je pense
que la Russie en vend à certains pays
qui nous leour France à fond pardon je
pense que pardon là je il y a des
domaines où je suis compétent non mais
donc je crois que la Russie arrive à
contourner une partie de l'embargo et
qu'on achète du GNL qui traverse
l'Atlantique du gaz lifié qui est encore
pire pour la planète donc la question
que je te pose pierre
c'est le réchauffement climatique c'est
une
calamité qu'est-ce qui se passe quand à
l'Inde la Chine les
États-Unis qui disent le train de vie
des Américains n'est pas n'est pas
négociable les Indiens se gargarisent de
cramer combien de millions de tonnes de
charbon char milliard de tonnes attends
est-ce que nous l'Europe alors les
chinois
alors donc est-ce que nous l'Europe on
sert la vis parce que on veut sauver les
bébés Fox sur la banquise on veut que
tout va bien que tout bien et que on est
en train de se faire dépeesser notre
économie parce que les autres ils on
rien à faire je parle pas des bébés F
les 200 personnes pardon mais pardon Je
te dis excuse-moi mais moi je vais pas
donner son nom mais quand je vais voir
cette dame qui est très fonctionnaire à
la commission elle a perdu sa fille elle
va on va dire voilà sa fille était
joyeuse elle part avec ses copines un C
SCO et il pleut et en une heure c'est
fini elle la verra plus jamais vivante
donc c'est pas les béb F les béb F
m'intéresse moins que laère d'humanité
tu veux je te fais des blagues comme tu
fais des bruits avec ta bouche d'accord
on va échanger donc ouais c'est
vachement un échange
donc je suis en train de te poser la
question la Chine elle en a rien à faire
c'est pas vrai la Chine la Chine inves
beaucoup plus dans les renouvelables que
nous la Chine investit beaucoup plus
dans les renouvelbles que nous la Chine
est en train de te dire qu'ils
investissent dans les renouvelables mais
ils sont toujours en train de consommer
du charbon j'ai pas dit qu'il avent stop
le sont toujours en train de construire
des barrages et virer les mecs qui
habitent dans la
vallé train de construire des réacteurs
nucléaires à gogo et s'ils peuvent te
sortir qu'ils vont construire des
énergies renouvelables parce que c'est
banqu dans les médias eux ça les arrange
parce que ils continuent leur mix
énergétique pas seulement que c'est B
c'est pas seulement c'est qu'il a aussi
des manifestations la question que je te
pose c'est l'Europe au milieu de tout ça
où on est les pros de la réglementation
sur des trucs qu'on ninvente pas
l'intelligence artificielle on veut
réglementer on sait même pas ce que
c'est quand tu vois l'Europe se faire
dans les chiquier mondial se retrouver
entre les États-Unis qui produisent du
gaz de schiste AG gogo les Russes qui
vont forer un peu partout et qui veulent
l'Arctique AG gogo les Indiens qui
veulent consommer AG gogo et nous on est
au milieu on fait
voilà déconnez pas les gars il y a le
réchauffement climatique on a même plus
de parole diplomatique pour arrêter une
guerre qui a 2000 km de Paris ça c'est
autre chose pardon
d'accord est-ce que l'Europe avec sa la
main sur le cœur va arriver à faire
quelque chose pour le moment on est
surtout dans le blabla pardon encore une
fois pour le moment il y a une question
clé on dit le ner de la guerre c'est
l'argent et bien aujourd'hui on se donne
pas les moyens on fait du blabla le
climat c'est notre priorité la
réindustrialisation faut lter contre les
délocalisation on se donne pas les
moyens financièrement je le répète sur
les questions industrielles Joe Biden a
mis 369 milliards de subventions et pour
ça il a taxé les rachats d'action
peut-être que certains boursiers
n'étaient pas contents mais Joe Biden a
dit on va faire un peu de dette et puis
on va inventer une taxe voilà ça va
faire her certains mais Joe Biden a dit
autrefois le racheter les actions de son
entreprise cétait juste interdit c'est
juste de la spéculation on va pas
l'interdire on va le taxé il a mis une
taxe Biden pour financer sa politique
industrielle a mis une taxe à 1 % sur
les rachats d'actions ça va rapporter 70
milliards et puis maintenant comme elle
marche bien ils ont gueulé hein les les
actionnaires ont gueulé pendant 2
semaines donc ilil allait tuer
l'économie américaine que B mais elle
marche très bien cette taxe ça permet de
financer une vraie politique
industrielle on prend un peu 1 % au
rachat d'action quand total énergie dit
on sait plus quoi faire de notre fric
pour faire monter le cours des stock
option on va racheter des actions et ben
aux États-Unis il payent 1 % et et comme
ça marche maintenant Biden la mettre à 4
% c'estàdire que chez nous Bruno Le
Maire nous dit ah non pas de taxes Bruno
Le Maire ça lui va bien quand il
augmente de 10 % le prix de
l'électricité ce monsieur est très je
poli parce qu'on est filmé mais quand
Paron est sur sview Oui parceon est
sview mais c'est un scandale public
quand Bruno le mer dit qu'il ne veut pas
de taxes sur la spéculation au niveau
européen qu' ne veut pas de taxes sur
les rachats d'action mais qu'il augmente
de 10 % le prix de l'électricité je
rappelle que la Commission de régulation
de l'énergie avait dit bonne nouvelle au
1er février il n'y a pas besoin
d'augmenter le prix de l'électricité les
experts avaient dit on pourrait même
baisser un peu le prix de l'électricité
et c'est pour le maire qui a dit non on
va mettre une taxe de plus 10 %. donc
monsieur et madame tout le monde y
compris les retraités qui gagnent pas
bien leur vie y compris les les gens
très modestes vont payer 10 % de plus
pour de taxes sur l'électricité mais euh
Bruno Le Maire refuse la taxe de 01 %
que demande le Parlement sur les marchés
financiers ou ce qu'a fait Joe Biden
donc oui il faut une politique
industrielle et et je finis quand même
sur la Chine y compris les Chinois quand
même ils n'ont pas stoppé le charbon
effectivement mais ils investissent
beaucoup dans le photovoltaïque dans
l'hydroélectrique parce qu'il compris il
y a des gens qui disent on a la marque
que nos gosses crèvent avec des
bronchiolites parce que il y a le
problème du CO2 et du dglement
climatique mais aussi le problème des
particules fines qui font qu'il y avait
des milliers de jeunes Chinois qui
étaient malades et donc il y a eu des
manifestations la Chine n'est pas un
pays très démocratique c'est le MO qu'on
puisse dire mais le gouvernement chinois
a à conscience de l'urgence climatique
aussi pour ce que vous disez tout à
l'heure il y a des zones qui deviennent
inavitables quand il fait en même temps
chaud et humide je rappelle que quand il
fait chaud pour notre cerveau et pour
notre foie il faut pas dépasser les
37°grés ou 38°gr donc comment est-ce
qu'on fait quand il fait très chaud on
se met à l'ombre et on boit de l'eau et
on évapore et ça marche bien c'est comme
ça qu'on peut résister à la chaleur seul
problème si l'air est en même temps trop
chaud et trop humide comme dans une
étuve on narrive plus à évaporer et
toutes les études du MIT les Américains
montrent comment il y a des zones de la
Chine avec 300 millions d'habitants
l'Asie du sudest ou de l'Asie du Sud-Est
aussi et puis de la pinearab milliards
de personnes l'étude que j'ai vu sur le
M pardon parler d'une zone de la Chine
qui c'est 300 millions de gens et qui
dans 20 ans ou 25 ans il y aura assez
souvent des épisodes d' Tuves où les
gens auront le choix entre crever sur
place ou déménager et si c'est 30000
personnes on peut faire un déménagement
mais si c'est 300 millions c'est
compliqué voilà et donc les les chinois
ne sont pas stupides ils ont conscience
de de du réchauffement climatique même
la COP 21 avit l'accord de la COP 21
avait été facilité parce que juste avant
les dirigeants chinois et Obama avaient
signé un préaccord c'est pour ça qu'on a
eu l'accord derrière donc simplement il
y a une inertie du système il y a des
gens corrompus il y a c'est compliqué de
faire bouger les choses donc est-ce que
l'Europe a intérêt à montrer qu'on peut
avoir un modèle de prospérité avec
beaucoup moins de CO2 je pense que oui
et c'est pas pour se flagéler ou pour
donner des leçons au reste du monde on
peut vivre bien votre but mon but n'est
pas de dépenser le maximum de fric pour
chauffer notre maison votre but mon but
n'est pas forcément d'avoir une voiture
qui pollue beaucoup si on a des
transports en commun efficasse et quand
il y a besoin d'une voiture parce qu'on
est dans une zone où il y a pas de
transport en commun on aura une voiture
plus légère avec des énergies
renouvelables c'est pas forcément
dramatique d'avoir une vie plus
équilibrée est-ce que tu as vu des pots
catalytiques sur les tanks chinois non
tu as vu des PO catalytiques sur les
tanks américains j'ai pas vu pardon tu
as vu des des PO catalytiques sur les
tanks allemands franco-allemands ou je
suis pas spécialiste des poat pardon il
y a des domaines où je crois tu
comprends la blague oui c'estàd que on
on fait du milliard en armement pour
aller se taper pour aller chercher des
ressources on pourra apporter la
démocratie pour les petites filles ou
sauver les petits enfants ou tu
vois est-ce que tu te rappelles arrête
de dire pardon à chaque fois est-ce que
tu vois est-ce que tu vois
l'argumentaire tu te rappelles de
l'argumentaire de bouche pour aller
choper l'IRAC la démocratie pour les
petites filles le machin bouche n'est
pas un de mes héros ça je sais Charles
est-ce que tu peux rebondir sur ce que
ce qu'a dit Pierre concernant les zones
inhabitables l'augmentation de la
température les phénomènes d'étuves les
millions de personnes qui vont être
obligés de bouger des gamins qui se font
prendre dans des ravines les îles
Maldives qui tombent dans l'eau les quoi
les îles Maldives qui tombent dans l'eau
non elle tombent pas dans l'eau
c'estàdire que quand tu as une
augmentation du niveau de la mer quand
tu es un peu bas estce tu as vu c'était
une blague blag fait pas des blagues
comme ça le discours c'est des choses
imp bon je vais essayer de te répondre
tranquillement et sans méchané
l'avantage que j'ai dans cette pièce
c'est que je suis sans doute le plus
vieux et vous avez quel âge 59 ouis
ouais vous êteson moi j'ai 9 donc j'ai
déjà c'est pas un argument d'autorité
non c'est pas simplement un argument
j'ai déjà vu c'est un argument
d'expérience le vieux con donc j'ai eu
la grande chance de traverser la crise
de 73 74 j'ai eu la grande chance d'être
ami avec un homme tout à fait éminin aux
États-Unis qui s'appelait Jay Forester
qui était a eu deux fois la grande
médaille du Congrès aux États-Unis pour
ses
inventions et cet homme était absolument
persuadé en 73 74 que euh on allait vers
un désastre épouvantable que il y aur
par exemple il y a eu le grand bouquin
de Berard que la moitié de la population
indienne allait mourir parce qu'il
allaient pas pouvoir se nourrir ça a été
un immense succès de librairie il en a
vendu des dizaines de millions donc j'ai
déjà vu la précédente vague maltusienne
où on m'expliquait qu'on allait tous
mourir dans des souffrances affreuses et
qu'il
fallait donner les offrandes qu'il
fallait à la DS Gaia [__] avec des
grands prêtres qui seraient d'accord
pour intercéder auprès de la DS Gaia tu
as discuté avec des assureurs récemment
j'ai été au conseil de
score pendant 7 ans qui est quand même
et au conseil de score on était
parfaitement au courant des
catastrophes soi-disant il y a jamais eu
aussi peu pendant toute la période de GT
qui était C ans aussi peu de en quelle
année de machin d'origine il y a eu pas
mal d'inondation parce que les gens ont
bâti des maisons dans les endroits
quelle année c'est pas possible bon
c'était ça c arrêté il y a 4 5 ans
c'était dans les 7 ou 8 ans qui
précédent donc j'étais si je peux vous
dire un truc c'est
réassureur justement il fait très
attention mais j'ai pas besoin de
conseil j'étais au conseil vous allez
vous montrer la cour de Suiss mais je
sais pas d'où vous la sortez votre C de
suisser moi j'aiétéis au Conseil j'ai vu
j'ai vu ce que payit ce score pour les
primes et ce qui touchait j'ai vu ce qui
était la réassurance des catastrophes
naturelles et j'ai vu qu'elle baissait
depuis 30 ans non mais ça est-ce qu'on
pe ça pardon les assureurs disent au
contraire qu'il y a des zones qui ne
seront plus assurables maintenant pardon
je suis désolé mais en on n pas dans le
mêmeonde on dans le mêe je suis allé
dans le pcalé l'autre jour il y a des
paysans qui ont tout perdu à cause des
inondations il y avait une odeur
pestilenciel les trucs qui étaient en
train de pourrir ça voilà et d'acc qui
traînit dans les ruisseaux encore de
encore du Patos mais vous en avez pas
marre vu aussi un garagiste vous avez un
garagiste le pauvre garçon tout perdu à
Cuse de la monté des e ok donc il n'y a
pas de problème climatique c'est j'ai
bien fait de venir vous savez les
inondations ça existait tout le temps je
dis pas qu'il y a pas de pramme forê
vous voyez pas une petite évolution F de
forêt non vous êtes le seul mais c'est
une je suis vraiment content de vous
avoir rencontré il y a des milliers
scientifiqu' m'z pas la mil scientifique
il s'inquièent pour rien il y a des
milli ils sont tous ils sont tous payés
d'ailleurs pour pour ça parce que a des
bon on y reviendra non mais je voudrais
quand même vous m'avez pas laissé parler
vous m'avez vous m'avez pas laiss je
voudrais terminer sur tout ça parce
qu'il y a un certain nombre de trucs qui
doivent être dit ici c'est
que vous n'avez d'abord le CO2 personne
n'a prouvé que c'était un
grosse connerie là quand même non mais
c'est
le champion du monde je crois qu'on
prise le champion du
mondeie des sciences à l'unanimité dit
le contraire charlesas dire une grosse
l'Académie des Sciences à l'unanimité
dit que CO2 le
réchauement je suis trèsux de le savoir
parce que alors moi je nulle part vous
l'avez lu nulle part je
je l'Académie des Sciences à l'unanimité
c'est cadeau
gardez-le son
chapau mais c'est du délire qu'on
raconte je veux dire je veux dire ben
oui et ben l'Académie des Sciences elle
je sais pas qu'elle va se tromper je dis
pas ça je suis pas compétent etme mais
c'est ce qu' avait c'est ce qu' avait
c'est ce que disait ce bon kunounin qui
est quand même le gars qui est
responsable de la de tous les trucs de
modèle et c'est un vrai scientifique
j'ai reçu chez moi toute une série
scientifique le le professeur donc
Furfari qui ont des gens qui sont formés
là-dedans qui ont passé leur vie à
discuter des problèmes de climat et donc
je rencontre des tas il y a plus de TR
il y a une association je crois entre 3
et 5000 personnes scientifiques qui sont
disponibles dans le monde entier vous
pouvez vous inscrire pour expliquer que
c'est ce que c'est pas ce qu'on nous
raconte donc je reviens à mon monsieur
Forester qui était tout à fait
sympathique et il était absolument
persuadé que il y allait il y avait du
pétrole qu'enc pour les 10 ou 15 ans qui
viennent et qu'après on allait tous
mourir de froid dans la neige et puis on
a trouvé du pétrole on a trouvé du gaz
on a inventé des trucs donc ce que
j'essaie de dire c'est que le le type
qui dit
ça va mal il faut que le gouvernement
intervienne parce que sans ça on va tous
mourir et que la seule chose qu'il faut
faire c'est ralentir la vitesse à
laquelle on va mourir parce que on n
peut rien à l'allure où ça va je trouve
une idée intéressante mais pas
enthousiasmante on on peut ne pas mourir
hein avant de te donner la parole pierre
euh Charles est-ce que tu connais un
truc qui s'appelle le permafrost oui il
est peut-être en train de bah oui il est
peut-être en train de fondre oh c'est
pas grave grave s'il te
plaît pas par mais je sais pas si c'est
grave ou si c'est pas grave vous savez
pas que vous é un expert j'étais au
conseil pour le climat pardon je voulais
pas dit mais j'étais au conseil pour le
climat avant d'être député donc
peut-être que même Emmanuel Macron
trouvait que j'étais pas stupide ce que
je raconé n'était pas stup vous êtes pas
en train d'utiliser l'argument
d'autorité là que vous seriez compétent
je suis content de savoir que j'ai
quelqu'un de compétent à côté de moi non
mais l'argument d'autorité fortune si
j'avais une fortune ce qui n'est pas le
cas je vous ferai confiance pour gérer
des fortunes mais sur la question du
climat la question du climat
ok mais la question du climat en 2024
dire qu'on ne sait pas si un
réchauffement climatique vous av au
début en supposant c'était votre
première intervention en supposant qu'il
y a un réchauffement vous l'avez dit
pardon vous êtes filmé attention vous
êtes filmé j'ai dit en supposant qu'il a
un réchauffement il n'y a pas de
réchauffement à ma connaissance il n'y a
pas de réchauffement mais je peux me
tromper dans dans dans l'hémisphère sud
les glaciers ne reculent pas en
Argentine il se passe rien dans
l'hémisère Sud quand
même l'Antarctique l'Antarctique est en
train de croit de l'Antartique est en
train de crore ça c'est faux tout ça il
faux tout ça il faut c'est quoi ta s
tout ça il
faux mais
la tu sais je lis des trucs toute la
journée je souviens pas toujours du truc
mais l'Antarctique la masse de
l'Antarctique c'est accru c'est dévelopé
quelle année sur combien de temps sur
combien sur les 20ou par exemple la même
chose c'est faux on me disait il y a 10
an tous les pauvres ours blancs allent
mourir on sait plus qu fout des ours
blan les ours blan tu j'imagines sur
Google peut quelqu'un pourrait le
faireme pour les terrain en Ukraine
benah les terrain en Ukraine je sais que
Black Rock On a on a acheté un paquet ça
je le sais de sceurer tu vérifiera ta
source pour moi alors dis-moi
dis-moi
donc
Antarctique climat copernicus.u c'est
quoi cette source je sais pas que je
l'ai v de plein de sources d'accord donc
et donc qu'est-ce qu'elle dit cette
source on aimerait le savoir elle dit
elle dit quoi elle dit que en 2022 elle
a cru de euh ok je je suis content de
savoir que j'ai dit quelque chose de
faux avec mon voisin on peut regarder
sur 20 ans pardon on peut regarder sur
20 ans les volumes et la surface
revenons au
permafrost partons de l'hypothèse qu'il
y a un réchauffement tropique P tropique
mais F on s'en fout d'Ille a un
réchauffement très bien il y a des zones
qui sont en train de devenir inhabitable
il y a énormément de gens qui vivent
dans ces zones côtières où c'est en
train de devenir inhabitable quand
attends attends je t'arrête une seconde
la question est intéressante toutes les
périodes de développement dans
l'histoire c'était des périodes où la
température montée toutes les périodes
de des désastres des dépressions c'est
les périodes de glaciation donc si tu
veux le fait que la température monte
dans toutes les civilisation ça a
toujours été considéré ça va 50 fois
plus vite que le dernier réchauffement
aujourd'hui le réchauffement saz vous
étiez pas là de 19 pardon il y a des
gens qui mesurent il y a des gens qui
qui il y a des gens qui travaillent
là-dessus et moi je leur fait confiance
quand ils ont des centaines à travailler
pendant des années et qui vérifient
qu'il passe des soirées tout vérifier je
leur fais confiance mais moi j'uris lu
un bouquin qui était le type responsable
du climat à la NASA
donc il mesurait la température avec je
pas je suis désolé j'ai pas le titre du
bouquin j'ai pas le nom du gars parce
que c'était il y a quelques années donc
il disait simplement ben écoutez vous
avez aujourd'hui des endroits où la
température ne monte pas il y a des
endroit où ça monte on sait pas très
bien pourquoi il y a des endroits où ça
monte pas et une grosse partie de la
haute température serait simplement du
au fait à l'extension des villes
c'est-à-dire que vous allez mesurer la
température par exemple du côté de West
Point qui était tout à fait dans la
campagne au États-Unis là où il y avait
les écoles militaires américaines et
maintenant il y a toute une ville autour
donc la température est montée c'est le
même point donc encore une fois on a
constatait une hausse de la température
assez forte à partir du moment où
l'Union soviétique s'est écroulé parce
que tous les gars qui mesuraient la
température en Sibérie il remplissaient
plus les papiers donc on a fait la
moyenne on s'est trouvé dessus donc il y
a toute une série de scientifiques qui
me racontent des choses qui sont ce que
me raconé ce bon monsieur Forester et ce
que racontait le le bon herart aussi qui
a écrit tous ces bouquins donc ça fait
la deuxième fois dans ma vie que je vois
que quelques part tout va très mal on va
tous mourir et que heureusement il y a
des gens qui sont tout à fait compétents
et qui vont être chargés de distribuer
des tickets de rationnement on dit pas
qu'on va tous mourir on dit que si on ne
fait rien ça va finir très très mal
c'est c'est ce que disent tous les
millénaristes depuis 2000 ans je veux
dire c été les mouvements de la peste au
12e siècle c'est étonnant vous êtes en
train de dire que la science a rendu son
verdict et pas ce type qui est un vrai
scientifique pas un politique mais je
vois que l'ensemble de la je vais pas
réper pas l'ensemble vous êtes en train
de dire que la science a rendu son
verdict dit dans tout son bouquin il dit
ça n'est pas vrai donc vous avez tout ça
et c'est pour ça qu'il y a eu 6 mois de
débat à l'Académie des Sciences
françaises et qu'à la fin il y a eu à
l'unanimité donc y compris Claude
Allègre le texte voté par Claude Allègre
condamne le bouquin donc votre gars il a
peut-être fait un bouquin aussi Pipo ou
payé par Total ennergie ou par axon mais
si peut-être que oui on sait pas en tout
cas non mais en tout cas en tout cas le
l de
claa recher suxci gé plus c'est pour ça
cétait vraent choant c'est pour ça des
sentifiques sont énervés en disant Clère
vous êtes en
trainutiliser l'argument
d'autorité sque je dis il y a Desbat je
dis il y a des gens qui continuent à
débattre vous vous dites plus
av qui pens qu'on a fait une erreur en
donnant le droit de vote aux femmes mais
en principe non ça les femmes on une âme
et un cerveau ça n'est plus discuté par
la plart des G question à tous les deux
oui bien sûr est-ce que vous pensez que
vous donnez ou vous renvoyez une bonne
image de vous à vous chicorer le nez
comme ça je v simplement dire un truc
par tout ça je vais te dire un truc je
vais te laisser dire un truc pierre tu
penses arriver à convaincre JAC Jacques
Charles en lui envoyant des pics en le
faisant réagir des choses comme ça
est-ce que tu penses que c'est productif
pas des pics je lui montre que
l'Académie des Sciences à l'unanimité
pardon après 6 mois de débat après 6
mois d'audition à l'unanimité c'est pas
une pique écoute-moi non mais bien sûr
que c'est pas c'est pas une pique arrête
de lever les sourcils on dirait un
politique je fais ce que je peux avec
mes sourcils ils sont ils sont bloqués
depuis 2 he j'ai besoin de défendre mes
sourcil politique il n'est qu'un
politique je fais ce que je veux avec
mes sourcils c'est la liberté Charles
gaccord tu vas faire quelque chose avec
tes cheveux dans pas très longtemps donc
est-ce que tu penses que cette façon
très 21e siècle d'aller au débat se
faire des Vanes des bruits de bouche
c'est valable aussi pour toi Charles moi
je fais pas de bruit de bouche non tu
fais pas de bruit de bouche
est-ce que vous pensez l'un comme
l'autre qu'il y a moyen de trouver un
consensus de s'écouter et d'avancer en
som non il y a pas de consensus si qu'il
faut réduire il faut réduire la
pollution ça je suis tout à fait
d'accord réduire la pollution je suis
tout à fait d'accord char il est d'un ce
point de vue pierre tu es un peu plus
jeune oui mais c'est pas un problème
d'âge he il y a des gens qui ont est-ce
qu'en terme de Matth j'ai le droit
d'être gâteux
St 90 ans St nouvelle chose à mon je
vais encore vous garder une petite demi
maximum je voudrais que ça se termine
par chacun essaie d'écouter l'autre
pierre bosse comme un singli sur ce type
de question ça fait des années qu'on le
suit c'est pas le genre de mec qui a
raconter des conneries quand il VI
d'accord quand il vient ici avec toutes
ses sources c'est parce que ici il sait
que tu veux de l'eau si c'est possible
oh là là tuas une bouteille en plastique
qu c'est la même depuis un an c'est
bien c'est un
belle diversion c'est important de
s'écouter pourquoi on cherch à vous
faire venir parce qu'on sait
pertinemment vous avez des points de vu
diamétralement nous on aimerait vous
faire passer la chose suivante pourquoi
les choses n'avancent pas ou pas
suffisamment vite ou pas suffisamment
fort pas suffisamment respecter l'un
comme l'autre les gens ne savent plus
échanger ne savent plus écouter ne
savent plus être bienveillant ne savent
plus se tendre la main si tu sou
convaincre pierre mais j'ai pas le
moreesoir ça marche pas si Pierre tu
essayes de convaincre char ça marche ça
marche pas non plus mon but est de que
ceux et celles qui ont des doutes en
face se disent ben tiens les courses que
montrre Pierre elles sont toutes pardon
si vous voulez vérifier elles sont
toutes sur le site changer l'Europe non
mais c'est pour dire que mes chiffres
c'est pas moi qui les invente cace par
pardon mais voilà je ne cherche pas à
convaincre Charles Gave qui a priori ne
souhaite pas bouger mais je je non mais
je vous avez pas le droit de dire ça je
passe ma vie à changé je pas ça attendre
2 minutes c'est la bouteille d'eau qui
arrive voilà je veux juste que des gens
qui peuvent avoir de l'estime pour
Charles ga sur d'autres sujets se disent
ok sur le climat apparemment l'Académie
des chances a dit qu'il y a plus aucun
problème donc maintenant la question
c'est comment est-ce qu'on évite le mur
on aura je
pense on t mourir on va pas mais vous
citez un gars qui a fait un bouquin et
moi je vous dis l'ensemble des
scientifiques
françaisenez comment il s'appelle le
grand grand char laisse terminer non je
voudrais parler du Grand du Grand
comment il s'appelle pas climatologue
mais écolo danois là comment il
s'appelle qui avait fait
l'environnementaliste sceptique et
cetera il a une positionition que je
trouve très intéressante il dit dans le
fond ce débat est-ce qu'il réchauffement
climatique ou pas ça aucun intérêt ce
qu'il faut c'est essayer de maximiser
l'utilisation offici astucieuse de
l'énergie pour que les gens qui sont
dans la misère puissent avoir une
augmentation de leur niveau de vie qui
soit bonne et cetera et donc il propose
plutôt que de dépenser 1000 milliards
comme l'a fait l'euro pour faire des
moulins avant et
des et des des mirages solaires là il
propose de utiliser cet argent pour
économiser de façon certaine le CO2
qu'on libère par exemple les nouvelles
centrales à
charbon dont il ouvre je crois deux par
semaine en Chine utilise même pas 10 ne
rejette même pas 10 % de ce que rejetit
les anciennes qui faisaient il y a 10
ans donc il dit ce serait quand même
beaucoup plus intelligent si on mettait
ces nouvelles technologies sur toutes
les chandales à charbon du monde on
ferait baisser le le CO2 de 10 % dans le
monde entier automatiquement ça
s'arrêterait donc sortons je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec ce que vous dites
sortons de cette espèce de millénarisme
on va tous mourir heureuse mais grâce à
Dieu il y a les grands prêtres qui vont
arriver avec leur robe et leur clochett
pour réussir à Amadou et Gaia sortons de
ce mininarisme retournons vers la
science et trouvons des solutions pour
éliminer le CO2 dans la mesure du
possible dans la mesure et c'est ce que
c'est ce que font tous les gens
intelligents et j'ai pas besoin d'avoir
un gouvernement qui distribue des
tickets de rationnement tu pens que la
science et la technologie vous nous V
régle le problème que ça l' toujours
était le cas alors je signale que il y a
à peu près deux siècles j'avais un pote
ce ce brave ce brave Maltus qui était un
pasteur ce qui était en plus il faisait
un péché contre l'Esprit puisqu'il y en
avait pas assez pour tout le monde et
ben Maltus il s'attendait à parce que on
meurt tous de faim parce que la
progression agricole ne progressait que
de façon arythmétique tu parles de tes
potes tu parles de Matus tu parles de ce
que tu veux moi j'avais un pote feu
Jacques BLAMON fondateur du programme
spatial français un mec qui a envoyé des
ballons sur Vénus et qui a été rencontré
le pape pour essayer que les gens
mangent moins de viande qui biographie
qui était le biographe officiel de
Copernic d'accord il disait mon bureau
ou il disait la science et la
technologie vont pas nous sauver au
contraire de que au contraire il a le
droit de penser ça ça me gêne pas il
avait est-ce que tu peux donner la
parole à Pierre s'il te plaît moi je dis
simplement laissons faire les
scientifiques laissons faire le marché
faisons monter le prix de l'énergiequau
moment où les gens se seront de la
gaspiller et W donc les gilets jaunes
vous pensez que c'était des gros bonets
il faut augmenter le prix de l'énergie
vous venez dire faut augmenter le prix
de l'énergie on va augmenter le prix de
l'essence pour comme ça les gens vont
changer leur comportement non pardon
mais je vous venez de le dire dans mon
dans mon coin des Pyréné t' écouté dans
mon coin des Pyrénées il n'y a aucun
transport en commun donc pense que les
gens vont changer leur comportement en
augmentant le prix de l'énergie c'est
juste stupide il faut il y a un petit
problème de calendrier il faut d'abord
investir dans les transports en commun
et aussi inventer des voitures qui sont
moins lourdes et qui pourront avancer
avec des renouvelables mais dire que
c'est que le marché va régler le
problème vous c'est quand même un peu
paradoxal on va être gentil pour la fin
c'est un peu paradoxal vous dites en
même temps qu'il faut faire augmenter le
prix que le marché va tout régler
surtout aucune intervention mais on fait
augmenter le prix de l'énergie et bien
ça provoque une catastrophe si on n pas
fait d'abord les investissements je
essayer de répondre rép rapidement et la
rénovation thermique c'est une très
bonne idée on peut vivre très bien dans
une immeuble ou une maison qui a été
rénovée on a moins chaud l'été moins
froid l'hiver c'est plus confortable
construire en bois aujourd'hui on
pourrait ne plus construire en béton le
le bilan carbone du béton et du ciment
est catastrophique y compris un grand un
grand fabricant de pont me disait
l'autre jour je voyais le patron d'une
entreprise qui est très connue en France
je donnerai pas de nom qui fait des
ponts et je dis mais pourquoi est-ce
qu'on on peut faire maintenant des
immeubles toutalement en bois et le bois
il va stocker d'abord c'est beau c'est
agréable les ouvriers dis que c'est
agréable de travailler le bois beaucoup
mieux que le béton et la ferraille on
peut faire des meubles de 6 se étages
qui sont complètement en bois et ça va
stocker le CO2 pendant un siècle et
quand je dis ça un gars qui fait lui des
des il me dit mais même les ponts et les
les ouvrages d'art on peut les faire en
bois ou en bambou donc et c'est pas
vivre moins bien j'ai vécu à Hong Kong
et tout est fait en bambou et ben donc
pourquoi est-ce qu'on continue à vendre
à part le lobby du béton et le lobby de
du ciment pourquoi est-ce qu'on dit pas
que aujourd'hui on ne fait plus
d'immeuble en béton et en ciment et on
forme tout le monde à faire du bois
qu'est-ce que vous faites des anciens
immeubles en béton et en ciment mais
j'ai pas dit qu'il fallait détruire mais
je mais à qui ils appartiennent mais il
y a des pertes gigantesques qui vont
être prises mais non les nouveaux pardon
Nau on a arrêté l'amante il y a pas des
pertes dire on ne fait plus de laamante
on la FA des sciences est toujours fermé
hein pardon mais donc je je pense que
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas vivre mal on va
pas tous mourir justement le but est
d'éviter compris son Commentaire quoi
les répercussions du prix de
l'immobilier le mais j'ai j'ai pas dit
qu'on allait détruire les anciens
immeubles o qu'on a'ura plus le droit
d'habiter dans les immeubles tout
compagesassurance sont en faillite vous
nous avez dit tout à l'heure qu'il y
avait aucun problème avec les compagnies
d'assurance donc j'ai pas dit ça j'ai
dit j'ai que la la rassureur je voudrais
corriger quand vous dites une erreur ce
qui vous arrive fréquemment mais ça me
parle en autre chose mais là ce que j'ai
dit tranquillement c'est que le
réassureur n'a pas eu d'augmentation de
ses frais P toutes les années où j'étais
là au conseil je les ai pas vu et on
m'annonçait tous les ans qu'il y allait
avoir des tempêtes des tnades des trucs
des machins et les comptes de score ne
les ont jamais pris en compte puisque ça
ne s'est pas passé donc je vous dis ce
que j'ai vu moi en tant que réassureur
au Conseil où j'étais assis voilà c'est
tout ce que je dis et pour revenir
encore une fois à un truc qui me paraît
tout à fait essentiel c'est ce que dit
aussi ce brave Kunin qui est quand même
un spécialiste enfin au moins de la
mesure des choses hein je sais pas pas
un spécialiste du peut-être il est pas
un spécialiste climain mais il est un
grand spécialiste mondial de la mesure
des choses et alors sil dit quelque
chose de très intéressant dont on a
absolument pas parler aujourd'hui c'est
que par exemple la hausse des
températures en Amérique du Nord qui est
assez qui est en effet assez
considérable se passe simplement dans
les températures basses
c'est-à-dire qu' la be de faire - 40 au
nord du Canada là il fait 20 et donc la
moyenne monte mais il
dit pour l'instant la plus grande partie
de la hausse des températures se fait
par une augmentation des températur
chaleur on n pas entendu parler de don
de chaleur depuis quelques années qui
sont écrasants dans non oui ben
moi mais moi je sais pas moi j'allais
quand j'étais enfant dans la région de
Montpellier par là entre Nim et
Montpellier il faisait une chaleur
écrasante maintenant j'ai une maison à
VI
il fait plutôt moins chaud qu'à l'époque
peut-être une connerie mais je me
souviens des ét on est d'accord on est
d'accord tempérure dernièes été était
pas terrible c'était Pasok y a oui il y
a des fois où il pleut oui heureusement
oui mais personne ne peut contester le
fait qu'il a un réchauffement global qui
a de plus en plus de son de plus en plus
long avant d'être député j'étais donc
membre du Conseil j'avais été invité
pour un événement très intéressant
c'était la branche jeune de la FNSEA le
syndicat principal et c'était il y a 5
ans et leur événement de rentrée le
grand débat c'était que peut faire
l'Europe face au dérèglements climatiqu
faut arrêter de penser que les gens
n'ont pas conscience du problème et le
un des le numéro 3 du syndicat des
jeunes agriculteurs la bon je répète la
FNSEA disait ce débat était inimaginable
il y a 10 ans il y a 10 ans Claude
Allègre était notre héros et la plupart
d'entre nous on était climatosceptique
mais il disait il y a une évolution
complète des mentalités il disait
aujourd'hui il n'y a plus aucun
agriculteur qui est climatoosceptique
nos copains céréaliés ont perdu 30 % de
la récolte de blé à cause des
inondations il y a quelques années et
cette ané à cause des sécheresses on a
des amis qui vont tuer une partie du
troupeau parce que il y a plus d'herbe à
partir du mois de juillet à cause de la
sécheresse on doit donner du foin et on
aura pas de FO pour l'hiver donc on va
tuer une partie du troupeau donc ce chef
du syndicat des jeunes agriculteurs
disait il n'y a plus aucun
climatoseptique chez nous on a invité
Monsieur L rouurou parce qu'il nous il
propose un projet européen pour nous
aider financièrement à transformer nos
pratiques donc à quoi ça sert de nier le
fait qu'il y a un réchauffement et que
oui il y a de plus en plus de canicules
quand je suis allé dans le pas calé sign
le réchauffement en fait ah si si pardon
il nous a expliqué qu'il y a juste que
les températur les plus basses sont
moins basses mais qu'il n'y a pas de
chaleur plus importante ce monsieur a un
problème enfin Pierre pardon un problème
extraordinaire c'est que je cite mes
sources monsieur CIN qui est un
scientifique
reconnu et il me il attribue après à à
moi ce qu'a dit Monsieur CIN je cite
simplement des éléments d'information
pour les gens qui nous écoutent dont
j'espère qu'iltiront quelque
chose voilà et alors ce que je trouve
extraordinaire mais attendez c'est moi
qui parle par exemple il y a quelque
chose qui m'a paru absolument scandaleux
et là je vais être assez c'est que
France interre qui est une France
interminable comme dit un de mes amis
mais enfin France Inter
terre annoncé tranquillement qu'il ne pr
naccepterait jamais quelqu'un en débat
jamais qui n'irait la réalité du
réchauffement climatique mais qu'est-ce
qui leur donne le droit d'empêcher
quelqu'un qui n'est pas d'accord avec
eux de parler il a peut-être tort là
n'est pas la question donc donc si je
peux me permettre donc ce que je trouve
extraordinaire c'est tous ces grands
démocrates ils veulent empêcher les
autres de parler ils veulent j'ai le
droit de me tromper j'ai le droit de
dire que la terre est plate et je vous
emmerde j'essaie de dire tranquillement
j'ai le droit de parler et ce droit est
infiniment supérieur à l'argument
d'autorité quand on me dit que la
science a tranché et ben je dis je n
veuxrte est-ce que vous pensez qu'il y a
un lien entre les cancers et la
cigarette mais ça'arrête le sida
çaarrête pas le sida mais avec la
cigarette et le cigare vous avez jamais
eu de covid qu'est-ce qu'elle a été vot
position covid dites-moi est-ce que vous
avez recommandéation stratégie du fur
char covid je suis fumeur j'ai eu le
covid mais moi je fumis des cigares et
les fumurs de cigares il sont jamais COV
un exemple je te pose une ce que je à
dire c'est vous avez pas le droit de
d'empêcher les gens de dire ce qu'ils
pensent
personne s'il te plaît Charles sur
France Inter est-ce que tu as déjà vu
des émissions qui durent plus de 20
minutes 1 heure est-ce que tu
progam laisse-moi t'er s'il te plaît
imagine-toi tu inv vites un
climatosceptique mais il a pas le temps
de se faire contrecarrer ou
contreargumenter est-ce que tu penses
que ça peut planter des graines dans la
tête des gens qui serait peut-être pas
extraordinairement productive mais c'est
pas encore une fois onémission on
estil le but de la parole Charles
laisse-moi parler s'il plat là on est à
presque 3h mission ça fait beaucoup
et Pierre
contreargumente source à
l'appui avec des trucs don sour avec des
trucs costaud les gens vont aller
vérifier on a une plateforme de faccking
il pe con aussi d'accord tu vas te faire
fact checker aussi mais pour revenir sur
France interne ou ce que tu appelles
France donne le droit il y a pas
d'émissions suffisamment longue où les
gens peuvent prendre le temps où ils ont
peut-être pas la même commun te est-ce
que tu comprends leur position non mais
le c'est le vieil discours c'est que il
faut pas désespérer billanc cour mais au
contraire on va on va on va faire comme
ce bon SAR qui disait pas alors qu'il le
savait que l'Union soviétique était une
saloperie parce qu'il fallait pas
désespérer Bill encour laisser le peuple
décider laissez-le s'informer laissez-le
prendre s inform pe en dit qu'on qu'on
le peuple a compris l'urgence climatique
pardon justement la plupart des gens
combien les écol au vo il faut combien
les écol une a question pardon non mais
je suis pas sûr non mais pardon mais
aujourd'hui la plupart des gens ont
compris l'urgence climatique la question
est de savoir est-ce que une vraie
rénovation thermique aujourd'hui c'est
40000 € peut-être que vous vous pouvez
mettre 40000 € dans pour rénover votre
maison mais la plupart des gens ne
peuvent pas mettre 40000 € donc la
question est est-ce qu'il y a des aides
publiques c'est pour ça que je me bat au
niveau européen pour qu'il y ait une
taxe sur la spéculation pour que tout le
monde pe de Patos à nouveau les pauvres
gens qui peuvent pas mettre 40000 € donc
un peu de Patos encore et vous êtes sûr
qu'il est pas mort de faim dans la
maison en attendant les 40000 € vous
trouvez donc chacun se
débrouille débrouillereilos
j'ai mis du Patos quand j'ai demandé si
pouit avoir des aides pour rén courant
qu'en ce moment il y a des gens qui font
des arbitrages entre manger et chauffer
mais je sais arr faire Patos arrête fa
mais ça existe pas en
Suisse pourquoi ça existe en France il y
a aucun précaire ben en Suisse ils ont
décidé de mettre des milliards dans les
transports en commun voilà voilà ils ont
il y a eu des votations le peuple Suiss
n pas il a vous AZ en Suisse le SMIC est
4000 ben oui parce qu'il do il do payer
leur santé ils doivent payer leur santé
avec leur propre salaire nous cotisation
voilà on va pas on va pas épiloguer s C
an j'ai quel questions Internet une pour
Charles euh question concernant tu sais
si tu es pas d'accord tu te Barles là
question Internet est-ce que les
suffragettes auraient dû quitter le pays
au lieu de se battre pour le droit de
vote bah si vous voulez le droit de vote
c'est un accroissement de la liberté
donc moi je suis d'abord je sais pas ce
que j'aurais fait à l'époque maintenant
si je dis dans ma famille qu'il faut
supprimer le droit de vote aux femmes je
vais pas être populaire je vois pas
pourquoi je dis parce que je vois pas
pour pouront penser qu'elle votent plus
mal que les hommes donc ça me paraît une
question qui n'est nul et non avenu j'en
ai rien à [__] ça m'intéresse pas
c'est pas une question qui m'intéresse
parce que je d'abord je me la suis
jamais posé et puis je dis mais par
contre si on vous demande de faire
quelque chose qui est complètement
hostile à tout ce que vous croyez du
point de vue moral ben vous avez le
choix entre rester dans le pays et
accepter cette loi vous en allez et ça
c'est un choix que chacun a qui peut
exercer librement moi je vois pas le
problème qu'il a aller vivre dans le
pays d'à côté vous savez j'ai vécu 25
ans en Angleterre c'est pas faire
hein est-ce que tu crois à l'égalité des
chances mais je crois qu'à ça mais je
crois pas du tout à l'égalité des
résultats l'égalité des résultats c'est
une abomination je forcer les gens à
avoir le même résultat c'est une
abomination pierre euh qu'est-ce que la
création de valeur sans ressources
physiques mais il y a besoin de
ressources physiques pardon il y a
évidemment besoin de ressources répondre
la réunionit aigu c'est la création de
valeur je Charles qu'est-ce que la
création de valeur sans ressource
physique c'est simplement une invention
c'est le que l'homme a reçu ce don divin
de créer quelque chose qui n'existait
pas avant et qui existe après lui par
exemple l'invention c'est de passer de
la bougie à
l'ampoule ça change la nature de là et
donc ce pouvoir de créer quelque chose
qui n'existe pas il n'y a que l'homme
qui l' et donc tout l'effort de notre
civilisation doit être de faciliter
l'invention cour courant que entre la
bougie l'ampoule il y avait quand même
la graisse de baleine oui B ils ont tué
des tas de baleinees qui demandaient
rien à personne mais maintenant ell
reviennent d'ailleurs il compris c'est
est-ce que on peut faire confiance au
génie humain pour inventer un modèle de
prospérité où on vit bien avec moins de
CO2 estce qu'on peut faire confance j'ai
pas dit le contraire je dis simplement
je veux pas que ça soit imposé par
l'État mais qui a dit qu'il fallait
l'imposer par l'État bah c'est vous
toute la journée vous vouz vous voulez
filer des subventions les subventions ah
ben oui mais c'est a il y a quelqu'un
qui va les payer ces subvention tax sur
les marchés financiers oui ben ben alors
alors c'est une question tout le monde
pie de la TVA pardon tout le monde paye
de la TVA même les gens qui dorment dans
la rue ils vont payer fin pardon
aujourd'hui tout le monde paye de la TVA
quand j'ai acheté mon téléphone j'ai
payé 20 % de TVA et même un monsieur une
dame même un monsieur une dame qui vit
dans la rue va payer 5,5 % de TVA pour
s'acheter de quoi manger mais sur les
marchés financiers c'est 0,0 aujourd'hui
la TVA sur les marchés financiers en
France est à 0,0 donc c'est pas choquant
de demand demander 0,1 % si c'est
pour qui suite un horrible financier je
peux vous expliquer ce qui va se passer
si par exemple on
enlève si on met une taxe de 01 % sur
les transactions total à Paris et bien
toutes les transaction vont se passer à
New York ou à Singapour la réponse non
est-ce que tu penses que c'est un
chantage pas un chantage c'estement la
réalité est-ce que tu penses que que les
capitaux de Total soi détenus maintenant
par des étrangers ça me paraî évident à
partir du moment où on n pas de système
de retraite en France autre que par la
répartition logiquement il faudrait
bâtir derilleur l'une des grandes mes
grandes ambitions de ma vie je vais
peut-être le faire la semaine prochaine
d'ailleurs ça va commencer c'est que je
vais sans doute lancer une université de
l'épargne parce que mon ambition c'est
de rendre les Français Libres
individuellement et qui peuvent l'être
uniquement s'ils s'occupent de leur
pognon parce que s'ils s'attendent à ce
que l'État leur paye leur retraite ils
vont l'avoir bien dans le babas donc ce
que j'essaie de dire c'est je veux que
les gens prennent les décisions qui les
concernent sans être embêté par des gars
qui ont fait des études pierre est-ce
que tu penses que nos retraite on va
l'avoir dans le baba non si on peut
créer des emplois justement si on met le
paquet sur le climat on peut créer
900000 emplois avec le projet qu'on
défend on pourrait créer 900000 emplois
ça fait 900000 personnesent combien les
retraites à payer avec ta génération qui
va aller en retraite 16 % du PIB mais
pardant là je là je rendrai Charles
grave qui expliqué que malsus pensait
qu'on arriverait jamais à nourrir la
population humaine et on a fait des
gains de productivité qui font que même
aujourd'hui il y a que 2 % de la
population qui est agriculteur mais ils
arrivent à nourrir 100 % parce qu'on a
misé sur l'intelligence sur la
productivité peut-être qu'on a fait trop
de productivité dans l'agriculture et
donc financer les retraites c'est tout à
fait possible si on crée des emplois et
j'y reviens on peut créer 900000 emplois
avec un vrai plan climat tel qu'on le
propose et la semaine de 4 jours il y a
déjà 500 d'entreprises qui sont passées
à 4 jours 32 he on estime qu'on
mouvement général vers les 4 jours créit
1600000 emplois donc si tu fais le
paquet sur le climat et si tu passes à 4
jours tu as créé 2 milliion et demi
d'emplois c'est 2 millions et demi de
gens qui vont cotiser pour les casaes de
retraite c'est une façon très différente
d'équilibrer les retraites une façon
beaucoup plus
équilibré commentaire dis à ta fille de
faire moin de bruit commentaire euh je
bosse en Suisse il y a des camions sur
les autoroutes et même beaucoup j'ai pas
les chiffres mais c'est de l'infox
l'intox ce discours non pardon il y a
aucun doute que le frais de FERR pardon
on peut vérifier je dis pas j'ai pas dit
qu'il y avait plus aucun j'ai dit qu'il
y en a beaucoup moins et effectivement
tu les grands axes au dernier moment
évidemment les derniers kilomètres il
faut aller bien livrer voilà mais mais
pour la grande traversée nous on a des
milliers de camions qui font de Paris à
Lyon les grandes de Paris à Toulouse les
grandes traversées qu'en Suisse on les
met sur des trains et c'est très bien
organisé ne perd pas de temps il y a eu
un vrai travail intelligent et du coup
au lieu de faire 300 km d'affilé ils
sont sur un train et c'est beaucoup
mieux pour la planète et pour la
sécurité des camionneurs alors là c une
question qui était censé être pour
Charles mais je vais la poser à tous les
deux tiens donc Charles gaveav est
d'accord sur le constat de
l'augmentation de la température virgule
il est donc favorable aux politiques
visant à s'adapter intelligemment à la
hausse des températures
pointinrogation donc là là on se prend
un réchauffement 2 degrés donc 4 degrés
sur le continent c'est ça pierre je
parle sous ton il faut tout faire pour
éviter ça d'c mais là là on est sur la
route là mais ça dépend de ce qu'on fait
dans les prochaines années ouais non
mais il y a qu'un faucon alors fait non
mais si nous on fait et que la Chine et
l' ne font pas ça sert à rien la
question la question c'est là on
ralentit je suis d'accord avec toi on va
essayer de ralentir mais est-ce qu'il
faut pas déjà maintenant penser à
s'adapter évidemment il faut s'adapter
évidemment on dit aux Africains bon ok
bon ça va cramer chez vous on dit on dit
aux Asiatiques bon alors votre marché
d'immobilier il est cramé parce que vous
êtes obligé de migrer laisse-moi
terminer s'il te plaît vous avez tous
être obligé de migrer donc vous avez
deux solutions soit vous migrez soit
vous enterrez on leur dit ça tu penses
qu'ils vont me prendre donc il y a deux
et là il faut en même temps mais c'est
très jtile c'est très vivifiant
intellectuellement il faut en même temps
fa 3 He que je me tape vos provocations
là il faut limiter le plus possible le
CO2 le méthane voilà il faut c'est pas
la on va se prendre le mur on a
tellement déconné depuis 50 ans qu'on va
pas you laabou ça va pas bien se finir
mais c'est pas la même chose de se
prendre le mur si on est à 30 km/h et
qu'on a la ceinture et le airbag ou si
on continue à accélérer et qu'on se
prend le mur à 200 km/h sans la ceinture
c'est pas tout à fait la même chose
voilà donc le but c'est qu'on soit
plutôt à 30 km/h et qu'on a des
ceintures donc les agriculturs politique
sur les parechocs ou pas euh je j'allais
sentir une mauvaise BL sur pour une m
mais pas pour une donc pardon mais les
agriculteurs que j'ai rencontré dans le
calé ou ailleurs ils demandent ils ont
parlent tous spontanément du
réchauffement climatique ils ne savaient
pas que je m'intéressais à cette
question j'ai vu leurs émissions tous
ils disent avec le réchauffement
climatique le niveau de l'océan monte et
C ter du pas decalé elles sont un peu en
dessous du niveau de l'océan et quand il
pleut il pleut de plus en plus donc faut
arrêter de prendre les agriculteurs pour
des couillons ils ont tous conscience de
l'urgence climatique et ils demandent
deux choses qu'on les aide à transformer
leur pratique pour faire moins de CO2
moins de méthane et en même temps ils
sont pas stupides on va pas il y a pas
de baguette magique pour stopper
immédiatement le réchauffement
climatique donc il faut mettre en place
des politiques d'adaptation et c'est
valable aussi pour les pays du Sud
l'autre jour j'ai déjeunis avec
jan-louis borlot qui avait eu un grand
projet assez génial pour permettre
l'accès à l'électricité pour 80 % des
Africains enant il faut permettre un
développement économique de l'Afrique ça
sert à rien de verser des larmes de
crocodiles Sur les réfugiés qui qui
meurent dans la Méditerranée si on
permet pas un développement économique
et démocratique de l'Afrique y compris
avec une énergie non carbonée et borlow
avec un grand plan d'investissement et
certains lui l'ont saboté mais en
Afrique aussi il faut permettre un
développement avec beaucoup moins de CO2
et en même temps des politiques
d'adaptation poli adaptation c'est en
même temps la recherche agronomique
c'est d'autres d'autres bâtiments
d'autres modes de transport
euh est-ce que vous avez trois livres à
conseiller Charles gaveave moi je la sur
ce sujet est tout à fait spécial il y a
le livre donc de comment il s'appelle ce
danois l'économie
l'environalist sceptique vous savez
c'était il a écrit un deuxième bouquin
qui vient de sortir pour expliqué qu'il
faut prendre tout cet argent qu'on met
dans des projets qui n'ont ni que ni
tête pour essayer de transformer un
petit peu
la la façon dont on fait distribuer donc
il a le bouquin de Kunin que j'aime
beaucoup BN longbard BN longborg voilà
celui-là c'est le c'est c'est le premier
qui a été intéressant parce qu'il a
commencé à écrire là-dessus il y a plus
de 20 ans B lborg il a étit Yakounine et
si je
devais euh
il faut relire le bouquin qui avait été
publié par ce catastrophiste en série
qui a écrit dans les années
60 the population
explosion pour voir ce type était
professeur à Stanford les imbécilités
qu'un homme bien éduqué qui fait
conscience à la science expliquait que
il allait mourir TR entre 300 et 400
millions de personnes en Inde dans les
10 ans qui suivaient ça a été un BA
pe-être un peu trop en avant en avant
art il s'appelait non il était pas trop
en avance parce que depuis la population
de l'Inde a triplé et ils sont
exportateurs de produits agricoles donc
tout ce qu'il avait raconté c'était que
des conneries donc ce que j'essaie de
dire c'est qu'il faut lire aujourd'hui
les gens qui sont une approche
scientifique du problème comme Kunin et
comme John lborg et il faut lire les
imbécilités qu'écrivaient les gens qui
étaient partisant d'une approche
religieuse qui était on va t mourir nous
sommes dans la fin des temps pa Anne
annel cétait celui-là c'est le meilleur
de tous il a fait il a le record
des des d'interrogations par le Congrès
américain sur la fin du monde crois
qu'il en est à 18 non il a 92 ans il est
toujours là non mais toi tu es l'
retrait Charles mon cher ami comme je
l'ai dit tout à l'heure j'e ça m'a
tellement fait rigoler tout ce que j'ai
fait toute ma vie que je serai jamais à
la retraite et que je me poêle en
inventant et en trant des trucsnière
c'est pour moi le travail c'est une
bénédiction un dernier bouquin un
dernier bouquin Charles mon dernier
bouquin un un dernier bouquin un dernier
bouquin c'est le mien tiens qui paraît
très bien ça c'est interdit ça ça c'est
interdit mais ça sappelle la vérité vous
rendra libre c'est d'expliquer qu
éditions c'est c'est chez Pierre de
taayac qui est un spécialiste des
décisions militaires qui a bien voulu
prendre mon livre j'essaie simplement
d'expliquer que mon programme dans la
vie il est pas difficile c'est sui de
pompido hein mais c'est c'est d'emmerder
les Français et on a pas
on pas abord le desjets qu'on voula AB
on voulait AB la Chine plus en détail on
voulait aborder lesats-unis plus en
détail aborder la dette plus en détail
on voulait aborder tout
ça on revient la semaine prochaine char
non Mo je m je reviens tant vous voulez
tous les deux ensemble je suis tout à
fait d'accordis pas sû en vrai pourquoi
on verra on verra moi je suis tout à
fait mais si j'ai pas droit des
graphiques que c'est parole contre
parole c'est pas j'ai pas dit que pas je
suis tout fait d'accord pour regarder V
graphique mais moi j'en ai très beau que
je fais moimême vous faites même moi je
prends les les vrais chiffres mais moi
je prends les chiffres de l'OCDE donc je
l' fait pas je l'ai fait moimême je
jamais maquillé un graphique de ma vie
parce que ça c'est être complètement
antiscientifique j'ai jamais fait par
exemple le coup de la crossse de HCK
vous vous souvenez les grands
spécialistes qui nous expliquai que ça
montait tout àure la crossse de HCK et
qu'on allait tous crier et on s'est
rendu compte que c'était un faux qui
était fait par l'Université de Toronto
et que ça a été vous avez jamais entendu
parler la Cross de dans les ah ben ça a
été le grand le grand truc des
scientifiques j'ai eu quelques
graphiques pierre 3 bouquins un livre
qui de
un journaliste américain s'appelle
perdre la terre perdre la terre il est
passionnant je crois que c'est nathanel
je sais plus comment je suis fatigué et
qui du New York Times un grand journal
qui montre comment déjà en 78 en gros il
y avait un consensus de la plupart des
scientifiques américains sur le
réchauffement climatique na nathanel
riche voilà c'est ça perdre la terre et
qui montre comment les lobes de même que
les lobis du tabac avaient semmé le
doute peut-être que oui peut-être que
non mais on n'est pas sûr que le tabac
fait des cancers et on on a perdu mais
donc en 78 au début des années 80 il y
avait quasi consensus sur le fait qu'il
y avait un réchauffement et pas de
panique on a 20 ans pour sortir des
énergies carbonées mais ceux et celles
qui vendaient les énergies carbonées ont
tout fait pour retarder et du coup
aujourd'hui on est maintenant
aujourd'hui il a une urgence deuxème
livre c'est mon ami Jean jusel vous nous
aviez reçu il y a quelques temps Jean
était dans ce fauteuil on fait la bise
on fait la bise à Jean et à Brigitte il
a écrit un petit bouquin passionnant où
il raconte sa vie alors aussi à Valérie
massonmot et à Valérie Masson nmot on
fait la bise à toute la communauté à
Christophe Cassou et à tous ceux et
celles qui qui font avancer ces
convictions et qui bossent et donc Jean
Josel raconte un petit bouquin très
sympa où il raconte comment il est fils
d'agriculteur à Jané en Bretagne comment
il va passer son temps il y a pas encore
l'électricité à la ferme quand quand il
arrive comment il va passer son temps
avec les copains jouer au football
comment il commence à faire des études
scientifiques Claude Lorius le Claude
Lorius qui met un quelle moral à zéro
qui met un glaçon dans son whisky et
c'est à ce moment-là qui qu'il a le le
le déclic pour expliquer le le lien
entre CO2 et climat voilà donc ce petit
bouquin et de jean-jusel est passionnant
et puis comme Charles GAV a cité son son
prochain bouquin je vous conseille mon
prochain B alors le mien sort dans 2
jours sur pour montrer que les 4 jours
32h c'est possible sans baiss de Sala
interdit de faire ça sur Ben lui il l'a
fait donc il respecte pas les c'est
libéraux qui ne respectent pas les lois
on reprend le débat donc ou sinon vous
allez sur le site
changerleurope.com 32h 4 jours oui c'est
possible quelles éditions Le Seuil c'est
un petit bouquin à 5
édition je pense qu'il y a 1 centime je
suis même pas sûr Charles tu touches des
droits sur tes bouquins j'ai tout donné
des œuvres et Sin et sinon vous allez
sur le site changleurope.com si vous
voulez nous aider à faire gagner ces
idées je voudrais un conseil pour les
jeunes générations une bouteille à la
mer c'est toujours le même je réponds
toujours de la même façon cette question
je leur dis ne restez jamais dans un
endroit où vous ennuyez la vie est trop
courte si vous vous ennuyez vous sortez
au galop et si on vous dit que vous avez
pas touché votre retraite et tout vous
vous en foutez ce qui compte c'est
d'être libre et de faire ce qui vous
intéresse et le reste c'est n'importe
quoi et le but d'une éducation
c'est d'apprendre aux enfants à dire
non a fait une vidéo concernant ça
d'ailleurs c'est possible tu sais les
bonnes idées ça peut être partagé par
des types qui pensent mal çaun problème
ça Mo à quoi ça sert de dire ça Contin
ton conseil je pourrais te raconter des
histoires sur qui sont intéressantes non
mais pas aujourd'hui pas aujourd'hui tu
comprend je dis tu as terminé ton
question ton conseil pour les jeun
génération moi c'est simplement dire aux
gens ne vous ennuyez pas dans la vie
c'est génial vivre c'est génial ça
préserve làd on peut être d'accord si je
peuxs il a pas fini de boire ça préserve
d'être
libre mais la vie c'est curieux la vie
est une maladie sexuellement
transmissible qui se termine toujours
mal donc bien sûr que ça va mal se
terminer bien sûr c'est pas si ça
respecte l'équilibre mais si vous prenez
votre pied
occupez-vous de vous etz une
intéressante ne pensez pas à sauver la
planète on s'en fout rigolez soyez
égoïste marrez-vous faites du sport
éclatez-vous mais arrêtez de penser à
des trucs qui vous dépassent et pour
lequel vous pouvez rien et qu'est-ce
qu'on va transmettre aux générations
futures l'habilité de la capacité de se
marer c'est prodigieux ça la capacité
d'arrêter les emmerdeurs de nous
empêcher de vivre moi c'est tu t'es déjà
marré avec un [__] de coup soil dans
le dos avec un [__] de quoi coup de
soleil dans le dos oh ben tu sais moi je
suis blond aux yeux bleus j'ai vécu dans
un pays on crev ch toute la journée donc
le nez qui pelit les C de soleil sur le
dos joue au tennis avec j'ai de secondes
série donc je joue au tennis sur des
endroits où j'aurais pas dû jouer comme
dans les remparts de Bayonne la au fond
il fait ça qu50 à l'ombre j'étais obligé
de C der une balle qui m'avait rien
demandé donc grosso modo la vie c'est du
coup de PE extraordinaire si jeu quand
je serai enterré jeis avir la chanson de
Armstrong
parce qu'en ce poil c'est marrant il se
passe des trucs mais arrêtez de vous
plaindre rentrez dedans moi la France
est devenue un pays triste sinistre mais
marrez-vous faites des coups poêz-vous
donc ce que j'essaie de dire aux gens
c'est mais j'ai 80 ballets je continue à
TR chaque matin je me réveille en disant
qu'est-ce que je vais faire comme
connerie aujourd'hui est-ce que tu
comprends par exemple gretber qui va
faire la pauream c'est hor pas terminé
j'ai pas terminé c'est horrible la pre
est-ce que tu tu comprends Greta tonberg
qui va qui fait des choses qui manif
qu'elle qu'elle ve ça pas si elle prend
son pied là dedans c'est son problème
c'est pas le je dis pas qu'il faut faire
des trucs inutiles je dis faites des
choses qui vous intéressent si vous
intéresse et sauver la planète faites-le
c'est comme les c'est comme les les
types les végétariens il si veul bouffer
des graines je m'en fous mais Mang pas
des graines que des graines non ils
mangent pas que des graines mais sils
veulent si moi je veux pas bouffer des
graines qu'il me foutent bien la paix
donc je réclame ma liberté individuelle
point barre et je dis aux jeunes tant
que vous réclamez votre liberté
individuelle vous serez heureux sinon
vous serez malheureux comme des cailloux
et vous vous plainrez un conseil pour
les jeunes générations et la liberté
individuelle elle peut revenir d'une
action collective je me souvens la
dernière discussion que j'ai eu avec
Stéphan et celle quelques jours avant
que Stéphane meurt il était dans son lit
on a passé 1 heure et dem à parler de sa
vie et il disait il faut lutter contre
le découragement beaucoup de gens
pensent que c'est foutu qu'on va ver le
chaos le mélange de la crise sociale
crise climatique il dit il faut lutter
contre le découragement il faut se
rappeler on a connu des systèmes qui
étaient monstrueux on a connu
l'apartthide et on a connu la fin de
l'apthide on a connu le mur de Berlin et
la fin du mur et pardon et je oui oui et
j'ai cette photo moi derrière moi je la
montre partout c'est le mur de Berlin
quand j'étais étudiant à chciencep ça ne
rajunit pas mais c'était en avril 89 et
le plus grand spécialiste de l'Allemagne
nous disait le mur de Bernard est encore
là pendant 50 ans et si on avait attendu
les grands chefs gorbatchef ELM col le
mur serait encore là et quelques mois
plus tard alors que ce grand spécialiste
le mur de Bernin il est là inévitable il
est là pendant 50 ans ils l'ont fait
tomber parce qu'ils avaient envie d'être
heureux ils avaient envie d'être libre
et pas mal de jeunes sur cette photo on
voit que c'est des jeunes qui poussent
et c'est pas pour des trucs théoriques
c'est juste [__] j'ai envie d'être
heureux je n'ai qu'une vie et ce mur
fout en l'air ma liberté il m'empêche de
voir mes cousins mes cousines de l'autre
côté et donc en quelques mois il au
début ils étaient 30 ils étaient 3000
ils étaient 30000 ils ont fait tomber le
mur de Berlin aujourd'hui et ils ont été
heureux et donc c'est pas les grands
chefs si on attend que les grands chefs
bougent je vois bien comment le système
c'est pour ça nous qu' propose un
référendum pour faire un électrochoc au
niveau européen parce que les grands si
on fait confiance au grands chef pour
faire baisser les loyers pour lutter
contre le dagement climatique pour
améliorer la le bien-être social ça va
pas bouger tout seul donc je pense qu'il
faut et on peut prendre son pied
l'action collective elle peut être ça
peut être réjouissant de de réfléchir et
de travailler avec d'autres ça n'empêche
pas de se marrer on a qu'une vie on peut
faire la fête de temps en temps et mais
je pense que s'engager au lieu il y a
beaucoup de jeunes qui sont très très
inquiets et a 4 ans je rentre chez moi
et un de mes fils me dit papa est-ce
qu'on va faire un effondrement par
solostalgie oui non mais il y a de quoi
il y a de quoi flipper à part Charles
qui pense que le réchauffement
climatique n'est pas très grave il y a
beaucoup de gens quand même
qui voilà et donc je pense qu'au lieu de
se dire [__] c'est foutu la réponse
est non ça n'est pas foutu mais il faut
qu'on arrive à provoquer un sursaut et
ça passe par une action collective ça
peut passer par aller voter le 9 juin
est-ce qu'on continue avec la droite ou
est-ce qu'on continue avec des petites
rustines ou est-ce qu'on on est capable
de vraiment changer l'Europe donc il y a
le fait de voter mais l'action
associative l'action collective elle
permet de garder de de se faire des amis
de garder l'agnac et on peut avoir des
victoirees Charles pierre
mercici pl
[Musique]